those
most gracious sovereign we
your majesty's most beautiful and loyal
subjects the commons of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland
in parliament assembled
beg leave to offer our humble thanks to
your majesty for the gracious speech
which was addressed to both houses of
parliament
it's a great honor for me and for my
constituents in beverly in holderness to
propose the humble address and all the
more so in this platinum jubilee
to say that this packed chamber is
intimidating and creates a certain
amount of nerves i think we can all take
as red
we wish her majesty the best of health
and thank her for her seven decades of
service to this day
our majesty has demonstrated a
selflessness which puts the rest of us
perhaps not least in here to shame
the legislative agenda we are debating
today must be seen within the most
alarming of international contexts
russia's unprovoked
and unjustifiable attack on ukraine has
united the whole of this house in
condemnation
we stand together with our friends in
ukraine
and i congratulate the right honourable
gentleman the leader of the opposition
for his party's wholehearted backing of
the measures to support the ukrainians
we are providing mr speaker
rocket launchers complete with rockets
so different
so different from the trident submarines
that the arnold gentleman's party
previously proposed
[Laughter]
which were to have been built but you
will remember never armed
now no one in politics mr speaker minds
being senior
but equally no one wishes to be seen as
past it
yet today i fulfill the role of the old
duffer
i do
[Applause]
whose best days are behind him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
plays the part of the up and coming
talent
[Applause]
the chief whip certainly made the right
decision with the latter
but given my part today mr speaker i
thought i'd dispense some advice
both to those both to those seeking to
enter parliament
and
young thrusters
who are already here
many of whom elected as long as two
years ago
and you and you know who you
can't
are
that you're still not in the cabinet
mr speaker some of us are here for a
long time
some for a short time
and some according to our media friends
for a good time
so for the candidates my advice is keep
going and realize how much simply comes
down to luck
when i applied to beverly in holderness
conservative association
the senior officers had already decided
who they were going to have as their
candidate
none other than that then member of the
european parliament who wouldn't be able
to continue in that role
the now right honourable member for
scarborough and whitley
after i won that selection
two elderly lady members
congratulated me they told me they had
voted for me
and the first one said you spoke very
well mr stuart thank you i said
and the other one came in yes but robert
goodwill he was brilliant
[Laughter]
to which the other replied but he's got
a job already
[Laughter]
robert of course won selection in
scarborough he then went on to overturn
lori quinn's a three and a half thousand
majority and was i think along with my
honourable friend the member for shipley
the only conservative candidate in the
whole of the north of england to take a
seat from the labour party at that
election
the leader of the opposition must wish
it was so today
[Laughter]
instead the only thing opening up for
him in the north
is a police investigation
[Laughter]
no
some months some months after the
election i met a member of my
association's executive committee and he
actually congratulated me and said that
he was glad that i had been selected as
a candidate after all i thought at last
my hard work was being recognized and he
added because he said because you'd have
never won scarborough
my my constituency of beverly in
holderness comprises four towns beverly
hauncy within c and hedden and many
other hamlets and villages which are
dotted across east yorkshire it's a
beautiful part of the world and has
history as well as charm
beverly
has contributed more than most places to
the improvement of our democratic system
over the years
admittedly mr speaker chiefly by running
elections in such a corrupt manner that
the law had to be changed
[Laughter]
after the unseating of the victorious
candidate in 1727 by petition
his agents were imprisoned and paul
passed a whole new bribery act
but mr speaker beverly's notorious
freeman were not to be put off so easily
beverly continued to be a byword for
electoral malpractice
the novelist anthony trollope stood in
the liberal interest unsuccessfully in
1868 and such was the level of
wrongdoing that a royal commission was
established especially and a new law
passed
disenfranchising the town and barring it
from ever returning
[Laughter]
obviously the law did change
free beer and cash inducements were the
electoral um with the electoral contra
the electoral controversies then rather
than say
beer and curry today
never mr speaker never
in the history of human conflict
has so much karma
come from a corner
[Laughter]
i said i would provide some advice for
our up and coming parliamentarians
when i
when i when i arrived here i was just
about wise enough to uh
back the winner of the leadership
contest that summer david cameron
what i wasn't wise enough to do mr
speaker was stop telling him every way
in which i thought he was going wrong
and i do mean everywhere
which funnily enough resulted in an 11
year wait to be asked to go onto the
front bench
which only came when he'd step down
now it may be
that my right honourable friend the
member for maidenhead saw merit where
her predecessor did not
but more likely it was just that she'd
seen a lot less of me
[Laughter]
so lesson one for the up and coming
don't make an enemy of your party
but there is of course more to this
place than the front bench
in my first term community hospitals
were being clothed in swathes right
across the country
and all three in my constituency were
lined up for the chop
now having led marches and
demonstrations in all the towns across
my constituency it became obvious that
the problem would not be solved locally
so i set up a campaign group chart
community hospitals acting nationally
together
and along with my along with my deputy
chairman the then member for henley we
recruited colleagues from right across
this house we waged gorilla warfare on
labour's health department breaking the
record for the number of petitions
presented in one day in this house we
held a rally outside this place with
hundreds of people and banners and
placards galore
david david david cameron spoke labour
mps spoke
my deputy i remember gave a rousing
speech and
so carried away with the righteousness
of our cause call on everyone to join us
on a march to parliament square
so it was mr speaker that our now prime
minister found himself being intercepted
by a police inspector
who told him no permission existed for
such a march and that we must go back
so i think there are two lessons here
stop camp never stop campaigning for
what you believe in
and having marched your troops to the
top of the hill
never be afraid to march them down again
if circumstances
now when when the call did come i was
lucky enough to go into the whips office
the only communal playpen in westminster
aside from the crash
being there made me realize how little i
knew after 11 years here because as a
whip you learn a lot
so that's another lesson
join the whips office if you are asked
given my position i'd like to i'd like
to tell you that being in government i'd
like to tell you that being in
government isn't all it's cracked up to
be
but actually it is
i served both my right honourable friend
the member for north somerset and my
right honourable friend the member for
southwest norfolk as secretaries of
state for the department for
international trade
both were exceptional they were tireless
and demanding but delivered outcomes
from a new department which no one
thought was possible so
young thrusters
enjoy your any department you're in and
value it
for itself not just as a stepping stone
to something else
after all as i discovered last september
you never know when you'll prematurely
be on the back benches
[Laughter]
today today's queen's speech unveils a
substantial legislative program under
four main headings boosting economic
growth and helping with the cost of
living making our streets safer
funding the nhs and tackling the backlog
and providing leadership in troubled
times
to pick out one item if i may mr speaker
the energy bill is of particular
importance to my constituents it'll make
possible the development of hydrogen and
carbon capture and storage for which i
expect the humber not only to be a
national leader but actually a global
leader
taking us to net zero but also giving us
energy security and huge export
potential
so the conservative party party under
the leadership of my right honourable
friend the prime minister has work to do
we were elected to deliver our manifesto
and level up the united kingdom and that
is what we will do
despite the human weakness which is all
too present in this place
i believe nearly everyone here is in
politics for the right reasons
and that elected public service
continues to be a noble calling
so i hope that potential candidates from
all sides will continue to come forward
that young thrusters will show ambition
for their country as well as for
themselves
and that as we fire legislative bullets
at the challenges that face us
we will take aim
in this platinum jubilee year
and
like our ukrainian friends
saying with total conviction
god save the queen
i command the gracious speech to this
house
can i call fair jones to
second thank you mr speaker
it is a real honor to be asked to second
the gracious speech this afternoon and
an even greater one to follow my
honourable friend the member for beverly
and holderness his was a pitch perfect
speech an exemplar of how to do it and
one which i feel undermined his status
as a self-confessed old duffer
members with more experience than i have
have seen many state openings but this
year's is undoubtedly special
even despite her majesty's absence this
morning the platinum jubilee is a
lasting reminder of the queen's immense
devotion to duty
and i know everyone in this house wishes
her majesty a speedy recovery
now this time last year at last year's
queen speech i sat up in the gallery as
seats in this chamber were especially
limited because of the coveted
regulations and as i watched my good
friend the honourable member for south
ribble get to her feet
i remember thinking to myself
all the best fletch i wouldn't want to
be in your shoes right
but karma comes at you fast doesn't it
but unlike my northern friend i have the
honor of addressing a packed chamber
with faces free of the burden of face
masks
now as much as i loathed wearing a face
mask in the chamber they certainly
helped me by hiding the looks of
disinterest and abject boredom whenever
i got up to speed
so i'm afraid this year the cameras are
on so at least try and look as though
you're enjoying it
now i'm being asked to do this i turn to
some trusted friends and colleagues for
advice
they're right honourable
his instant reaction was oh my god love
you better be funny
the honourable member for the cities of
london and westminster told me i would
be a total mess
and even my dad a former member and my
inspiration in many ways
said after yesterday's rehearsal well
you're going to have to tell the jokes
better than
so that speaker that's actually better
feedback than he gave me at the start of
my political career at my count in 2019
the result had been declared and i took
to the podium to make my acceptance
speech
my mum was beaming in the front row and
i saw my dad move to the back of the
hall presumably to get a better view or
to take a photograph but just a minute
or so into my speech
dad had had enough and he gave me the
winded up signal
[Laughter]
so with friends like those
i ran straight for the warm embrace of
the house of commons library
there i discovered that i am the seventh
member from wales to have taken part in
the loyal address since 1874.
i am the first woman from wales
i'm the first conservative from wales
[Applause]
but i am very proud to say that my
constituents in brecken and bradleysha
have a long association with the loyal
address
in 1975 one of my predecessors tyrone
rodrick a senior figure in the labour
party proposed the speech
as members will know brecken and
ravnisha is two-thirds of the historic
county of paris
and so with a proposal and now a
seconder coming from the undisputed
better half of the county
i wonder how my honourable friend for
montgomery feels this afternoon
knowing that he is neither the has been
nor there will be
[Applause]
however that i have even been asked to
give this speech today is a surprise to
many most of all myself
i was always afraid that i had torpedoed
my political career long before it even
began
in 2005 when i was at university i
shared a flat with a friend who was
working on the campaign to make my right
honourable friend for haltom price and
howden the conservative party leader
it was suggested to myself and a few
friends
that wearing a pink t-shirt which said
it's dd for me
would go down a storm at party
conference
turns out it did
i'm sorry
so 14 years later when i was asked at my
selection meeting for breckenham
radishes have you ever done anything to
embarrass the conservative
i had to say yes
i was later asked what i had learned
from the incident
i said that i don't look good in pink
now today is a proud day for my
constituency and my family apart from
since in london for university and
working in europe i have lived my whole
life in wales raised in a firmly
conservative household
and i think being a conservative in
wales has helped me develop the thick
skin which i hope will get me through
today
certainly helped after last week's
results anyway
in 2019 my honorable friends the member
for wrexham honest man and i became the
first three women to be elected to the
conservative benches representing welsh
constitution
i like to think that the three of us
were worth the 100-year wait
but while we have some difficult
questions to answer and challenges to
meet on the treatment of women in this
place it is imperative that we do not
put anyone off becoming a member of
parliament
yes the house of commons is a strange
place to work and yes sometimes some
people don't realize that they are part
of the problem but despite that here is
a place where women achieve great things
it was a woman who introduced the autism
act the late and much missed across this
house member for chesham and amisham
it was a woman who delivered the
children's funeral fund and continues to
be a pain in the government's neck on
hormone replacement therapy
the member for swansea east who i'm
sorry to see is not in her place today
it was a woman who secured inclusion in
today's gracious speech that the
government will license pedicabs right
across the city
for the very first time no guessing no
prizes for who that was
and it was a woman long before my time
who stood up to the might of the unions
empowered council tenants to buy their
homes and 40 years ago this year
protected the falkland islands
it is important mr speaker that we say
today a woman's place is in the house of
commons
and by the way it was also a woman who
got 20 million quid out of the treasury
for the global centre of rail excellence
made cyber flashing a criminal offence
and got the mod to scrap the closure of
breck and barracks just saying
as much
as much as we must attract more women to
this place we must do our utmost to
attract wide-ranging talents so that our
benches are filled with the
plain-speaking common sense of the
honorable member for ashfield
the distinguished professional
experience of the member for newbury
and dare i even say it the political
diplomacy of the honourable member for
stoke-on-trent north
[Applause]
mr speaker
my liberal democrat opponents tell me
that all i do is talk about farming and
the military
so today i will keep them happy and do
exactly that
during my major speech i said i felt i
had won first prize in the lottery of
life by becoming the member for brecken
and radisher that's as true today as it
was then
it's a glorious part of the world
stretching from the upper swansea valley
to just outside ludlow
it is kept thriving by thousands of
farmers
not trusterian farmers who inherit their
wealth but the ordinary mud under the
fingernail grafting farmer who works
year-round to put food on our plates and
to give their kids a future
the cost of living crisis is having a
particular effect in rural areas
costs of fuel and fertiliser are
eye-watering and this presents a real
risk to our ability to feed ourselves
it is deeply tragic that it has taken
war in ukraine for us to focus on uk
food security
if i do anything in this place it will
be to bang on about the importance of
farming to this country
hence why i welcome the measures in the
gracious address which will see british
produce on tables around the world
and even the online safety bill which
will protect the unsuspecting farmer
from nefarious internet
[Laughter]
mr
videos
mr speaker if you walk down the water in
brecken as i know you have you will see
24 trees honoring 24th a foot
better known as the south wales
borderers who fought at the battle of
rorke's drift made iconic in the film
zulu
whether brecken barracks sunny bridge
training area or the navy's outdoor
leadership training center in talabant
my constituency is extremely proud of
its military footprint
we are also home to the cambrian patrol
the olympic gold medal in infantry
training a 60 kilometer march for teams
of eight over just 48 hours
now i know
he will be far too modest to tell you
himself
but the secretary of state for wales is
in fact a finisher of that event
so modest was he so keen to keep his
light under a bushel that when we
visited the cambrian patrol back in
october he brought his finisher
certificate along
and put it out on twitter
it was dated 1987.
i took great joy in pointing out that i
was two years old at the time
and great joy recounting it again now
over the years many wrongs have been
done to military veteran veterans and i
applaud the efforts of those right
across this house to correct that the
honourable member for barnsley central
has led his benches in that effort and
on this size my honourable friends from
plymouth more view and wrexham have
spoken for male and female veterans in
ways few can match
and so on behalf of the many veterans i
represent
particularly those who served in
northern ireland and tell me they have
been frightened of opening the post for
decades
i warmly welcome the inclusion of the
legacy bill in today's gracious speech
so mr speaker let me conclude my second
of the loyal address and give way to the
leader of the opposition i know we are
all delighted he has not cancelled this
afternoon speech
i warmly welcome it on behalf of my
constituents
today's queen's speech contains a
commitment to write the historic
imbalance that has pervaded this country
for too long and level up all four
corners of the united kingdom
it offers leadership in turbulent times
and looks to the long term ironing out
our challenges of food and energy
security and makes best use of our
newfound legislative freedoms
it helps this country stand tall on the
world stage as it has done for so long
and it is my honor to commend this
greatest speech to the house
[Applause]
[Music]
the question is that london will address
be presented to her majesty as follows
most gracious sovereign
we your majesty's most beautiful and
loyal subjects the commons of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland in parliament assembled
begged leave to offer our humble thanks
to your majesty for the gracious speech
which was addressed to both house of
parliament
i now call the right honourable kia
stammer the leader of the opposition
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
before i turn to the address
i want to thank his royal highness the
prince of wales for delivering the
address this morning
and i too want to pay tribute to her
majesty in the year have a platinum
jubilee
her dedication to britain has been a
reassuring constant in an ever-changing
world
her commitment to public duty a reminder
of the responsibilities we all owe each
other
her dignity and her leadership an
inspiration to all of us
she will forever have all of our thanks
for 70 years of service to our country
we all wish her well
i also want to congratulate the prime
minister
he's achieved a new first
the first resident of downing street to
be a constituent of a labour council
[Applause]
i'm sure they will serve him well
and i want to congratulate
mr speaker i want to congratulate the
mover and the second on their fine and
funny speeches
i understand that the member for beverly
and holdenness
owns over 900 copies of eagle comic
books he's no old duffer
he is an extensive collector of the
adventures of dan dare from the
inter-planet patrol
a comic a comic book with a hero with a
moral message
a spirit that he's channeled into his 17
years in this
house how you do it although there is
some mischief in him as he's just
demonstrated in his speech
i particularly liked his advice that you
should make an enemy of your party
leader
so i think he's a little bit more dennis
the menace myself
the member for brecken and radnesha
is
dedicated not only to obviously a
punishing consultation exercise on what
to put in the speech for today but also
a punishing exercise regime
a former cox with twickenham rowing club
a half marathon runner and even
an iron man competitor
maybe maybe
she's an iron lady in the making
[Music]
and i know that
if they were here
david amos and james brokenshire would
have been proud of both the mover and
the seconder
we all missed them both
and i know the pain on the conservative
benches is still raw
their friends taken too soon
but their passing leaves us united in
our resolve to defeat the evils of both
extremism
and cancer
i also want to pay tribute to my dear
friend jack dromey
jack picked fights on behalf of working
people
and he won them
in 1975 he led the first equal pay at
strike he campaigned for the rights of
cleaners everywhere from the house of
commons to mi5
and in the last year of his life
he campaigned for a public inquiry on
behalf of the families bereaved by covid
the only way that we on these benches
can really pay tribute to jack
is to aspire to champion working people
as well as he did
because mr speaker
times are hard
but they're much tougher than they
should be
as we emerge from the pandemic
find a new place in the world outside
the european union and transition to a
carbon neutral economy
our country faces great challenges
but at the same time great opportunities
are within our reach
we can rebuild stronger learning where
our society and our services need more
resilience
we can do more than just get brexit done
we can ensure britain is the best in the
best position to thrive outside of the
european union
and we can lead the world in zero carbon
industries generating high-skilled
high-wage jobs across the country
but mr speaker for that to happen
we need a government of the moment with
the ideas that make the aspirations of
the british public
this thin address
bereft of ideas or purpose
without a guiding principle
or a roadmap for delivery
shows just how far this government is
from that
too out of touch to meet the challenges
of the moment
too tired to grasp the opportunities of
the future
their time has passed
mr speaker the first great challenge our
country faces is the cost of living
crisis
inflation stands at seven percent and
rising
household bills have gone up by hundreds
of pounds
the cost of the weekly shop has rocketed
and people are seeing their wages run
out much earlier in the month
and the value of their savings fall
i wish i could say
that the worst is over
but last thursday the bank of england
revised down britain's growth
and revised up inflation
this government's failure to grow the
economy over a decade combined with its
inertia in the face of spiraling bills
means that we are staring down the
barrel of something we haven't seen in
decades
a stagflation crisis
it is a truly shocking legacy of this
government
it should humble those on the benches
opposite who've ignored the red lights
on our economy even whilst wages were
frozen for over a decade
and whose complacency is best summed up
by a prime minister whose response to
the crisis
was to make fun of those that were
worrying about inflation
a government of the moment would use the
great powers that it has to tackle this
head-on
bring forward an emergency budget
with a windfall tax a windfall tax for
oil and gas producers which would raise
billions
the money that could be used to slash
the cost of energy bills and help
businesses keep their costs down
even the bosses at bp don't agree
when the prime minister says it would
deter investment
it's a common sense solution
but instead
the government is bereft of leadership
the chancellor ruling the windfall tax
in
the business secretary ruling it out
and a prime minister who doesn't know
what he thinks
and it's not just about the short-term
measures a government of the moment
will take a step back from the crisis
and ensure that britain is never again
so vulnerable to a surge in
international prices forced to go cap in
hand from dictator to dictator looking
for a quick fix of imported oil
that means standing up to those vested
interests who oppose onshore wind
the cheapest and most reliable source of
electricity that we have
but this prime minister is too weak to
stand up to his back benches
and it means investing in the insulation
we need to use less energy in our homes
that would take 400 pounds off energy
bills every year
and cut gas imports by 15
but this prime minister is far too
concerned with vanity projects ever to
prioritize investment in insulating
homes
so we're left with an energy bill not up
to the moment it's the latest chapter in
a pathetic response to the cost of
living crisis
where there should have been support
it's been tax rise after tax rise on
working people
the only country in the g7 to do so
during a cost of living crisis
the low growth
that led to the stagnation we see today
is the same reason wages have been
frozen for so long
over 12 years of tory government the
economy has grown far slower than when
labor was in power
and it's set to go even slower in coming
years
the slowest growing economy in the g7
next year
as the director general of the cbi said
for a country that's used to growth of 2
to 2.5 percent the conservative record
is simply not good enough
mr speaker we can't afford to go on like
this
if if the tories
if the tories had simply matched
labour's record on growth in government
people would have had higher incomes
boosting public finances
and we could have spent 40 billion
pounds more on public services without
having to raise a single tax
so the second great challenge our
country faces is to get britain growing
again
a government of the moment would have
grasped the metal and set out a new
approach the economy
an approach based on a stronger
partnership between government and
businesses
a partnership dedicated to growth
there would have been an industrial
strategy to grow the industries of the
future
with the government providing initial
investment that brings confidence and
security
and acts as a catalyst for the private
sector to invest in gigafactories
hydrogen and steel
high productivity jobs
right here in britain
a government at the moment would finally
abolish business rates
and replace them with a fair system that
creates a level playing field with
online giants
so that our businesses can compete
invest and grow
and a government of the moment would
have a plan to revive our town centres
and new businesses
providing finance for a new generation
of startups in our town centres
giving councils the power to take over
empty shops
and fill the space with workshops and
offices in the jobs of the future
instead of that new approach to the
economy
we have a chancellor who thinks it would
be silly to do anything different
a chancellor who rather than partnering
with business has loaded them up with
debt and wonders why they're struggling
to invest
a chancellor who seems content
to have the slowest growth of any g20
country g20 bar one
russia
shocking a chancellor whose legacy will
be low growth
high inflation and high tax
and with it the diminishing of britain's
living standards
[Applause]
no hope of taking on the big challenges
no hope of seizing the great
opportunities
hopeless
and because they're not up to the
challenge of growing the economy all
those tax hikes
aren't going into improving public
services
no chance of a doctor's appointment
people forced to wait months for urgent
mental health treatment
supersized classrooms the norm again
never before
have people been asked to pay so much
for so little
and mr speaker
the third great challenge we face is
ending the poverty of ambition this
government has for our public services
that means a government of the moment
relentlessly focused on school
improvement
labour would improve leadership and
teaching standards at state schools
funding it by ending tax breaks for
private schools
it means a government at the moment that
would finally deliver world-class mental
health provision that matches years of
empty rhetoric on parity with physical
health
labor would hire new clinicians
so we can guarantee mental health
treatment in four weeks
paid for by closing loopholes to private
equity
firms instead
we have a government that went into the
pandemic with record waiting lists and
has got no plan to get them down anytime
soon
a government that takes the public for
falls by pretending
by pretending that refurbishing a
hospital
a wing of a hospital
is the same as building a new hospital
a government that can't hire the gps it
promised or the gps we have to see more
patients
lost in spin
no ambition not up to the challenge of
the moment
and it's not just education and health
that needs reform
fraud has become commonplace seven
million incidents a year
britain routinely ripped off
but the business secretary suggested it
doesn't even count as crime
but fraud is just the tip of the iceberg
victims are being let down whilst this
government lets violent criminals off
the overall charge rate stands at a
pathetic 5.8 percent
meaning that huge swathes of serious
offences like rape knife crime and theft
have effectively been decriminalised
a government of the moment would say
enough is enough
invest in community policing
pulling resources
nobody can be proud of this record of 12
years
invest in community policing pulling
resources away from vanity projects like
his ministerial yacht
it would strengthen protection for
victims of crime and anti-social
behavior and increase the number of
specialist rape units in the justice
system so that it stops routinely
failing women
instead we have a government that talks
tough whilst letting the justice system
fall apart
no care for victims or their communities
not good enough
not up to the moment
we have a government whose time has
passed a cabinet
out of ideas and out of energy
led by a prime minister who's entirely
out of touch
mr speaker it doesn't have to be this
way
it won't always be this way a labor
government would tackle the cost of
living crisis head-on
get britain growing again after 12 years
of failure
improve public services so they deliver
for people paying for them a labour gun
would rise to the moment
where this government has badly failed
thank you mr speaker
hi minister boris johnson
mr speaker
mr speaker and i need to join you and
members across this house in
thanking his royal highness the prince
of wales for delivering the gracious
speech
and in sending our warmest wishes to her
majesty the queen
the whole house knows the reluctance
with which her majesty made today's
decision
and her extraordinary service to this
nation continues to inspire us all
mr speaker as we come to the halfway
point of this parliament this country
has seen off the biggest challenge any
post-war government has faced
but the cost of the pandemic has been
huge with the biggest fall in output for
300 years than the destinated government
expenditure of 400 billion pounds and
the aftershocks are still being felt
across the world with a global spike in
energy prices the impact we're seeing on
the cost of food and it's precisely
because this government got the big
calls right and made the tough decisions
during the pandemic that we had the
fastest economic growth in the g7 last
year and we'll return to that status by
the way by 2024 mr speaker and therefore
have therefore have the fiscal firepower
to help families up and down the country
with all the pressures they face now and
we will continue to use all our
ingenuity and compassion for as long as
it takes
and my right home will offend the
chancellor and i will be saying more
about this in the days to come but at
the same time as we help people we need
the legislative firepower to fix the
underlying problems in energy supply in
housing in infrastructure and in skills
which are driving up costs for families
across the country
and this queen's speech takes those
issues head-on
and above all we're tackling the
economic challenges with the best
solution of all and that's an
ever-growing number of high-wage
high-skill
jobs mr speaker jobs jobs jobs and we
drive up employment
by creating the right platform for
business to invest making our streets
safer 20 000 more police creating a
healthier population fifty thousand more
nurses funding the nhs to help them
clear the covid backlogs and giving the
confidence that people know that they
will be looked after in old age by
fixing social care delivering gigabit
broadband giving the remote parts of the
country the access that they need and
using our brexit freedoms to enable
revolutionary technologies like gene
editing to help our farmers grow more
nutritious and more productive crops and
it's that combination of public and
private sector together that is tackling
unemployment with half a million people
more on the payroll now than before the
pandemic began and it is that strength
at home
that enables this country to show
leadership abroad as we have done and
will continue to do in supporting the
people of ukraine
so this queen's speech delivers on our
promises it will not only take us
through the aftershocks of kovid but
build the foundations for decades of
prosperity uniting and leveling up
across the country
mr speaker allow me to join the leader
of the opposition in paying tribute to
those colleagues we've lost in this
parliamentary session time
will not dim our shock at the despicable
murder
of sir david amos a friend of so many uh
who lost his life giving the service he
loved most a uh constituency surgery in
a local church
and among the many legacies of sir david
which include his amazing work on animal
welfare his campaign to support women
with endometriosis i'm proud to say that
today southend on sea stands as a city
in history
yesterday we
gathered at st margaret's church to
remember james brokenshire
a true gentleman who faced his battle
with cancer with enormous courage
generosity and strength of character
it was typical of our dear friend that
even in the midst of his own battle he
was supporting and encouraging others to
seek help
campaigning for better lung cancer
screening and becoming the first mp to
secure a debate on the issue on the
floor of this house we willed him to
pull through because the world needs
more people in public life like him
his loss is felt deeply on all sides of
this house and by all those whose lives
he touched finally we began the year by
joining the right honourable member for
camberwell and peckham
in paying tribute to her wonderful
husband jack dromey and one of the great
trade unionists of our time
who having married someone who would go
on to become in his words the
outstanding uh parliamentary feminist of
her generation will also be forever
remembered in his words as mr harriet
harman nader
we all knew him as a man of great warmth
energy and compassion and
he commanded the utmost respect
across this house
mr speaker the gracious speech was
magnificently proposed
self-deprecating i thought uh by my
honourable friend the member for beverly
and holdenness who's campaigning
brilliance i've seen it firsthand as he
pointed out when his backbenchers almost
20 years ago he and i organized a
demonstration against labour's plan to
close community hospitals it was called
chant community hospitals acting
nationally together and he his memory of
it is much more glorious than mine i
remember only a tiny handful of
desperados
and
we were stopped almost immediately by
the police
mr speaker uh who who
who who turned us back but we
nonetheless he nonetheless succeeded in
forcing the government to perform the
then labour government i should say to
stress to perform a u-turn on the
funding for community hospitals and uh
as a as a great pace bowler that i will
meet him based but i probably should say
he's a great a great medium place but he
bowled them uh middle stump uh mr
speaker and it's fitting that today he
is proposing the gracious speech for a
government that is delivering the
biggest nhs catch-up program in history
and far from closing hospitals building
new hospitals mr speaker 48 of them in
fact so we have the best health service
in the world i know by the way he has
experience of of healthcare in a less
fortunate country uh he was lying in bed
with a fractured rib after a skiing
accident in
chamonix
when three men in white coats arrived
claiming that they were there to perform
the operation
and on closer expression they turned out
to be the members for haltom price and
howden the member of sutton coalfield
and my honourable friend uh my noble
friend the lord lancaster uh which at
which point it is said uh that my
honorable friend levitated miraculously
from his bed and made his escape his
speech was in the finest traditions of
this house
i was delighted that the motion was
seconded by my honourable friend the
mepper for brecken and radisher
some more seasoned members will remember
the 14 years of service rendered to the
people of cardiff north by her father
gwen
who joins us i'm told in the gallery
today
delighted to see him there and i'm sure
he'll be filled with admiration a speech
just delivered by his daughter i also
know uh the honorable lady sadly lost
her mother earlier this year and i have
no doubt that she too will be simply
bursting uh with pride as she looks down
on us today
because while the honourable lady may
only have been an mp for a few short
years she has already established
herself as a fantastic campaigner
including ashley she said herself
changing the law to back
to ban cyber flashing
uh saving brecken barracks and with the
queen's dragoon guards securing the
return of a permanent welsh regiment in
wales
nor was she prepared to remain silent
while the leader of the opposition's
colleagues in cardiff tried to keep
wales in perpetual lockdown she is a
tireless advocate for welsh veterans in
the armed services generally an issue
that is personal as well as political
for her and as a fellow enthusiast for
dogs at polling stations i would like to
see her take nancy the labrador uh to
the polling stations on thursday nancy
is of course named in honor of nancy
astor a great conservative woman who
certainly left a mark on this place and
this country and whose influence and
achievements i'm quite sure the
honourable lady will emulate in the long
and successful career that clearly
awaits her it was a pleasure to hear
from her and i thank her for seconding
the motion
mr speaker on sunday i spoke to miss to
my g7 counterparts uh together with
president zielinski
urging our international partners to
join us in going further and faster in
supporting ukraine
and i'm sure the whole house will share
my sorrow and revulsion at events in
mario paul in eastern ukraine which has
endured weeks of merciless russian
bombardment and some of the worst
atrocities of the war
at the same time i'm pleased to report
that our brave ukrainian friends are
succeeding in repelling the russian
assault on kharkiv defending their
second city with the same fortitude that
saw putin's attack on their capital
we should be proud that when their very
survival the survival of great european
democracy was imperiled our united
kingdom has led the way providing
ukraine with the weapons to defend
itself and helping the world to impose
the toughest economic sanctions on
putin as i walked through the streets of
kiev last month i saw firsthand the
wholehearted support
what the wholehearted support of this
house in this country has meant to the
brave people of ukraine
so let the message
ring out from this chamber today we will
persevere in our support for the
ukrainians until putin has failed and
ukraine has won mr speaker
during the pandemic this government
worked night and day at extraordinary
speed to protect lives and livelihoods
across our whole united kingdom whether
by injecting 400 billion pounds of
direct support for the economy and
supporting jobs through our world
leaning furlough scheme becoming the
first country in the world to administer
an approved covid vaccine
or by delivering the largest testing
program and the fastest vaccine booster
campaign in europe
all of which allowed us to retreat
retain one of the most open economies
and societies across the continent which
we wouldn't have done by the way for
this
body office with the fastest growth in
the g7 last year now we will bring that
same urgency impatience and
determination to deliver on our mission
of getting our country back on track and
easing the burdens on families and
visitors across the land that's why
we've already committed 9.1 billion
pounds to assist with energy costs alone
we're giving back 150 pounds to people
in that council tax
cutting fuel duty
increasing the warm homes discount
creating no i haven't let me
increasing the warmth homes discount
creating a tax cut for 30 million
workers by raising the national
insurance threshold delivering the
biggest ever increase in the national
living wage worth an extra thousand
pounds a year for those working
full-time uh mr speaker but however
great our compassion and ingenuity we
cannot simply spend our way out of this
problem we need to grow out of this
problem by creating hundreds of
thousands
[Applause]
of new high-wage high-skill jobs across
the country and as i give way to the
lady opposite uh mr speaker i remind the
house that there has never been a labor
government that left office with
unemployment lower than when they came
can't just say it's not normal we do
give way but obviously the prime
minister rowan
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
prime minister for giving way we've
heard a lot of words very rapidly
delivered but what we haven't heard yet
is an apology an apology to the
pensioners that are choosing between
heating and eating an apology to the
children that have gone hungry
throughout school holidays and an
apology to the hundreds of thousands of
family members of covid victims that
were lost during the pandemic
mr speaker i of course this government
is doing absolutely all we can to help
people during the pandemic to help
pensioners and by the way it was this
government that introduced a triple lock
for pensioners uh to protect them uh
this government helps people uh with the
cost of eating uh the 9.1 billion pounds
that we're putting in uh the holiday
food act holiday activities and food
program that we put in mr speaker the
extra the extra billions that we're
putting in to support local councils but
but be in no doubt this is this is what
i think everybody in this country needs
to understand and what we are doing mr
speaker is making sure
making sure that we have a strong
economy with high-wage high-skilled jobs
that will enable us to take this country
forward and that would simply not have
been possible if she had listened to the
advice of her front bench who wanted to
keep us in lockdown mr speaker
that's absolutely true absolutely true
and it was worth giving away just to
make that point and mr speaker
and that's why we're going to continue
with our leveling up and our
regeneration bill which will help no
[Applause]
wherever people live in communities
across the whole of the united kingdom
that is the objective of this queen's
speech mr speaker it is all focused on
driving growth and jobs our schools and
higher education bills will ensure that
people have the skills to do them
raising standards in our classrooms
implementing the lifetime skills
guarantee so people can retrain and
acquire new qualifications at any stage
of their life and our energy bill will
power our power our new green industrial
revolution
[Applause]
creating hundreds of thousands of new
green jobs taking forward this
government's energy security strategy
and about time this country have what
had won uh with 22 billion pounds 20 22
bit mr speaker they they didn't want a
single nuclear power station
come on
be honest look at them look at them
great quivering jellies of indecision
that they are mr speaker
our 22 billion pound infrastructure bank
supporting the transition to net zero
vast new green industries in which our
united kingdom will once again lead the
world mr speaker just as we got brexit
done so with this queen speech we will
finish the job of unleashing the
benefits of brexit to grow our economy
to cut the cost of living and by
bringing the urgency and ambition to how
we exercise our freedoms that we have
regained our brexit freedoms bill will
enable us will enable us to amend or
replace any inherited eu law with
legislation in uk law that puts the
interests of british business first and
british families first and so that is
what we are going to do we're going to
seize the chance to make our united
kingdom the best regulated economy in
the world we're going to take forward
those trade deals we've got with 70
different countries
worth over 800 billion pounds a year
with specific legislation in this
queen's speech i hope i'm not speaking
too fast for the honourable
for our new free trade agreements with
australia and new zealand and while you
were using our new freedoms to control
our borders
with a new plan for immigration so we
can fix our broken asylum system tackle
illegal immigration
illegal immigration that undermines the
legal immigration that we support
crack down on the vile people smugglers
and i know that the leader of the
opposition or perhaps i should in
deference to his phrase i should refer
to him as the leader of the opposition
of the moment and mr speaker
the leader of the opposition of the
moment the leader of the opposition at
the moment likes to oppose these plans
or he claims he opposes them uh but it
turns out that legislation
no
legislation to permit the offshoring of
asylum seekers
only one of the
sorry privacy only one person can be
undefeated at the same time the prime
minister's not giving way prime minister
yes and mr speaker the leader of the
opposition of the moment uh purports to
oppose these plans claims to oppose
these facts but it turns out they were
actually pioneered in 2004 by a labour
government
the right of gentleman may have got tony
blair to take part in his election
campaign but it's a shame he cannot get
behind tony blair's policies mr speaker
during the pandemic we marveled at the
courage
and commitment of
so many people all the people working in
our public services from the
extraordinary men and women in our nhs
risking their lives to save others to
those toiling to keep our country going
whether in schools or shops or on public
transport so it is right mr speaker that
this government is now investing more in
our nhs than any other government in
history
giving our nhs the funding it needs to
help clear the cobit backlogs and we
will also make sure that every penny is
well spent so so whether through pop-up
clinics in our communities more
face-to-face gp appointments or new
cancer screening machines we maximize
the ability of our nhs to check and
treat its patients
but mr speaker when times are tough and
families are facing such pressures we
must also cut the cost of government and
cut the burdens that government faces on
taxpayers and on citizens
we can't have expensive delays in
delivering passports and and driving
licenses that see families stranded and
unable to go on a holiday
hgv drivers unable to transport goods
around this country
in the way that is so integral
yes so integral to the economy we need
we're going to fix it so
let me send a very clear message from
this house today this government will
not tackle the postcovid manana culture
we will take whatever steps are
necessary to deliver for the british
people because the british people are
not prepared to wait and we share their
impatience
mr speaker
mr speaker we will get through
the aftershocks
of kovid just as we got through kobe
as i've told you with every ounce of
ingenuity and compassion
and hard work not by irresponsible
spending that merely treats the symptoms
of rising prices while creating an ever
bigger problem for tomorrow but by
urgently pressing on with our mission to
create the high-wage high-skilled jobs
that will drive economic growth across
the united kingdom the whole united
kingdom that is the long-term
sustainable solution to ease the burden
on families and businesses that is the
way to get our country back on track
after the pandemic to unite and level up
across our whole country exactly as we
promised that is what this queen's
speech delivers and i commend it to the
house
i don't call
the leader of the snp in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker and can i
thank the duke of rossi for coming to
parliament today and leading us in the
state opening and
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
duke of rossi for coming to parliament
today for leading us in the state
opening with the address that we had and
to send
the best wishes from everyone across the
house and certainly from our own benches
to the queen and what is such a
momentous year for her
we also need to reflect on those that we
have sadly lost
over the course of the last session of
parliament and we think of james broken
show we think of david amos and of
course we think of jack romey three
outstanding but different
parliamentarians
all who
i think were a fine example to all of us
of how to conduct ourselves in in this
place
let me thank the
member for um beverly and holdenness for
his moving of the the motion this
afternoon on early night uh traffic
around his history in in government uh
and i hope he's still got a lot to to
give he's made it very clear that he was
removed early from office by the prime
minister and perhaps he still has some
some days ahead of him but i think it's
important that he stressed that the
the unity that there is in this house on
the topic of ukraine that we all stand
together
that we all stand together mr speaker
with our friends in ukraine
and standing up for the warmonger the
war criminal that still resides in
moscow he will face justice and we will
make sure that ultimately that the
people of ukraine
prevail but of course i thought it was
interesting that the the honourable
member told us that the recent
difficulties that the prime minister has
had with the
the metropolitan police there they are
not you he's had his court felt in the
in the past as well and let me let me
also thank the uh the second of the the
motion from brecken and radnensher um i
think really what we had was a was a job
application for for for government from
the
the member and i'm sure she'll have a a
long and fruitful career in front of her
as a member of this house and a member
of the the governing party
mr speaker
as much as i hate to rub salt into
wounds
this queen's speech has one very obvious
backdrop that deserves mention and
that's the democratic drubbing the prime
minister and his party got last year
and i know that they
might want to hide from that reality
but the message from people right across
these islands was crystal clear
the people made clear that this is now a
prime minister facing his final days in
office and a tory government that it's
on its last legs
and i'm proud to say mr speaker that
scotland sent the strongest message of
all
i understand this might be
uncomfortable listening for the opposite
benches but they need to hear it all the
same
because they need to hear what scottish
democracy is telling them and has been
telling them for years
last thursday mr speaker saw the best
ever result for pro-independence parties
in the local elections
the scottish national party is the
largest party and the largest number of
councils the greatest ever result in a
local election in our party's interest
this is mr speaker
the 11th election victory in a row for
the snp
and it's the eighth election in a row
that the snp has won under the
leadership of nicolas
mr speaker
a party in government
winning more votes
than winning more seats can you imagine
that prime minister no he can so
what about the conservatives down by a
hundred thousand votes and they lost 66
seats in scotland
and the worst news for all of them is
after all of that
they still kept their leader
so
democracy has spoken in scotland it's
spoken before and it will speak again
and again
and all our democratic decisions are
saying exactly the same thing
scotland rejects this westminster
government reject the tory party and we
are demanding
demanding the choice
of an independent future
because the
scottish people know the cost of living
with westminster
we know the price we pay with the prime
minister and the price of being stuck
with a tory government we didn't vote
for
and it's a price none of us in scotland
not one of us can afford to pay
any longer and at that i will give way
i thank the right honourable gentleman
for giving way and i'd like to ask him a
direct question how does it feel that
eight years after scotland so
conclusively said no at a separation
that the pro-independence parties are
still getting the same proportion of
votes as they achieved eight years ago
despite everything that's been thrown at
us and despite frankly everything that
we've thrown up after ourselves when
will the right honourable gentleman
admit that the game is up
well i have to i have to say to and i'm
going to call him my honourable friend
because i i i do enjoy his his company
but i have to say to him
if
if the game is up
if the game is up for anybody or any
party then the game is up for the tory
party
and the game is up for the union and i
and i say to him
i say to him
that he needs to reflect on the fact
that the snp has won the last 11
elections as i said
we went to the public
and we asked for a mandate to have a an
independence referendum
well
i i i i hear from a secondary position
we didn't get one
i would ask honourable members opposite
to the flight very carefully
because when we consider the first pass
to post elections firstly to the
scottish parliament last year we won 62
of the 73 seats and there is mr speaker
a pro-independence majority in the
scottish parliament and we're here in
the queen's speech today about
respecting democracy
why
are the scottish conservatives and those
in london denying democracy for the
people of scotland
how many times mr speaker
how many times
do the people of scotland have to let
the snp into government and westminster
says no what price democracy
what price democracy mr speaker
when this place ignores the sovereign
right and the will of the scottish
people yeah yeah and i will tell you
this
that a day of righteousness will come
for those that are seeking to frustrate
the rights of scots to have a referendum
because mr speaker that day will come
and that day will come and not only will
be a referendum
[Music]
thank you very much mr speaker does he
agree with me that the reason
that this shower of corrupt criminal
conservatives are blocking
scotland's rights scotland's democratic
and legal rights
to have a democratic mandate over their
own future is because they
[Music]
david davis
mr speaker it is in breach of this
house's regulations it is somebody
called
[Music]
i don't think i need any help
what i would say is we want moderate
and tolerant language that doesn't bring
this house or expect members outside to
copy the behavior i want good behavior
and i want moderate language i want
people to think before they speak in
blackfood no
thank you mr speaker and i agree with my
my honorable friend and i'll come i'll
come on to we don't want to get into
this
i will come on to these points in just a
second but let me let me let me say
respectfully to the in particular to the
member for west africa and from the
member from ban from buckland because i
think they know
that a referendum will come
and
let me take the
the warnings from the speaker about
behaviour in this house and how we
should all reflect on our behavior and
how we all interact with each other and
that goes right across the house and i
say that to
my friend from from edinburgh south
sitting on the labour front bench as
well
that when we have that referendum
it's implicit on all of us
that we engage constructively and let's
examine and by all means pull apart the
arguments for against scottish
independence
but let's treat
the electorate with respect
and let's trust the electorate
who have given the scottish government
that mandate
to have that
referendum
the most
you know i i hear what you did in 2014
you know point is
that the electorate are given a choice
in election to elect a government any
government that has a mandate for an
independence referendum and let's not
forget
that in 2014
we've explicitly told that if we stayed
in the united kingdom
that our rights as european citizens
would be respected
what did this house before what did this
house do to scotland this house took
scotland out of the european union
against its world and it's perfectly
right
under those circumstances mr speaker
that the people of scotland have got the
right to revisit whether or not they
wish to become independent i'm going to
make some progress the most glaring
omission in this queen's speech is a
complete lack of any immediate action to
help people with the biggest
inflationary crisis in 50 years
democracy spoke last thursday but it's
pretty evident that the government
hasn't listened and what we saw from the
prime minister today he certainly hasn't
learned because of course people turned
out last week to punish the prime
minister for the scandal of partygate
let's not forget
the public know
that this prime minister is the first
the only prime minister that has found
to have broken his own laws in office
and still sits here as prime minister
that should shame
this house as it shames us
but the electorate also turned out to
punish a prime minister and a chancellor
have been so consumed by the crisis of
partygate
that they've failed to lift a finger to
fight the tory made cost-of-living
crisis
mr speaker as the bank of england
confirmed last week
the occupants of number 10 and number 11
downing street have now led us
to the brink of recession
as my friend the member for glasgow
central has said the very first line of
the queen's speech should have been a
commitment to bring forward an emergency
budget where is it
where is it where's the emergency budget
that we need
an emergency budget to tackle now
the rising cost of energy of fuel under
food
thank you i'm grateful to him for giving
way would he agree with me that um it is
remarkable that for a government that
says it cares about the cost of living
crisis there was absolutely nothing new
in this queen's speech for example
around a mass home insulation program
which will be the cheapest most
effective fastest way of getting our
emissions down creating hundreds of
thousands of jobs uh tackling climate
emissions as well yet we've had nothing
new in this queen's speech on that at
all
my honourable friend is right there's
nothing in this queen's speech to deal
with the cost of living crisis nothing
to deal with with home insulation and
you know in the scottish parliament the
cooperation the collaboration between
the snp and the greens is an example
where two parties can come together to
make sure that we prioritize
the climate emergency something really
missing from this queen's speech today
mr speaker
scottish power have already called for
urgent action they have called for one
thousand pound bill discounts for 10
million families before energy bills
rocket by another 900 pounds the sorter
and yet once again nothing from the
prime minister and the chancellor in
this queen's speech in fact
the chancellor has already told us that
this strategy to tackle the cost of
living crisis is literally to sit in his
hands
because
because
he thinks it would be silly to act
silly to act
at a time that people are facing tough
decisions
and whether to turn the heating off
whether they can afford to put food on
the table
and the chancellor
the chancellor thinks that
that tells everything that we need to
know about the humanity and the
compassion of this conservative
government
and yet
just like the spring statement
nothing has come from this government
this queen's speech represents one more
missed opportunity
and i can give the prime minister some
suggestions they could have matched the
scottish child payment which doubled in
april and will increase to 25 pounds per
week per child by the end of this year
positive action to help those most in
need it could have matched the increase
in scottish issues social security
payments by six percent
it could have done what governments are
supposed to do in emergency
help people through it
by any measure or meaning
this government fails on all counts
mr speaker another gaping hole in this
program is when it comes to energy
policy as has already been raised as my
friend the
member for tomorrow in london
rightly said last month the prime
minister's energy strategy is nothing
more than a contract lacking any
substance or ambition the lack of
ambition to drive growth and green
investment and forge the path to net
zero not to mention an industrial
strategy to back it up fails this and
future generations that lack of ambition
won't help investment in renewables and
it won't help or just transition and it
certainly won't help consumers now or in
the long term
and as for us in scotland a country is
so rich in energy potential it is
fleecing us of our green present and
future on that point
mr speaker i thank you i remember for
giving way
his constituency and my constituency
border
the comedy firth which has the nigg
fabrication yard where many of the
mightiest platforms are production black
will north sea were constructed would it
not be a positive suggestion to her
majesty's government that we should
power ahead with building floating
offshore wind structures
in the highlands of scotland and that
would help the prime minister and it
would help us in scotland as well
i'm very grateful
for for that intervention and i and i
agree 100
with what he said in fact you and i have
been he and i have been talking about
that over the course of the recent
months that is fantastic potential
for the highlands and not just for the
highlands but for the whole of scotland
to benefit from the industrial
revolution that will come from the
opportunities in green energy
and mr speaker we need to make sure that
we learn from the lessons of the past
that we are able to capture that supply
chain
and if we go back to the 1970s nigg was
a thriving industrial base
thousands of jobs in that community
supporting the oil industry
and i know that my my honourable friend
like i
wants to see the highlands and islands
being a thriving area where there's an
industrial future for us but yes
absolutely we need the uk government to
to help us and i look forward to
together with my honourable friend
having discussions uh with with the
government and exactly how we how we
take that forward i can see the
secretary of state for scotland nodding
so perhaps we can we can discuss that to
discuss it over the coming days
since the start of this year alone
we know that the uk government has
profited by at least 1.7 billion pounds
from the revenues that have been brought
in from norsey oil
all that revenue from scotland's
resources and still
and still this uk government is refusing
to match the scottish government's 500
million pounds just transition fund to
help ease resilience on fossil fuels and
still mr speaker
no commitment to carbon capture and
storage in scotland's northeast
not only is this with the west
government westminster government
harming our planet they are holding
scotland back
i am genuinely grateful for the right
honourable gentleman for giving way
particularly on the scottish cluster
being so
important to my constituency and bam
from buchan i would
would he agree that the uk government
has thus far committed 41 million pounds
to that project but that wasn't what i
wanted to intervene on what i wanted to
intervene on was his mention of the 500
million pounds just transition fund for
the northeast scotland could he do what
his colleagues from uh kilmarnock
loudoun and aberdeen south haven't been
able to do this far and describe in
detail what is good that 500 million
pounds going to be spent on in the
northeast
let me let me just say to the honourable
gentleman that we've been short changed
on not getting carbon capture and
storage in scotland twice now we've been
promised it was it was coming and we all
know
we all know in scotland that getting
carbon capture and storage
in the northeast of scotland with the
acorn project it's absolutely
instrumental in getting to net zero by
2045 is absolutely instrumental
in making sure that grangemouth has a
green chemical future and there can be
no more dithering there could be no more
delay
and the acorn project must be greenlit
and it must be greenlit now now i'll say
to the honorable member that yes we will
spell out exactly the plan for that 500
million uh transition fund and i'll say
to them i'll say to the house now that
we will take our responsibilities on
these benches and together with my
friend from pomeranka london and my
friend from aberdeen south we will be
speaking more
on our future energy potential for
scotland because we will accept our
responsibilities to deliver that energy
strategy to deliver that industrial
policy which is lacking from those on
the government front bench
and of course
they won't cover mr speaker i've
concentrated on what the
legislation and this queen suite fails
to do in terms of attacking the cost of
living crisis and our dream future
but what the legislation does queen
speech does propose to enact is every
bit is harmful because
at the heart of the sessions programs
there's a twin track that needs to be
challenged an attack on devolution an
attack on human rights law
as the prime minister gets increasingly
vulnerable and desperate it is probably
no surprise that he's reached back for
the policy that got him the job in the
first place brexit
the brexit freedoms bill to repeal eu
retained law and the other brexit
legislation in his queen's speech
represent a race to the bottom on
standards
the very idea
that westminster will be able to strike
down devolved legislators retained eu
laws is the latest and only the latest
in the long line of tory power i mean
prime minister shakes his head but
that's the reality we've seen it over
the course of the last few years the
scottish parliament have the right to
retain eu law because we have the
opportunity and the right the right to
find our way back into the european
union
and we wouldn't be denied the right to
retain eu law and we won't be denied the
right to an independent future in europe
and the same applies to our human rights
laws
the proposal by this uk government to
rip up the human rights act is one more
example of a government that is prepared
to force through legislation that is not
only immoral
but internationally illegally the attack
on human rights legislation is all the
more concerning given the context of the
continuing failure to respond
compassionately compassionately and
comprehensively to the ongoing ukrainian
refugee crisis not to mention the
anti-refugee bill that was passed in the
previous session
the agenda of this westminster
government couldn't be clearer
a hostile environment to demolition to
human rights law and to refugees and
that agenda continues a pace in the
queen's speech on that point
i'm grateful to him for giving away
and both the government's independent
review of the human rights act and the
cross-party joint committee of human
rights have found that there's no click
there's no case no evidence base for
replacing the human rights act with a
british bill of rights so does he agree
with me that the only reason the
government are trying to do this
is because as long as the human rights
act is on the statute book it's a
serious threat to their project of
diminishing the accountability of the
executive
yeah
absolutely my my honorable learner
friend is absolutely correct and the
public should be very afraid as to what
this government's doing and the
consequences of that and to our
hard-fought and hard-won human rights
that have been built up over many
decades
mr speaker
i think the right of gentleman would
probably accept that i give a lot of
credence to the
human rights of british citizens
but the primary argument i've seen with
respect to the modification of the human
rights act is giving the government the
ability to deport
criminals foreign criminals who are then
who are being released from prison this
is an important right of a government
and surely that's worth having if
nothing else
well i'm afraid that that is a fig leaf
mr speaker for what exactly what is
going on which is the attack on the
rights that have been so hard fought and
won over the course of the last few
decades
all of this is the cost of living with
westminster and it's exactly mr speaker
why scotland wants out so just as i'm
gonna have to make progress so just just
as this queen speech seeks to and you
know i hear i hear scotland doesn't want
out
it doesn't work
you know and i i i really i'm not and i
i hope he last looked like he rises
at some point the queen's speech debate
and tries to defend her because because
what i'll say to the honourable
gentleman i'd say to the prime minister
is we've got the mandate for an
independence referendum if he doesn't if
he doesn't think if he doesn't think
that we're going to win it let's bring
it on and have the referendum
i'll tell you what you'll soon find that
scotland will vote for for independence
so just as this queen speech seeks to
entrance brexit britain our scottish
parliament will bring forward
legislation to offer a very different
future to our people a positive and
progressive future at the heart of
europe and we're not seeking the prime
minister's permission
the only permission that we need you
know anyway
the prime minister just couldn't care
less
because he's sitting talking to his
friends on the government front bench
that's the that's the that's the disdain
that's the disdain that we see for the
people in scotland from this government
they simply couldn't care less
so we're not seeking the prime
minister's permission the only
permission we need the only permission
we will ever need is the democratic
permission of the scottish people
[Applause]
but it's the people of scotland who hold
sovereignty and he might want to listen
to this because let's not forget the
legal opinion in the case of mccormick
versus the crown at the court of session
in 1953 when lord cooper stated that the
principle of the unlimited sovereignty
of parliament is a distinctly english
principle that has no counterpart in
scottish constitution
it is mr speaker unquestionably the
right of those in scotland to determine
their own future those rights were
enshrined in the claim of right that was
so instrumental in delivering our
devolved parliament and is the case
today as we seek to exercise our rights
in an independence referendum let me
remind the words
to the prime minister of parnell who
used to sit on these very benches no man
has the right to fix the boundary of the
march of a nation
no man
has the right to say to his country thus
far shall go and no further mr speaker
time and time again the people of
scotland have spoken
and they want a choice
the choice to choose our own future
they spoke in the last hollywood
election and they spoke again last
thursday
and the longer that scottish democracy
speaks the louder it will get
if the conservatives want to stand in
the way
if they want to try and deny democracy
then they should well be warned
democracy will sweep them away
just as their party was swept away last
week
thank god for that
i don't come to the father house
peter bottomley
can i say to the
parliamentary leader of the snp
it's a delight to follow him sometimes
it's more of a delight to precede him
today
i might just remind him that
the electorate don't always vote in the
same numbers the same way
in
between 2010
and 2015
the snp vote went up
the snp vote went up after they lost the
referendum
by 2017 their vote had gone down by
about 26
i think it's worthwhile looking through
his notes some of which he gave us this
afternoon
to check how the figures change and they
may change again
i won't at the moment i
only talk about his speech at the moment
start talking about mine that's right
i think that um
nothing i can say need to tame the
leader of the house there's a prime
minister or they leave the opposition
they want to go off they know they've
had hard days but what i want to say is
that
i'm concerned about people's home lives
two small changes to park home owners
will make a great deal of difference
in 2010 the then housing minister said
there'll be
park home reform we haven't had it
we need to change from rpi to cpi pitch
fees
that could be incorporated in the next
finance bill and i hope that that will
be happening here the second
is the question of commissions
why should those who are park home
residents have to lose a significant
part of the value of their home when
they sell it
those two things can be changed quite
simply second probably by a handout bill
there are plenty of mps who may come up
in the ballot i haven't come up with
four six years um who take that forward
but the rpi cpi one is one which
government can do quite easily
in the notes to the queen's speech and i
can
thank the government for giving us
copious notes on
the proposals in the queen's speech
we learned that the number of social
tenants
is about four million
and the number of leasehold tenants
private sector pipelines about four
million leases
private ones social and
leaseholders about 4.6 million
and the fastest growing
proportion of home occupation
are leaseholders
we won't get decent information from the
last census
because the only choices people put down
because they owned their home
or they were a tenant
and when i asked people what a leasehold
should say
i wasn't given a clear answer
people think they own them they might
have said i own them they're wrong
they put down a tenant they might fall
i'm not actually i'm a leaseholder
why the people who compiled that census
question couldn't actually wake up to
the fact there are 4.6 million
households actually probably about 6
million to be
complete but let's take the 4.6 million
why do we have
uh officer national statistics
and our department of now it's now
leveling up allowing a question which
doesn't allow accurate answers and
totals to be given
then on leasehold
the department of housing leveling up
over the years has commissioned the law
commission to make reports on what would
make life easier fairer and cheaper
we haven't had that legislation put
forward there are words about how
something will happen in this parliament
we know that uncontroversial legislation
often comes into the last expected year
of a parliament and often can be lost if
the election comes early
let's assume the election is likely to
come in may 2024
will those 4.6 million leaseholders
still be left hanging
on the chance of the legislation not
getting through both houses of
parliament when it's been proposed i
asked the government to try to make sure
that they get that legislation ready for
the next session and get it through
early as a priority i suspect they could
start in the house of lords and get it
through the house comes fast rather than
having the controversial stuff starting
here
i've spent about 15 years
following others who are doing for
longer and trying to get justice for
leaseholders the number of crooks in the
field number exploiters and other
heartless people sort of people who one
could use parliamentary privilege on
quite justifiably
need to be held back and the ordinary
people need to be held brought forward
we heard in the debates on the building
safety bill how many of you were stuck
and how government eventually came
around to making changes which are very
welcome
i mean on the fire safety defects we
know we have to find the problems fix
the problems fund the problems and then
get the money back from those who
haven't yet
coughed up
i want to turn lastly if i may just to
planning
someone who started a petition
parliamentary petition number 61113
about banning development on farmland
that petition has been signed already
the last week by over 700 of my own
constituents let alone the many others
the person who wrote to me is not
actually one of my constituents said a
migrating bird coming to the south coast
might start thinking i've got to the
coast i can rest if you have a solid
wall of housing between the south coast
and south downs they've got to go on
miles more that shouldn't be happening
and i put this particular plea through
the prime minister to the secretary of
state for leveling up
on the planning appeal
sorry the appeal against the planning
decision
for a judicial review granted by the
high court in the last few days
where the department leveling up had one
inspector who was about to approve the
protection of the goring gap chats more
farm
between goring and ferring in the eighth
one in worthing one in uh
aaron district council
that inspector was about to approve the
protection this area when a second
inspector much to everyone's surprise
allowed the building of over 400 homes
on one of the very few agricultural
fields between the south downs and the
coast on the west side of worthing
that decision is now
to be heard in the high court
i ask the government to decide they will
not oppose the application of judicial
review not oppose
the overturning decision
cancel the decision or at least let the
court cancel it and say they will never
again allow two inspectors to play toss
a coin for development of major farmland
in one of the very few areas in a
built-up area
i i would say that if we want local
democracy
we need to trust local councils but even
if we can't trust local councils i've
tried to do
we can't trust a department inspectorate
which allows two inspectors
to make decisions which are incompatible
with each other's responsibilities
i know
that the political success of the labour
party in worthing will lead to a new
leader of the council but i'm delighted
that the present leader of the labour
group on the council came to the goring
gap at my invitation to make a speech in
favor of asking government to solve this
problem i hope to leave the opposition
who's visited on a couple of times once
telling people another time not telling
people who's coming i'm not telling you
don't mind not telling me
he didn't even tell the labour party he
was coming he wanted the photograph but
things have changed since then
let's let's hope the government can see
sense and protect the goring gap the
chasm farm and local democracy
dave mengelia thank you very much mr
speaker
mr speaker we've got finally the queen's
speech
30 bills
and what the prime minister calls fiscal
firepower
well i can't see that fiscal higher
power in what's being done to support
our constituents and i fear that many of
these 30 bills are like so many of
recent government policies
mere headlines or worse dog whistle
headlines that appeal to a certain
section
of our electorate but do nothing to
solve the real problems that our
constituents face
i should declare at the outset uh mr
speaker um that i am a leaseholder in a
property that is having cladding removed
and i concur completely with the
honourable member for westworthing about
the challenges for that group of people
and for leaseholders more generally um
and it is disappointing that we still
have so much work to be done on
leasehold reform
but in hackney south and shoreditch as
in many constituencies up and down the
country
we need real support for the people
who've been left behind
in my constituency
we see a huge challenge with one in two
children living in poverty after housing
costs are taken into account
and in london we know that sixty percent
of households in poverty are working
households that's an increase from 44
only a few years ago and it's a
reflection of the low pay
that too many workers are paid
and the high housing costs in
constituencies like mine
so
we all know that employment is a huge
opportunity but it is not a route out of
poverty on its own for many people in
london because of these high living
costs
and that cost of living crisis is not
just hitting those in constituencies
like mine with those high prices but
biting everybody biting now those who
are just about managing those who are on
good incomes but hitting huge increases
to their fuel bills and we know the
government's response to that has been
from the clanner chancellor pay lend the
money now and people have to pay that
later further indebting particularly the
poorest households
so we need much better support for those
left behind and the government talks
about leveling up but
in hackney we don't see much of this
leveling up fund we are the seventh most
deprived local authority area in the
country but in the government's approach
to levelling up
hackney current says priority too
and yet
constituencies like richmond shire
derbyshire dales and high peak which are
respectively the 256th
the
265th and the 202nd most deprived
constituencies in the country are being
prioritized over those children in my
constituency living in poverty living in
overcrowded conditions often too often
sharing a bed with a parent up to the
age of early teens because there is
nowhere else for them to sleep
and struggling because of the challenges
of the pandemic they need support and we
must make sure and this government needs
to hear that leveling up isn't just
about leveling up in between different
regions of the uk but in parts of london
within our amazing capital city and of
all people the prime minister who have
the honor the honor of serving as the
elected mayor of london should be aware
of that and it is a shame on him that he
is not tackling this head-on
we need much better support mr speaker
for
housing generally i have more private
renters in my constituency than i have
homeowners and more social housing
tenants than both of those combined and
all have real problems and the
government is finally unveiling its
renters reform bill something that we're
all keen to see
but just abolishing no fault evictions
isn't enough to solve the challenges of
where people can live you cannot live
now in the private sector and grow a
family because even with no fault
evictions being abolished if that does
eventually happen it doesn't make it a
stable home with rents escalating at the
whim of the landlord um i give way to
the honourable jedi
very grateful mr speaker
doesn't she understand that this
gracious speech is all about leveling up
and giving people more opportunity and
there needs to be a surge of private
investment into these places with better
paid jobs and better skills trading and
better education that is the whole point
of it and will she support that
[Applause]
mr speaker if that's the whole point of
it forgive me but i can't see that i
have the privilege of chairing the
public accounts committee where we have
looked at the towns fund and the
leveling up approach and it is a chaotic
policy it is a headline without proper
detail and analysis about how to deliver
this only the bristol area has seen
economic growth outside london um over
many decades now it is a challenge for
every government but the idea that
headlines saying it's going to happen
are actually going to deliver is just
for the birds and we see this huge
increase in private renters and yet no
real support for them where is the
security if you cannot afford to buy
your own home and you cannot qualify for
social rented housing which in my
constituency is in massively short
supply in any case with
hundreds thousands of families living in
massively overcrowded conditions we've
all been on the doorsteps a lot in the
last week mr d mr speaker and it's a
privilege to always to meet constituents
but when you keep meeting constituents
who you knew when their children were
toddlers whose children are still living
sharing the bedroom two or three of them
while their parents live in the living
room and those children are now young
adults it's not good enough there is no
hope for those people because the
government and these proposed bills do
nothing to enable councils to build that
an important social rented housing we
have better rights to printers and
provide a proper stepladder to
purchasing your own home every policy so
far has fueled the equity in those who
already own their home rather than
giving a real leg up to first-time
wannabe first-time buyers in
constituencies like mine we're a
two-bedroom modern flat as i've said
repeatedly in this house mr speaker but
i repeat it again
on the market for around 750 000
pounds
that's just for a two-bedroom leasehold
flat
and as of june of last year the median
house price in the constituency was six
hundred thousand pounds but there aren't
many i i'd be struggling to find a
property uh for that price in many parts
of my constituency but that's a huge
increase nine point one percent over the
past five years a house in hackney costs
more than 16
times 16 times the average hackney
salary
and that's not
and you know he has a range of salaries
though there are a lot of people at the
poorer end and one in 35 people in my
constituency
are recorded officially as homeless as
or in temporary accommodation
but that doesn't include those
overcrowded ones those who are
overcrowded because there's no space for
them to go and those with no recourse to
public funds you can't possibly afford
to print privately even though they're
working and certainly can never buy and
rents as i as as we all know are very
very high so we need much better support
and there's no real solution in this
queen's speech
and crucially we need real support for a
lost generation
many people have been very badly
affected by covid
but a group that i worry about
particularly are our children
who have lost out on the on two years of
education and hats off to the teachers
and schools that kept educating them but
for many children however well the
school did if you didn't have the
technology at home you were clustered
around one computer and a mobile phone
with poor data that was never going to
be the same as a classroom experience
so schools did the best they could and
many did a very very good job but there
is a challenge for children who lost out
on education who will go through the
system without catching up under the
government's proposal so i look forward
to seeing what's in their bill but
really realistically and i've been
talking to my schools about the cost of
their energy bills as just one recent
crisis and the cost increase on their
energy bills mean the choice between
heating the school
or losing a teacher
so having our children freeze in a
classroom but being taught by a teacher
or a warm school where they can
concentrate on learning but losing that
crucial classroom teacher that's the
stark reality and i'm happy to share
with anybody in the government the
figures from the schools that have
provided it to me if we can work
together for a solution on that but the
cost of catch-up is a cost that is
absolutely vital we pay
it is taxpayers money well spent to
invest in the generation
that will be the engine of our future
that will be the entrepreneurs because
my constituency may be poor but it is
not it has no poverty of aspiration but
unless we give those children the leg up
now and the catch up now they will not
get the advantages that they should have
and we've seen the complete failure of
the tutoring scheme which my cross-party
committee highlighted as a concern very
early on we have we said where are these
tutors that are going to go in and tutor
and of course that contract has been
axed so we still need a lot of support
we're seeing children in years seven and
eight according to teachers in my
constituency having to be taught how to
do decent handwriting because they miss
those crucial years at primary school
pupils in years seven and eight losing
out in some areas because the qualified
teachers are focused on the exam years
and we all want our children to succeed
and the government needs to make sure
that school funding is properly resolved
it's fallen in average terms uh in real
terms per pupil by uh 1.2 for the most
deprived fifths of schools but increased
by nearly three percent for the least
deprived fifths of schools is this
leveling up it doesn't look like it to
me and the prime minister purports to be
an intelligent man i'm sure he can do
the maths and work out that that means
there's an awful lot of children losing
out
i was pleased to see that the victims
bill is finally finally
perhaps going to appear it's only been
in three manifestos and four queen
speeches
but this is a real crucial problem again
my committee has looked at the backlog
in the criminal courts the many factors
to that some of which cannot be resolved
through legislation the sheer grind of
day-to-day delivery and government of
decent
public services is something that seems
alien to the prime minister and his
front bench but that aside we need this
victims bill to support victims better
like the woman in my constituency
violently attacked by her partner
in front of her seven-year-old daughter
she went to the police
the court case was too set for two years
after that violent attack it is no
surprise that he has repeatedly broken
his non-molestation order because he
feels that he can get away with it
scot-free
and this is happening to victims up and
down the country and for those
particularly in that kind of domestic
abuse situation she has said to me i
just want to move i want a shot of this
i don't want to be reliving this or do i
nor do i want my daughter to relive this
over the next two years and if the
victim's bill is to mean anything in
terms of domestic violence it needs
decent
options on alternative housing for those
who are victims because that's so often
the break that those people need and
they cannot get it in my constituency
was such a shortage of housing that is a
huge uh an ongoing issue
i'll give way to the honourable
gentleman to the shop housing and we
need to get more houses delivered so
will she be supporting the reforms to
the planning system that have been
incorporated in today's queen's speech
mr speaker i will support anything
that delivers the housing i haven't had
a chance to look at the detail i think
we do not yet know all of the detail but
absolutely in my constituency if there's
a bit of land and nothing's moving on it
it's we are looking at it as an option
for housing but we cannot fit everything
into an inner city london borough we
need a better balance of housing but we
do definitely need that more affordable
housing and in constituency like mine we
need more socially rented housing
because the other options are not real
options for people people have been
housed in temporary accommodation in
other boroughs outside of my
constituency often want to move back
when they're on a five-year lease i'd
say to them that is some at the moment
the current situation
thanks to this government often the best
you'll get but when the rent is as high
as it is in the private sector they
worry because they cannot survive
without some benefit top up if it fits
in with the housing benefit cap and so
they are stuck
in a terrible cycle of never being able
to have a permanent home
i just wanted to touch on a couple of
other issues that have been raised in a
lengthy queen speech
the prime minister mr speaker talks
about brexit being done will promise
that you know and i know
that it's not done is it it's far from
done and there is going to be a very
long tale of changes that have been
repeatedly delayed there was no planning
after the vote in 2016. we've seen
import controls once again delayed and
it's not even clear what will change
businesses are confused people are
confused
and that lack of planning is coming home
to roost so you can use this the prime
minister mr speaker can use the slogans
but we can see through them and he can
have a peruse any day he wants of the
committee reports that we've put out
there highlighting these concerns
and the queen speech has got a whole
chunk of dividing issues issues
that the prime minister would love me to
engage with now but i'm not going to
give him that satisfaction because i
want real results for the people in my
constituency not the flim flam and the
headline cheap headlines of things that
he hopes will start culture wars between
members of this house and our voters
because
everybody in this house and all our
constituents know that the cost of
living has to be a priority that
leveling up has to be a priority
i was pleased to see a uk infrastructure
bank announced uh mr deputy speak mr
speaker but i'm a bit puzzled because
this is the same government
that created the green investment bank
and then a few years later
sold it off to the private sector so if
this infrastructure bank is going to
invest in green technologies
well good if we if it works but why have
we had a decade of wasted time on that
opportunity
um in summary mr speaker
this bill is not about bringing our
country together and supporting people
who need it it's about division
our prime minister has his head in the
sand about real life and the real
challenges of the cost of living and
finding a home for most of our
constitution so many of our constituents
there is no direction from this
government that's flailing around trying
to come up with a list of headlines but
unable to competently govern this
country in the interests of the people i
represent
yeah
theresa may
thank you mr speaker and i refer members
to my entry in the members register it
is indeed a privilege to be able to
speak in this debate on the humble
address in her majesties platinum
jubilee year and as others have already
spoken everybody across this house
including myself wishes her majesty all
the very best
and thanks her for her unstinting
service and her exemplary devotion to
duty
as others have done i would also like to
recognize the passing of three excellent
members of this house sir david amis
james brokenshire and jack dromey they
all came into this house in order to
make a difference to improve people's
lives
and they worked unstintingly to do just
that
and i would like to congratulate my
honourable friends and members for
beverly and holderness and brexit for
their absolutely excellent speeches in
proposing and seconding this greatest uh
speech of the humble address
uh i want to speak about a few of the
elements of the government's program
that i very much welcome the modern
slavery bill
will cement the government's commitment
to enhance the provisions on supply
chains i understand the first element
will be an extension
of the requirements excuse me on supply
chains to public procurement to
government departments this is important
in 2019 as prime minister i committed
the government to use its power of
public procurement to actually ensure
that it was cleaning up supply chains
and cracking down on modern slavery i
genuinely believe that dealing with
supply chains is one of the key ways in
which we can ensure that we eradicate
modern slavery business has a huge role
to play here so does government section
54 was important in the modern slavery
act but of course it doesn't actually
require action other than putting
something in an account in your
reporting accounts which might be to say
that you've done nothing about modern
slavery so it is excellent that the
government is now moving this forward
and going to enhance this legislation i
think it could be transformative
i also want to welcome the social
housing regulation bill
one of the clear messages that came from
residents and survivors of the terrible
tragedy that was the fire at grenfell
tower
was the concern that for not just months
but for years the voice of residents in
social housing had not been heard had
not been listened to by those in
authority who had responsibility to
respond
this was something that we then
discovered from consultation across the
country was not unique to grenfell tower
but sadly there were too many occasions
where those responsible for social
housing was simply not listening to the
points that their tenants were raising
so it is important that we enhance the
ability of tenants to have their voice
raised enhance the regulation regime and
ensure that we can do something which is
so important in this country which is to
raise the value for people of social
housing so the stigma is not attached to
social housing and being in social
housing we're all one community the type
of housing we live in should be
irrelevant to how we are treated
uh and important here also is the
renter's reform bill
i note the briefing says it will provide
4.4 million households with more secure
and higher quality homes renting is the
only option for more and more people and
for for some it is the flexible option
that they actively want
but it isn't easy if you then live
feeling that you could be evicted
through no fault of your own and dealing
with those no-fault evictions was a
commitment that has been made previously
i seem to remember my government made it
and i sincerely hope that it will now be
enacted through this through this bill
when it comes to housing it is important
for the government to recognize the many
concerns that were expressed by the
public and by members of this house
across the house on the elements of the
planning white paper that the government
published
and uh i understand that the housing
secretary has heard those messages and
is looking carefully at what should be
in the the uh planning bill we do need
more homes we need to ensure they're in
the right place we need to ensure
they're in designs that are actually in
keeping with the community and the
neighborhood in which they are set
i believe the housing sector is
interested in these street votes so that
if uh in a street somebody wants to
extend their floor their house by two
floors they can have a vote in the
street and the street will decide
whether that's a sensible thing to do
can i simply say
to my right honourable friend uh the
prime minister and others on the front
bench that i think the government needs
to be very careful about the potential
unintended consequences of such a mood i
can well imagine a situation in which
somebody persuades their neighbours in
the street to agree to sorts of
development that might enhance the value
of their houses but actually has a
negative impact on the wider community
and the wider
neighborhood
looking at the issues of planning and
and uh this ties in with the energy bill
and issues in relation to the energy
bill um i do wish the government hoped
that the government i urge them to take
the opportunity to move ahead in
relation to building regulations to
ensure that we embrace now the standards
that will be required
for our reaching net zero we are still
seeing new homes being built with gas
boilers
and those are going to be retrofitted in
a few years time and so wouldn't it make
more sense to actually make sure that
the regulations ensure that we actually
do the take moves now for net zero but i
welcome the energy bill and there is
much in there that will help us to move
to net zero and that is uh that is
excellent
i also welcome the national security
bill uh which i expect will enhance our
ability to deal with threats from
hostile states that is very important
it's increasingly necessary and it is
very timely
in relation to northern ireland uh there
is reference in the queen's speech to
the legacy
bill i think it is important i've said
it before in this house that we reach a
point where there is an ability to try
to draw a line on the past but that must
be done sensitively in recognition of
the sensitivities of all communities
i note there is
i will keep waiting
mr speaker thank you
welcome back
i think there's an explanation that i
was at the nigerian uh embassy getting
my during my pass it's what i can go
good in nigeria at the end of may can i
ask another lady it's really important
for my constituents those who have lost
loved ones i can name them the dolly
duggan ford
uh
montgomery uh murdered by the ira nobody
ever made a card about my cousin nobody
ever made a carnival i want justice my
relatives want justice my constituents
want justice does the honourable lady
agree
can i say theresa may i say honorable
gentleman we welcome him back to his
place in the
in the chamber um that is why i say it
is important that these issues are
addressed sensitively they have
consistently uh been looked at by some
of my colleagues in relation to those
veterans who may find themselves being
caught before justice but what is
important is that people who did lose
loved ones during the troubles
and the majority of those losses would
have been at the hands of terrorists but
who did lose loved ones during the
troubles are able to feel that sense of
first of all actually understanding what
has happened and being able to know what
has happened and i think this is one of
the things that is driving the
government's intention in relation to
this in relation to this bill
and they they will want to be able to
feel some sense of closure uh which they
have not been able to see for so many
years
i note that there is no reference to
what has been referred to in the papers
as a bill in relation to and i'm going
to use the word the northern ireland
protocol and possibly to varying the
terms of the treaty unilaterally
can i say to my right honourable friend
and he will not be surprised if i say
this that i do not feel that that would
be the right move for the government
that i think the government needs to
consider not just some immediate issues
but also the wider sense of what such a
move would say about the united kingdom
and its willingness to abide by treaties
which it has
signed
i will give way to them right i i thank
the former prime minister for giving way
can i say to her um with the great uh
with great respect that i hold her in
that surely what is more important here
is the good friday belfast agreement
and the need to protect the political
institutions
i stood in the election last week not a
single unionist member was returned to
the assembly that supports the protocol
there is no consensus for this it needs
to be dealt with it is harming our
economy it is driving up the cost of
living it is undermining political
stability in northern it threatens the
good friday agreement it has to be dealt
with
right honourable gentleman that i put a
deal before this house which which
actually met the requirements of the
good friday agreement
and actually enabled us not to have a
border down the rsc
or to have a border between northern
ireland and the public violence sadly
the dup and others across this house
chose to reject that but it was just
such an opportunity for what he wanted
can i say to my right honourable friend
that i am deeply disappointed that we
only see draft legislation on a new
mental health act
the process for a new mental health act
was started in 2017.
i have said before and i've said once
before in debate on a queen speech
previous queen speech that i feared that
we might not see a new act until 2023. i
now fear we might not see a new act
until 2024 and
given the proximity of potential general
election may not see a new act in this
parliament at all uh i have to say that
i think those suffering from mental
health deserve better from the
government and i would encourage action
on introducing a new mental health act
i'm also disappointed we don't have an
employment bill particularly to put
through the policy of ensuring that tips
that are left for waiters actually get
paid to those individuals
and it was a popular policy and i would
hope that the government think we'll
think again on putting it through
the final issue on which i'm
disappointed is that we don't see a
commitment to an independent public
advocate
this was a 2017 manifesto commitment i
recognize my right honourable friend did
not put it in the 2019 manifesto but it
was one of the key recommendations from
the report i commissioned from bishop
james jones
33 use years on
from the hillsborough disaster
i think it is time that we actually took
action to provide much greater support
for those families who lose loved ones
in public disasters and there have been
other disasters since hillsborough
i think it would be a very fitting uh
legacy for those who sadly have lost
their lives at hillsboro and other
disasters if we see that support being
put in through an independent public
advocate and if i can just say to uh the
front bench the government doesn't need
to do any work on it because the
honourable honourable member ferguson
hailwood actually has a bill that is
written and which i'm sure she will be
aiming to introduce in this house and
which could be supported now underlying
my final comment is underlying the
government's programme is the desire to
level up the economy and encourage
high-wage high-skill jobs a country that
works for everyone is about leveling up
opportunity across the country
but the economic background against
which the government is working does not
make delivering on those aspirations
easy
the cost of living crisis is making life
difficult for many across the country we
have rising inflation the need to
restore public finances
the number of people who are
economically inactive in this country is
rising
as well as we've seen a hit to sterling
and forecast growth is well below trend
all those make for a very challenging
environment and it's a time like this
that the conservative principles of
sound public finances and competent
economic management are needed more than
ever
and as we level up across the country we
should ensure that we're a government
that doesn't work just work for certain
parts of the country but a government
that truly works for everyone
great pleasure to follow the right
honourable lady
especially since the current prime
minister
entered office
and i agreed with a lot of what she said
especially on the need to move ahead
quickly with new legislation for people
with mental health issues and what she
said on on social housing i thank her
for that miss madame deputy speaker um
i'd like to pay tribute to her majesty
the queen
she was missed today very much
on behalf of the liberal democrats i
would like to send her our very best
wishes
we all look forward to celebrating the
incredible milestone of the queen's
platinum jubilee next month
as an mp serving the royal borough of
kings upon thames
i know there'll be street parties galore
across my constituency demonstrating our
patriotic and affectionate support for
her majesty
i'd also like to pay tribute to three
others whose absence we feel very
acutely today
james brokenshire david amos
and jack dromi
parliamentary colleagues who sadly left
us in the last 12 months
all three were mps who command respect
across the house
respect for their seriousness of purpose
and their collegiate way of working
they are all missed in every corner of
this house
i must also compliment the honourable
members for beverly and holdenness and
brexit for their speeches today
the member for beverly holdness was a
well-respected chair of the education
select committee when he described the
then education secretary's reforms as
ill-conceived and incoherent
you'll believe to hear that his speech
was neither of those things
and in my opinion he's neither an old
duffer nor a young thruster
but far more valuable than either of
those a member with an independent mind
whips off his dream
and his mention of a royal commission to
deal with political wrongdoing has given
me an interesting idea that i think we
should take up with ministers
now
madam david speaker we are all servants
of the crown but the member for
breckenradnisher has taken that further
than most when she worked for the prince
of wales as a researcher
i'm not sure if she was consulted by his
royal highness for today's gracious
speech
but her speech was an interesting
insight into the complex relationships
between conservative mps and i thank her
for that
madame dr speaker
this should have been a cost of living
queen speech families and pensioners
across the united kingdom
are facing the biggest squeeze on
household budgets and living standards
at any time during her majesty's whole
long reign going back to the
1950s yet the government's program
offered
nothing now there was a hint in the
prime minister's speech i don't know if
you caught it he said that there was
going to be some measures brought
forward by himself and the chance in the
next few days
yet the press are reporting that the
treasury are saying they have no idea
what the prime minister is referring to
so we wonderful if at least the minister
from the front branch could enlighten
the house because our constituents need
some help and there's nothing in this
queen's speech when inflation is at
seven percent and rising its highest
rate in 30 years predicted to get into
double digits by the end of this year
and we've all heard from many
constituents heart running stories about
the sacrifices they are making just to
try to make ends meet because of
inflation
parents going without meals to make sure
there's enough food for their children
pensioners huddled in only one room to
keep their heating bills down
families who've seen energy bills soar
by 700 pounds already
are now told to expect another 800 pound
rise in the autumn people desperately
need more help from the government
but what have they received instead
modern day speaker
tax rises
broken election promises on pension
rises
and wages rising far slower than
inflation
madness speaker the government's unfair
tax rises could not have come at a worse
possible time
and the government's rise in national
insurance contributions coupled with the
freezing of income tax thresholds that
they like us to forget
together they are hitting the low paid
really hard
when everyone really needs what everyone
really needs is an emergency tax cut and
that's why liberal democrats want an
immediate cut in vat
our vat cut idea would help everyone
would help small businesses on high
streets and would cut inflation
yet by failing to cut v80 by choosing to
make the cost of living emergency worse
this government has confirmed people's
deep fears
that they are government
that just doesn't care
given the increase which
is now reported in treasury or seats due
to inflation and due to the increased
vit
receipts does he not think it would be
appropriate for the government to take
that action but as we also recognize in
doing so
vat reductions could not apply in
northern ireland and people in northern
ireland could not benefit from it
because of the northern iron protocol
well i hope the government will find
helped a way of working with politicians
in northern ireland to help people who
are struggling but he's absolutely right
about the va t point manager speaker the
chance of getting nine billion pounds
extra in vit this receipt over the
prediction in the budget 38 billion
pounds and yet they say they can't
afford a vat cut it's clearly nonsense
the local elections last week people
across the country rose up to say enough
is enough
from stockport to somerset cumbria to
cambridge harrogate to harpenden voters
chose liberal democrats to be their
local champions to fight for a fair deal
for them and their communities
and for liberal democrats that fair deal
must start with real action to tackle
soaring energy bills and rising food
prices and not just a vat cut
we want to increase and extend the warm
homes discount to help over 7 million
people with their heating bills
and increase the winter fuel allowance
to help pensioners betrayed by the
conservatives breaking their election
promise on the pensions triple lock
the democrats want to help families and
pensioners in rural areas who heat their
home with heating oil or lpg
who aren't protected by the energy price
cap
we would pay for this with a windfall
tax on the super profits of the oil and
gas companies only last week
we learned that bp and shell are now
raking in a billion pounds in profit
between them every single week from the
same soaring gas and petrol prices that
are making families suffer so much
surely even this government can see in
this economic crisis
we need to cut taxes for families by
asking these corporate giants to pay a
little bit more
this government is failing so many
groups
there's nothing to back british farmers
for example who are at once some of the
hardest hit victims of the cost of
living crisis and yet crucial to solving
food inflation for the rest of us
instead of backing our farmers and our
rural communities the government is
adding to their pain
selling them down the river with trade
deals that allow low welfare foreign
imports to undercut responsible british
farmers
and cutting the payments farmers rely on
costing some of them up to half of their
entire income
quite simply that risks driving many
small farmers
out of business altogether
in the southwest alone
farmers will lose almost a billion
pounds by the end of 2027 as a result of
these conservative policies
madam death speaker this government's
programme
not only fails to help people with the
cost of living emergency it also fails
to address the crisis in our nhs and
care services
take our ambulance services many are in
crisis
resources have been slashed
and paramedics and handlers are not
being given the support they need
in the southwest
if you're a stroke victim
you now have to wait
almost two hours for an ambulance
that is a terrifying statistic an
average weight for an ambulance of
almost two hours
and it's not just stroke victims
in devon
an 88 year old man derek painter lay in
and i quote excruciating pain after he
fell on the stairs
he waited seven hours
for an ambulance
that is just horrific
thousands of people are watching loved
ones in agony and distress
some have even watched them die
this is heartbreaking and it cannot go
on
can ministers can the prime minister
look these families in the eye in such
distressing circumstances and tell them
they've got a grip
on this health crisis
and it doesn't just stop at the
ambulance crisis
over years now this government has
allowed our nhs to spiral out of control
local health services are at breaking
point following the conservative
government's broken promises to recruit
more gps
people are struggling to get
appointments
and gps are under more pressure than
ever
and then there's a ticking time bomb of
nhs dentistry or the lack of it
forcing people to shell out thous
hundreds if not thousands of pounds for
private work because they cannot get to
see an nhs dentist
there was nothing in the queen's speech
to tackle these health crises
and nothing for the social care crisis
either
last year
the government promised to reform social
care but all we got instead was an
unfair tax hike
more than a million people are missing
out on the care they need right now
and still the government is doing
nothing to help
nor is it doing anything to support the
millions of unpaid family carers who are
making big sacrifices to look after
their families their loved ones
they're already facing serious financial
hardship
that was before the cost of living
crisis struck
and they're now being pushed to breaking
point
and they were once again forgotten in
the queen's speech i've told ministers
i've told the prime minister on
countless occasions about the everyday
struggles carers face
the amazing kingston carers network in
my constituency tell me their members
like carers across the country are
desperate for a rising carers allowance
and for respite services to give them a
break
yet even the government's promise of a
weak unpaid leave for carers surely the
very least the government can do
was missing from the gracious speech
it's just not good enough without these
unpaid carers these family carers our
health and social care systems would
crumble
the government is ignoring them at their
peril
nor can it forward modern day speaker to
ignore the growing public anger about
raw sewage being dumped into our rivers
and seas
i see it in the hogsmill river in my
consistency
kingston's blue jewel
and one of only 210 chalk streams in the
world
sewage pollution is killing these rivers
and chalk streams
and threatens the habitats of countless
wild animals and saw as the beauty of
our precious local environment
i know other members across the country
are seeing the same
with sewage being poured into their
local rivers and streams
and into the seas along our coasts
whether in eastbourne or east devon
liberal democrats have proposed tough
new laws and a new sewage tax on water
companies to end the dumping of raw
sewage
and our constituents will not forget
the government's failure to listen
and include such measures in the queen's
speech today
i'm happy
i'm very pleased to raise the issue of
sewage in our rivers and pollution does
he not think the solution is to take all
of our water companies back into public
ownership and stop pouring millions of
pounds of our water costs into the
profits of the private sector often in
overseas locations
i have to say i disagree with them
gentlemen i want a sewage tax i want to
punitive laws regulations on these
companies who've been getting away with
it that is a way for much quicker
progress we can't wait any longer we
need clean rivers we need clean seas
um finally monday speaker this queen's
speech comes not only at a challenging
time for the uk domestically it comes at
a dark moment for us and for our allies
as putin's brutal invasion of ukraine
continues
i am proud of how we on all sides of the
house have stood united in our resolve
support president zelinski and the brave
ukrainians
fighting for the same fundamental values
which we treasure so deeply liberty and
democracy
but we need to do more
and send clear strong signals
here in this regard i'm afraid that one
thing in this address was conspicuous by
its absent
a decision to reverse this government's
cut to our armed forces a cut of 10 000
troops
that cut
is a deeply misguided policy at this
perilous moment
our national security has to be a
priority
i urge the government to reverse this
decision immediately and demonstrate to
our nato allies britain's determination
to stand up to aggression now and in the
future
i now call to make her maiden speech
an offer
[Applause]
deputy speaker thank you for giving me
the opportunity to make my maiden speech
it's a privilege to follow the right
honourable member for kingston and
serbian um i hope uh the eloquence with
which he makes his speech
is infectious it's a pleasure and a
privilege to to have spoken in the same
debate as the father of the house my
right honourable friend uh the member
for worthing west he's sadly not here
but i had hoped to tell him he sets a
fine example and i'm looking forward to
addressing this place in 2017.
[Laughter]
madam deputy speaker it's the honor of
my life to be the first mp to be elected
for the new city of salvation
yet i will never forget
that the circumstances that have brought
me here
are truly
horrific so david was and remains
a legend
across the whole of essex
an outstanding mp for basildon for 14
years and for south and west for a
further 24.
quite simply
sir david embodied all that is good
about our parliamentary museum
he had a gift for building bridges
across this house
and i think that everybody here misses
his decency
his kindness
his smile
and his wicked sense of humor
here in westminster it's already obvious
to me
how easily you could become disconnected
from normal life and from the
constituents we serve
yet in nearly 40 years as an mp that
never happened to sir david
he always remained absolutely dedicated
to the people he represented
from his successful private members bill
on fuel poverty still relevant today
to eliminating cruel tethering
so david champion causes close to his
residents hearts
animal welfare the incredible music man
project endometriosis
and of course
making south end a city
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
madam deputy speaker there are others i
would like to mention
the life of an mp is clearly demanding
but there are rewards and recognition
that go with that
one group of people however
share many of the pressures of our
journey
but little of the recognition
so i want to pay tribute to lady amis
and her five children
no one i repeat no one has paid a higher
price for our democracy than they have
as we continue on with our lives theirs
has been shattered
forever the dignity
love and spirit of reconciliation that
they have shown has been an inspiration
to me
and i know the whole house would wish to
join me in telling them
their sacrifice
their contribution to our democracy will
also never be forgotten
i'd also like to pay tribute madam
deputy speaker
to
the other mainstream parties who chose
not to contest the by-election proving
once again
attacks on our democracy will only ever
bring us closer together
madam deputy speaker south and west is a
wonderful constituency award-winning
beaches the earliest recorded woodland
in essex an international airport
nationally important wetlands and the
beautiful town of lyon sea where i was
born and love living
arrive from london
madame deputy speaker by road
turn right towards the scene
and they're spread out before you is in
my opinion the most captivating view in
the southeast
and that is the view madam deputy
speaker that admiral blake would have
seen in 1652
when he bought the crippled english
fleet back from the anglo-dutch war to
old lee for refitting
spurning instructions to go to medway
[Music]
speaker what we all know now
the only way is essex
two months later blake left old lee with
the biggest and the best equipped fleet
the nation had ever set to see
but there's much more
mr speaker delicious shellfish and
cockles are still fish daily in my
constituency and our picturesque high
streets sport a wealth of independent
businesses including the internationally
renowned rotties ice cream and the best
fried doughnuts in the country
so it's no wonder
this madame deputy speaker that the
times recently announced leon c as one
of the best places to live in the
country proclaiming it fresh air and
funkiness in buckets and spades
madam deputy speaker we also have a very
proud tradition of sea bathing in south
and west indeed we have the largest
collection of historic swimwear
in the country
changing facilities however
have always been controversial
historic reports from the 1900s
men
not queuing for bathing machines
choosing instead to rummage around in
macintoshes to get changed
men who performed this
the last man prosecuted in the 1950s
in court he was told surely
it's time to give it up
but purportedly replied to the judge if
he didn't mind he would stick it out for
a little longer
there is of course
much more to south and west than our
beautiful seafront
from internationally significant
heritage sites such as the saxon
prittlewell prince burial a stunning
medieval monastery and the 17th century
london shipwreck to chalkwell's famous
rose garden and the palace theatre which
previews many west end shows
southend baden deputy speaker is
absolutely worthy of being the uk city
of culture
exactly you may think the calls for
south end to be a city have finished i
can tell you they've only just begun
absolutely
[Applause]
what makes southend truly special madam
deputy speaker are its people
positive
talented
hard-working and entrepreneurial and i'm
so proud to represent them
give a southender a lemon
madame deputy speaker and you will not
just get lemonade you will get
lemoncello
because south and west is home to tapped
an international cocktail success story
started in the founders kitchen around
lockdown
madam deputy speaker as a conservative i
believe in opportu inequality
of opportunity
after wartime service
my grandfather worked for south end
general post office for over 25 years
my grandmother was a dinner lady
above all they valued education
my mother
dr margaret garrett
went to westcliff high school for girls
and that was the making of my mother and
of my family and i'm delighted madame
deputy speaker that they are here today
including my wonderful husband edward
and my son piers
but that's why championing southend
west's great schools is so important to
me including our world beating grammar
schools
and it's also why i welcome this queen's
speech with its commitment to turbo
charging school standards
school attendance
a register to make sure we don't have
invisible children in the system and
greater safeguarding and also fairer
funding
ensuring that every child in our country
receives a quality education is the only
way to achieve true equality of
opportunity
but that must apply to health care too
which is why i also welcome this
government's commitment to the nhs
every 45 minutes a man dies of prostate
cancer in this country
including my own father 18 months ago
his treatment by the nhs was exemplary
but there are now new and better ways of
treating prostate cancer particularly
earlier screening and that's why i will
be a loud voice for the brilliant south
end charity prost 8
and its groundbreaking work in this area
so to conclude madam deputy speaker
as disraeli once said
you could not have a softer climate nor
sunnier skies than at south end
i cannot hope
to replace my predecessor
but i can promise to work hard every day
to make the new city of south end a
beacon of enterprise unity kindness and
opportunity
[Applause]
[Music]
madam deputy speaker and can i say
what a delight it is to follow the
honorable lady for south and
out west in her
in her maiden speech
and i like other members of the house
who would very strongly empathize with
her remarks about david amos who is a
friend to many of us um absolutely
somebody who did cross um the best of
this house of commons of ours um he will
be a very tough act to follow but the
honourable lady's speech they just show
why
she is now the member of parliament
to take on
david's many many battles i would say so
as well uh as a northerner i for a long
time thought leon c was as credible as
as the wig and pier
but but but
i can well empathize and sympathise with
the divisions of those uh be map wearing
people changing on the on the on the
beach because this would happen in the
rather cooler climbs of blackpool and
southpaw in the north of england but may
i wish the the honourable lady every
success um
uh
madam speaker the the queen speech was
for i think many of us a tale of almost
of two countries um
a vision that the prime minister would
seek to set out of a country going
forward but the reality for many of our
constituents for the country frankly
this is in reverse gear my constituents
over the course this election and other
areas where i was able to to knock on
doors and it turned they are actually in
many cases frightened the frightened
like one of my constituents whose
husband had to wait seven hours for an
ambulance like my constituents who are
on waiting lists which seem to grow and
not get shorter and who are frightened
about their health frightened even about
the possibility of early death while
they're on those waiting lists my
constituents in school are concerned
about their futures because they can't
see the high quality education that is
there in the brochure but isn't being
delivered in the ground because of
underfunding not lack of good teachers
but lack of enough teachers and
investments in our education but my
constituents at the moment are
particularly frightened i think about
issues like housing marvel fun for
hackney made the point about london the
london housing market is a very unique
one but actually the lack of social
housing the lack of affordable housing
across this country of ours is very much
the same and there is a housing crisis
in my constituency and there is nothing
in this green speech to touch on that
the the biggest issue though undoubtedly
and i've not had such a large number of
emails um at a personal level and is is
people's concerns about the cost of
living in crisis you know when we've got
um again a tale of two countries the
centuricas of this world the bps in this
world the shelves of this world making
record profits many of it go to their
already well-heeled shareholders and yet
my constituents and those vulnerable
members on both sides of this house who
have already seen a 50
increase in the the the cap the energy
cap and likely to see an equivalent
increase later on this year they're
frightened of what that means people who
really are frightened to put the heating
on people who are frightened to cook and
and to use
the oven
people who simply don't know how they'll
make things things through the end of
the month
woman who wrote to me she's a teacher a
single parent mum and as a single parent
mum she was able to buy her own home but
she tells me she's frightened that she
may have to sell that home because she
doesn't know how she can continue to
afford
the upkeep on it and that's somebody not
at the the what we that would think of
at the the worst offend a professional
teacher should simply not be in that
position but she's frightened frightened
for her children frightened for her
budget a family who's um where the the
the the wife was telling me she's
concerned that her husband even though
she herself is in work is going to lose
the car that he gets because he's
disabled the thing that gets him around
gives him his own life support mechanism
and frankly that will go and makes the
point that her benefit so that his
benefit increased rather even though
she's in work for his disability at
three point one percent is de facto a
serious decrease with inflation like
it's at ten percent later on this year
pensioners who again are concerned about
how the make ends meet um pensioners who
have seen the government breakage
promise of the triple lock and
pensioners who have seen a 3.1 increase
in the pensions but actually who are
facing inflation at levels way way above
that these are people who are very
concerned about the future in this
country and cannot see the glossy
brochure that the premise is giving us
and we've got to do something about this
we've got to do something about the
situation where it isn't just those that
seemingly the the lowest
economic groupings in our society who
are suffering people across the piece
who are worried and there are things the
government can do we know even have the
increase the national minimum wage to
the 10 pounds that many on this side of
the house target even now the increase
that 50 percent increase 50 pence
increase would yield something the order
of 900 pounds a year um to those in
receipts of that that even after tax
would go some way to paying the
the increase in energy costs and why did
the chancellor not do that so these are
important issues we can and even now
could do that we could see a reversal
some of the tax increases the
government's brought in and in
recognition those penalized and those on
average incomes those are lower incomes
that would be the right thing to do in
responsible society to say to those
better off in our society maybe they
should people like me actually um now
over retirement age who pays no national
insurance that's got to be wrong
in our society why should i not who
still get the benefits of working the
benefits of our international insurance
system why should i not be making my
contribution why should not those on
higher incomes be paying national
insurance pro rata to those incomes let
us strong
look after those who are weak we say
that's why police officers you who are
strong look after those who are weak we
say that to our those with the brains to
run our hospitals those who use strong
look after the vulnerable why don't we
say to the better off you helped look
after those most in need because that is
the mantra of a fair society but madam
deputy speaker in the queen's speech as
well i did look for other issues for
example what are we going to do about
the climate crisis it's already been
mentioned there is nothing that's on the
face of the queen speech or even in the
government's uh puffing around it that
gives us any indication that it will be
the investment in home insulation which
is absolutely fundamental if we are
going to tackle um the the climate
crisis and there are many things the
government can be doing it would create
jobs it would create skills it seems so
obvious that
a crash an emergency program of home
insulation would be part of moving the
nation in the right direction it's
simply not there that would be good to
save energy costs it would be great to
save this planet let's do it uh but it's
not there but i'm just because there's
many other things that could go but who
wants it for me to turn to the situation
in northern ireland now i'll take my
friends um from northern ireland both
here and
elsewhere
northern ireland now isn't a political
crisis we know that but you know um i
spent
part of my own time when the storm and
assembly was not meeting talking to many
different people about the need for for
constructive and effective executive in
the north of ireland because the needs
of the people of north london are very
similar to the need to make decisions
it's it's an under funded and badly
structured health system
it's um it's it's the absence of reality
that the cost of living crazy is hurting
people it's real concerns about the
investment in education in in the
northbound these are things that are
common across the piece they don't have
tribal identities or whatever and i
would say to
honorable members here presents
actually i understand that the debate
about the protocol has to go on and
we'll just we'll agree and disagree on
some aspects of it but actually in the
end having an effective executive is
something that doesn't matter we'll say
to the restless member for lagun valley
when he talks about permanent political
instability this isn't the message of
a constructive process that devolves
government taught me about i believe in
devolved government because i believe
it's good for the people of northern
ireland um but um as as we as we said
we don't face that constructive
devolution if instead we have once again
and boycott thank the honourable member
for giving way my party believes in
devolution very strong indeed has done a
lot of the heavy lifting to make the
evolution work more than many others but
i'll tell the honorable member this
gently
the cost of living crisis is accentuated
in northern ireland by somewhere in the
region between 27 and 34
of higher costs because of the the
border on the rac
it has got to be removed or else that
crisis will go on and will poison all
relationships on the economy well
look
let me say i i don't understand that his
party isn't as committed to devolution
they were part of making that the
evolution process worked over the years
and and that transformed the the
situation on the ground and
i know this um but what i would say to
him is that the prime minister's
protocol is something that has to be
debated in this chamber members of the
do you appear here to debate that in
this chamber and i hope they do take
that opportunity but stopping reform of
the health service um as stopping the
kind of things that could be done about
the cost of living crisis in in in terms
of education etc these are things that
are here and now i don't implore them to
think seriously about what that does but
we can unite on them
across all parties in
northern ireland is this is that
and the honourable member of the
strength has made a a a very important
comment early on about the the the
legacy of the troubles and one of the
things that i've
over time i've listened to many many
victims of
the families the family's victims of the
troubles
and their common insistence still that
they want justice and i fear that this
amnesty proposal this blocking of things
like inquests is going to prevent that
search for justice and actually that
does unite their people across the
political divide in northern ireland
i've never forgiving way and i know that
he doesn't want a speech dominated by
the northern ireland issue but would he
accept
that not only is the northern ireland
protocol adding significantly to the
cost of living crisis in northern
ireland and slowing down the recovery of
the northern ireland economy from covet
but it also poisons
the very essence
of the belfast agreement and therefore
stops the working of the institutions it
removes democracy because it does not
just just unions members but all members
on the assembly will not have any say on
60 of the laws
it removes the principle of consent
because not one unions member so
supports the protocol and yet it would
be the role of those members in the the
executive in northern ireland that
implement the very protocol the union's
population are being damaged
economically and constitutionally by
well
i'm just we could continue to debate the
protocol and no doubt will
um and the the different views on on its
impact there are those and honourable
members in this house know this in
northern ireland who say in actual fact
business wants to get on and make the
protocol work but nevertheless we'll
continue to debate this issue of course
we will but nevertheless the point out
the central point of making is this is
that
to delay reform of education to play the
important investment in the good
governance of northern ireland is a very
high price to pay uh for not bringing
the matter of the protocol before this
house and just to speak i've probably
spoken enough i just want to say two
kind things about the governments uh
it's queen's speech one is the is the
victims the potential for um something
about victims and that's a major step
forward really important and the second
of course is to see some progress on the
governance of football it may seem like
a
a periphery to many people but football
actually does match which is our
national game and actually making sure
we get this right is something that is
important so i look forward to
seeing the details this because they've
got to be got right
david dibs thank you madam deputy
speaker it's a privilege to follow the
writing member for rochdale i've
followed him over the years many times
and whilst i may not always agree with
him he always speaks with level-headed
common sense and that's a privilege for
the house
madam deputy speaker
the proverb tells us the good die young
and in this house that couldn't be more
true than this year
with uh three of our most valued members
david amos james brokenshire and track
dromi
all leaving us before their time
and david amos was a particularly close
friend of mine
and so it's particularly privileged to
speak after his successor
in her
storming
maiden speech indeed when she was
telling her macintosh joke i was
reminded of and made a speech about 30
years ago on those benches
when
a rather striking red-headed uh scott
knack
made a absolutely stonking speech maiden
speech
and i think it was john smith jumped up
and said that was no maiden speech that
was a brazen [ __ ] of the speech
well hers was too elegant to say that
um
she was much more elegant than that but
i will say but i'll say this to her
and perhaps it's the greatest compliment
i can give her and as i say david would
have been proud of you
now i want to make some simple points
madam speaker madam definitely speaker
uh fairly quickly but
this uh
there's a great deal to welcome in this
queen speech in 38 bills and and uh
those who have been poo pooing them
perhaps ought to think uh wait until
they see the details of some of them the
tackling of economic crime embracing the
freedoms that brexit offers that's too
late reforming and securing our energy
supply resolving the northern ireland
legacy issues these are all massively
important issues and there are many
others like them which should get our
undiluted support
there are some
and the front bench will be disappointed
if i did not say this there are some
which perhaps require more careful
handling
for example the online safety bill a
very well very necessary and well
intentioned bill but is so complex will
have
dozens of unintended consequences in
part including possibly curbing free
speech unintentionally so we have to
make sure we give the time to that uh to
look at it carefully similarly the
national security bill undoubtedly a
necessary bill but we're going to have
to handle it carefully because it it
replaces the official secrets act
and we must make sure it does it in a
way which does not curb the rights of
honorable whistleblowers for example
whilst protecting the state from
its enemies
now a queen speech is
built on sand if it's not underpinned by
strong economic foundations indeed
in the actual queen speech
it said the government will drive
economic growth to improve living
standards and fund sustainable
investment in public services
but taxes today are too high
so we need to get some fundamentals
right high taxes don't deliver growth
they stifle it
low taxes deliver investment low taxes
deliver higher productivity therefore
low practices deliver growth
therefore low taxes is the preemptive
answer to stagflation which is the
biggest threat on our horizon in the
coming year
so
i would say to the house that
i rather agree with some of the points
coming from some of the opposition
ventures about the need for an emergency
budget i don't agree with the argument
uh for uh for
windfall taxes i think that would defeat
itself but there's certainly need to act
quickly and the prime minister i think
used the phrase deploying our fiscal
firepower well we need to deploy our
fiscal firepower now
when our constituents need it not after
they've already suffered uh the
increases of prices they've faced now
and then the more that they'll face in
the latter part of the year
now this is a good queen speech i will
give way to me
and it's absolutely right that
lower taxes now put money in the
people's pockets to allow them to spend
on the kind of things that they are
finding it difficult to spend on present
but is he worried that there seems to be
this attitude
using the far power in a couple of years
time coming up the election will be seen
as cynical rather than dealing with the
issues now which are hurting people and
hurting them badly exactly right
it's quite plain if we increase for
example example national insurance for a
large part of the population and that
increases their suffering
in not being able to eat and heat the
house at the same time and then one year
before an election we drop the income
tax i'm afraid in the working men's
clubs of yorkshire that would be seen as
a cynical uh deployment of the state
power and i suspect the same in belfast
and expect the same in the rest of
northern ireland where as we've heard
already it's a bigger problem even than
an arrest united kingdom so
uh yes absolutely that's right and
that's why we should give the people
their money back now uh my right-hand
friend i'll give way to him that's about
to quote
my right honourable friend agree that as
there's going to be a big windfall
element in extra north sea oil and gas
taxation which already has a double
corporation tax windfall element and a
big increase in vat on domestic heating
and a big increase in in tax on pump
diesel and pump petrol at least that
money should be given back by other
taxpayers my right old friend is right i
mean in fact so much so he has been the
the icebreaker in this argument i refer
to it as the redwood argument we have we
have uh record tax collections this year
a record tax collections because of
fiscal drag and a variety of other
reasons underestimates by the by the
treasury and that's the money we should
give back to the people we don't need to
balance the budgets twice over we need
to get that right
now there are elements which uh i think
we need to reinforce or increase of what
the queen's speech is talking about i
mean my favorite line in the queen's
beach is the same one every year it's
other measures we put before you
and i want to speak just to those for a
moment now
um we are conservatives we believe in a
property only democracy and governments
for 30 years governments of all powers
all persuasions and for 30 or more years
since margaret thatcher and truth have
failed in this regard they've failed
uh my generation two-thirds of people
bought their own home
today it's a quarter
that is a scandal and it's of course
yeah i approve
of the prime minister talking about the
right to buy for uh for housing
associations i should do i first came up
with the policy in 2002 it was my
responsibility and we still haven't done
it but that won't solve the problem
we're a million houses short at least uh
in a period which we've had seven
million uh people increasing population
we're about a hundred thousand houses a
year
short in terms of what we're
constructing in addition to that million
so what we need to do is to find a way
which doesn't hit what people call the
nimby problem but which is people
talking about their own environment and
protecting their own environment in
objective things you find a way around
that and i think we need to look very
hard else has done before in the 20s at
garden villages and garden towns and
using the increased wealth created by
them to actually pay for
the uh the resources the community
centers the surgeries the schools the
roads the wi-fi that is that is
necessary and there'll be plenty of
added value uh to make the farmers rich
at the same time so it would be
politically a
and not a straightforward better an
easier policy uh than uh we might think
we're also believers in social mobility
i think the whole house
are believers in social mobility we used
to be the best in the developed world
used to be
now we're amongst the worst in the
developed world
now when inequality is greater social
mobility is more important indeed it's
the only real moral argument for in a an
unequal society and that is that people
everybody has an opportunity everybody
has a chance to take part and so in the
last 20 years or so
top one percent of the population have
roughly trebled their income
whereas the median is roughly flatlined
so there's a stronger argument for
social mobility today than also
the best mechanism in social mobility
for social mobility is the education
system
and it's about some very good proposals
in the education bill in this
uh this uh queen's speech but
uh
adding uh the academy system will help
at the margin but it won't solve the
problem it hasn't solved it for the last
30 years it won't solve it now
the great scandal
is that
half
of children
from free school meals families half of
children from preschool middle families
are failed by the education system by
the time they're 11.
they can't meet
the
english or mathematical requirements to
make progress in education their lives
are effectively over in terms of social
mobility at that point
we need to take a grip of that that
means re-engineering the classroom it
means helping our brilliant teachers
with more artificial intelligence more
software support more
augmentation the technology is there now
it exists now it's proven it's available
i i hope the house won't laugh too much
but i said i'll wait to see it
demonstrated eaton of all places uh
where it was
brilliant at bringing on the weakest
children i give away
i'm very um grateful to my enroll um
for giving away would you recognize
though um in terms of educational
attainment if some child's hungry
because many of our children are hungry
because they're living in poverty it's
not going to help them yeah i agree
entirely
and
i have arguments i'm not going to deploy
today on universal credit and so on
which relate directly to that but one of
the outcomes for example of having a
technologically augmented teaching and
assessment system is the teacher knows
in days if the child has got a problem
which you didn't have before suddenly
suddenly it's education performance
starts let's say because the parents
separate or the trouble at home or it's
going hungry or whatever it may be so
she's right
i agree with the basic premise but this
will help even with that if we do it and
i want to see us do that
and deal with that scam
the other area the the last errand to
speak about very briefly is the
fundamental question of health care
we all of us support the national health
service we always no doubt applauded the
brilliant staff and the doctors and
nurses who did a fantastic job
but we tell ourselves over and over
again we have the best health care
system in the world and it's not true
it is simply not true
we have those committed doctors
and we are now spending more than the
oecd average on healthcare more now we
see the average but we are not
delivering more than the oecd average
whether it's
survival rates in all the different
categories of cancer care or whether
it's coronaries or strokes or diabetes
or whatever we are not doing as good a
job as we should for the money and the
work and the skill and the commitment
that goes into it so my argument here is
that we should look at the other the
other countries that are doing better
than us whether it's germany or france
or estonia
or austria or sweden or
canada or australia have different
systems they're all
free at the point of delivery all free i
mean i've
been a beneficiary of the canadian
system and it's an insurance based
system but it's free at the point
delivery and it's supported by the state
if you can't afford it
and it works better than our system
and i think we need to look at those
other systems and learn from and stay
with the fundamental principles of the
health service but actually learn and
improve what we have i'm i'm just about
to sit down so she'll forgive me so we
need to rebuild ourselves we on this
side need to rebuild ourselves as a
party of low taxes as a party of and for
homeowners as a party of aspiration and
opportunity and security it's time for a
new model conservatism fit for a new
britain in a new world
so jeffrey donaldson yeah thank you
madam deputy speaker and it's a pleasure
to follow the member for haltom price
and haydn and thank you for the support
that he has given to us over the years
in northern ireland in particular
and can i also add my voice on behalf of
my
uh my honourable and honorable friends
and the people of northern ireland in uh
paying tribute to her majesty the queen
in this her platinum jubilee year
and in particular on behalf of the
residents of royal hillsborough and my
constituency we look forward to her
majesty being able to travel to northern
ireland again in the near future and to
stay with us in hillsborough
and and meet again with the very proud
citizens of that village
who have recently been accorded
royal status
uh madam deputy speaker much has been
said already and i think it is important
that as the government goes forward
there is a focus on the health
of our citizens and on the cost of
living crisis in particular and recently
in the assembly elections the local
political parties in northern ireland
were very much focused on these issues
and i as i campaigned across northern
ireland i met many people who are
concerned about uh
their ability to pay their bills
or about how long they're going to be
waiting uh on our health waiting lists
sadly we have the longest waiting lists
in the united kingdom even though we pay
more per capita
into the health service than any other
part of the united kingdom and that i
think flags up the need for
reform of our health care system in
northern ireland alongside much needed
investment in that system and we as a
party are committed to this we're also
committed to ensuring that measures that
the government bring forward here at
westminster
are applied to all parts of the united
kingdom in terms of supporting
hard-pressed families working families
during this cost of living crisis and i
hope that any measures that are
introduced by the government and that
any spending commitments that apply to
those um are
applied across the united kingdom and of
course um that the barn consequentials
are made available to the northern
ireland executive
and it is a matter of regret uh madam
deputy speaker that at this moment in
time we do have a political crisis in
northern ireland
and that political crisis is born out of
the reality that once the government
talks about in brexit taking back
control of our borders our money and our
laws in respect of northern ireland
are part of the united kingdom we have
not yet completed that journey
as the right honourable member for
east antrim reminded us
i've now been elected to a northern
ireland assembly which is the
legislature for northern ireland uh
dealing with those devolved matters that
are not uh principally a matter for this
house and yet many of the regulations
that apply to trade in northern ireland
to business in northern ireland are
enacted by the european
parliament by the european commission
and no not a single citizen of northern
ireland not a single elected
representative in northern ireland has
any say in how those regulations are
drawn up so we haven't entirely taken
back control of our laws
isn't it a disgrace that we can want to
cut vat in the united kingdom but we're
not allowed to to cut it in northern
ireland in what sense are they honoring
our internal market and our
constitutional arrangements
of course the right honourable member is
correct and they are not and you know
i've listened to
some members of congress for example um
lecture us on the need
to abide by the protocol to implement
the protocol and yet this is a nation
that was founded on a campaign of no
taxation without representation and what
have we in northern ireland we have tax
laws on vat for example that apply to
northern and we've no representation in
how those laws are enacted
that is not the essence of democracy
and it's important because in this queen
speech
the government indicates measures that
they intend to take to help small
businesses for example um to
reduce regulations to alter the way that
business is regulated and that's one of
the benefits of leaving the european
union we have more control how we
regulate our businesses
but that won't apply to northern ireland
because we are regulated by the european
union for the manufacture of goods for
example we have to comply with eu
standards which means divergence from
our main market which is great britain
we purchase four times more goods from
great britain than we do from the
european union in its entirety and we
sell far more goods to great britain
than we do to the whole of the european
union as well and yet we find this rec
border
this trade border within our own country
is harming our economy is damaging our
the ability of our businesses to expand
to invest it's costing them more i
recently heard from one company a small
business in manufacturing in newton
abbey in the constituency of the
honourable member for south antrim
they tell me that in the first year of
the operation of the northern ireland
protocol the additional cost in bringing
component parts from great britain the
transportation costs the delays in
getting those goods in the additional
paperwork the customs fees
amounts to over 100 000 pounds for that
small business alone that's costing them
jobs it means they can't invest in the
expansion of their business this is
harming business in northern ireland and
peace and prosperity go hand in hand
a a stable northern ireland doesn't just
depend on the absence of violence it
depends on the growth of our economy on
creating jobs for our young people of
giving them hope for the future and the
protocol is harming our ability to do
that because it's harming our access to
our biggest market in great britain
of course i thank the right honourable
gentleman for giving way and i i
absolutely hear the passion in his voice
and the anger and it must be so
frustrating for the community in in
northern ireland i was interested
hearing marks and spencer's being quoted
about the additional on costs that
they're facing in terms of the selling
of their products in northern ireland
relative to see the mainland and but can
i just ask and this is not supposed to
be a difficult question
but what was it that the prime minister
promised
to
his party when he when the prime
minister addressed the party back in
williams in 2019 i think autumn 2019 did
he make it clear what was the reality
behind what he would do in negotiating
with the eu
well i can uh answer the the member
quite clearly
the prime minister came to our party
conference and told us uh there would be
an rc border quote over his dead body
that's what he told us and unfortunately
the protocol created an irish sea border
and it is harming uh our economy now
i am only asking the prime minister to
honor the commitments that he has given
to us i'm not asking him to do anything
more than that and and the honourable
member made reference to supermarkets
can i just point out the absurdity of
what this protocol means sainsbury is
one of the biggest supermarket chains in
northern ireland it has no supermarkets
in the republic of ireland
and yet when saiyans removed the goods
they're even their own brand products
from great britain to northern ireland
for sale in sainsbury's supermarkets in
in my part of the united kingdom they
have to complete customs declarations
pay fees there's a delay in moving those
goods which is you will know for food
products can be vital that delay and it
costs them more and that is driving up
the cost of food in northern ireland for
example a chilled
food products it's estimated that the
additional cost as a result of the
protocol is 18
in comparison with the the same products
in great britain and as uh the
honourable member uh reminded us earlier
in this debate um the rhode haulage
association have said that the cost of
bringing goods from great britain to
northern as a direct result of the
protocol has gone up 27 in the first
year of its operation there can be no
other impact of that additional cost
than to drive up the cost for the
consumer of purchasing products in our
supermarkets and in our shops that is
the reality and when people say that
it's a nonsense to link the cost of
living
to the protocol then the evidence is
stark and it is clear
yes there is a cost of living crisis in
great britain but it is exacerbated in
northern ireland it is enhanced in
northern ireland by
the the
presence of the protocol and the
presence of the rac border that's why
madam deputy speaker i have had to take
the reluctant decision as leader of the
democratic unionist party not to
nominate ministers to the executive
until this issue has been uh
addressed because we're being asked to
implement a protocol don't forget it's
ministers in northern ireland who
oversee the ports we are the people who
are required to implement to oversee
this and it is simply not fair that as
unionists we're asked to engage in an
act of self-harm against our own people
in northern ireland with with the
implementation imposition of our
protocol which we do not accept do not
support and we do not believe is
necessary in order either to protect the
integrity of the uk internal market or
the integrity of the eu single market i
thank the writers of general for giving
way he he may remember
that the reason i resigned as brexit
secretary went back to a previous prime
minister a promising full alignment that
was the phrase between the north and the
south and it seemed to me at the time
that the outcome of that was that
northern ireland would have no more
legislative power than a colony
because it had no ability to correct the
sorts of problems he's now talking
and is it not the case is his argument
that for as long as that stands this
will make northern ireland not more
stable but less stable well that is
absolutely the case and the european
union told us including the irish
government a co-guarantor of the belfast
agreement argued that the necessity for
the protocol was to protect the good
friday agreement and the political
institutions created under it madam
deputy speaker it has had the opposite
effect there is no north-south
ministerial council operating at this
time uh the executive is not fully
functioning the assembly is unable to
carry out its full functions and
east-west relations between the united
kingdom and the republic of ireland are
at an all-time low since uh as far back
as i can remember so can we not see the
harm the protocol is doing to the
relationships that are at the heart of
the agreement but it goes further madam
deputy speaker
the court of appeal in belfast has ruled
that the protocol changes our
constitutional status it overrides
article six of the acts of union
now this is a fundamental building block
of our relationship with the rest of the
united kingdom
the union is not just a political union
it is an economic union
and article 6 confess on the people of
northern ireland previously the people
of the whole of the island when it was
all part of the united kingdom confers
the right to trade freely with the rest
of our own
nation article 6 says there shall be no
barriers to trade within the united
kingdom yet we now have an irc border we
have barriers to trade article 6 has
been breached and overridden by the
protocol without the consent of the
people of northern ireland to such
constitutional change and that is
contrary to the commitment in article 1
of the belfast agreement which says
there shall be no change to the
constitutional status of northern
ireland without the consent of the
people of northern ireland so i think
the prime minister is right
in the queen's speech today to to
highlight the need
to
prioritize support for the agreement and
its institutions
including through legislation now the
legislation referred here is only to the
legacy of the past
and as
the this house will be aware we have
great concerns about the um initial
proposals put forward by the government
because it denies to innocent victims
the right to justice which we think is
wrong
you never create peace i do not believe
is built uh on the basis of injustice
uh and we await with interest
the the government's revised proposals
but sadly there is no reference to
legislation in the queen's speech on the
need to address the very real
difficulties being created by the
protocol madam deputy speaker that's
what we are looking for we're looking
for that commitment from the government
the prime minister's first duty as
minister for the union is to protect the
integrity of the united kingdom and
indeed in the queen's speech and i quote
it states the continued success and
integrity of the whole of the united
kingdom is a paramount importance to my
government including the internal
economic bonds between all of its parts
the prime minister is the prime minister
of the united kingdom of great britain
and northern ireland and those three
words are the most important words for
me in my constitutional status and
northern arm we are an integral part of
the united kingdom and when the
government says it is of paramount
importance to protect the internal
economic bonds between all of its parts
then that has to include madam deputy
speaker
northern ireland that means addressing
the protocol because the protocol is
incompatible with these two commitments
it is incompatible with upholding and
protecting the internal economic bonds
between all parts of the united kingdom
and it is incompatible with prioritizing
support for the belfast or good friday
agreement and the political institutions
which are being undermined by this not a
single unionist elected to the assembly
supports
the protocol not a single one and yet
the good friday agreement is premised uh
on the basis that the institutions will
operate through consensus there is no
consensus for this protocol the unionist
community does not consent to the
protocol i will not allow my ministers
to be put in a position where they have
to impose upon their own people uh
checks and regulations over which they
have no control and no say and that have
been created by a foreign entity the
european union
in conclusion madam deputy speaker
i want to be clear and in response to
the honourable right honourable member
for rothsteil my party is absolutely
committed to the future of the political
institutions we want them to work and to
deliver for everyone in northern ireland
my party is committed to the operation
of those institutions we are committed
to our participation in those
institutions but it has to be on the
basis of fairness it has to be on the
basis of a consensus it has to be on the
basis that we address the problems that
are in front of us
and that have flown from the imposition
of the northern iron protocol
last uh thursday i stood for election in
my constituency of lagon valley i've had
the honour madam deputy speaker
representing uh this beautiful
constituency for the past 25 years in
this house
but i believe in northern ireland i
believe in the future and i believe i
can play a role in strengthening the
political institutions and that's why
in in response to the points that have
been made i'm prepared to commit
the remainder of my political career
to going back to those institutions and
working with my colleagues to make them
work i am prepared to leave this house
i've been a member of for 25 years and
which i would dearly love to continue
being a part of because i want to invest
in the future of our people i want to
work for our people i want to deliver
good government
but i have to say to you madam deputy
speaker i will not leave this house
until this protocol issue is resolved i
will not leave this house until i can be
sure that our political institutions in
northern ireland have have a stable
foundation that means and i say this in
conclusion to the government
the words in the queen's speech are
there
but they have to be matched by actions
of course i'll give away well no friend
has made the point that he will remain
in this house i feel it is right that he
does remain in this house particularly
at this juncture in northern ireland's
constitutional and economic economic
place within this united kingdom whilst
there are those who
feel they can speak for unionism
they are not the people that speak for
unionism you are the leader of unionism
therefore it is vital that you remain in
this house until this government honor
their commitment uh to restoring
northern ireland's place within this
united kingdom and in truth you are only
adhering to the mandate that our
electorate gave to us last thursday in
doing so
ordered just before the honorable
jennifer i didn't want to interrupt the
honorable ladies of what what she was
saying because it was very powerful but
she really mustn't call the honorable
gentleman you three times in the chamber
he's he
so perhaps she would just like to give
her last line again
saying he
it is absolutely vitally important that
he remains in this place to ensure that
northern ireland's place within this uh
united kingdom is constitutionally and
economically restored
well deputy speaker i really appreciate
the intervention of the honourable
member for upper band and congratulate
her colleagues in the constituency for
their success in the assembly elections
the dup the democratic unionist party
re-entered the executive at the
beginning of 2020 on the basis of an
agreement called new decade new approach
at the heart of that agreement for us
is the commitment by the uk government
given by the then secretary of state to
protect northern ireland's place within
the uk internal market
some two and a half years later that
commitment has not been honored and yet
in the queen speech today two other
elements of the new decade new approach
agreement have been uh referenced by the
secretary of state for northern ireland
that is the legacy of our past and
legislation linked there too and we are
told by the secretary of state he will
introduce a bill on language and culture
well i have to say to the secretary of
state
that if he proceeds to introduce that
legislation without um the government
moving to deal with the protocol it will
be the government will be in serious
breach of its obligations under new
decade new approach it will be moving in
a one-sided fashion in a non-balanced
way and that is not the way to build
consensus it is not the way in the words
of the queen's speech to prioritize
support for the belfast agreement and
its institutions what the government
must do has to be balanced it must take
account of the concerns of the unionist
community as well as the consent the
concerns of others
currently the legislation coming forward
reflects the concerns of others but it
does not reflect the concerns of the
members in this house who represent the
unionist community or of the wider
community and so i i reiterate my
commitment
to
lead my party into the political
institutions and i will do so as soon as
the government takes decisive action to
deal with this protocol and to remove
the irish sea border yeah
dame andreas
thank you madam deputy speaker and it's
a great pleasure to follow the right
honourable gentleman the member for
lagan valley who has spoken very
powerfully of his commitment to the
union which i very much share
madame deputy speaker i'd like to start
by paying huge tribute to her majesty
the queen and to wish her a very speedy
recovery
and and to regret very much that she was
not able to attend the other place in
person today but also to um to pay
tribute to the to the speech that was
given on her behalf i think it was it
was very positive very optimistic and i
absolutely will be delighted to support
the government in implementing it and
why is that because we as the
conservative party is the government
truly do believe in opportunities and i
think that opportunities and a hand up
ran through the queen's speech today in
full measure and i was delighted to see
that i think there is a lot in there
that will enable people right across our
country to find their lives better and
their opportunities greater
and i want to just um touch on a couple
of the specific measures that have been
announced today starting with the
leveling up bill
and i want to focus rather selfishly on
my own wonderful constituency of south
northamptonshire because we're very
often seen as a lovely
midlands area
in the middle of england
we are quite mixed we have the fabulous
silverstone circuit
we have motorsport valley and high-tech
engineering we've got some fabulous
rugby sides and cricketing sides and
some great football teams and it is a
wonderful place to work and to live but
we also madam deputy speaker have quite
a few problems
one of those which is one of our assets
is that i am fortunate to represent 92
villages
and parishes
and
sadly very few
bus links
and so in my constituency wonderful as
it is for many young people leveling up
to them would mean actually being able
to get the bus to work or to school and
so i'm really hoping that with some of
the measures the government takes to
level up there will be many more bus
routes made available so that young
people and yes people who don't
necessarily reach for a car as their
first
thought will actually be able to get
around on the bus and i urge the
government to do everything in that
regard
secondly planning living in south
northamptonshire we are in the middle of
england as i say we're between the m1
and the m40 the a43 runs through we are
the rat run of choice for every hgv
whenever there is congestion on the m1
or the m40
and frankly
as a result of being the
logistics central for hgvs passing
through they now want to park themselves
in south northamptonshire so we are
under massive threat from huge
warehousing applications which are
completely inappropriate for the area
there's plenty of logistics and
warehousing dotted around but please
madam deputy speaker i implore the
government to ensure that local
communities will be able to resist
inappropriate warehousing development
that would literally concrete over the
beautiful areas of northampton and
toaster and brackley we are very much
under threat
the third pledge i'd like to make on
behalf or the third plea i would like to
make on behalf of south northamptonshire
is that about demographic growth
again because we're a lovely area people
want to move there and they are most
welcome we are absolutely open for
newcomers from all over the place but
together with the new housing newcomers
coming in the new um school pupils the
new jobs needed and so on we never
ever receive our fair share of funding
for anything whether it's for the
hospital whether it's for gps whether
it's for school places and i understand
that there is a lag but i do urge the
government to consider those places that
are growing in population very very
quickly so that they too can get some of
the funding that's desperately needed
so i just wanted to make those pleas for
south northlands but of course leveling
up is about the whole country and it's a
huge opportunity right across the united
kingdom and i want to mention here the
energy security bill an absolutely
brilliant initiative by the government
to ensure that not only is our energy in
the future
cleaner and greener but also that we can
make our fortune in the world using our
strengths in energy and in innovation in
the renewable space in the nuclear space
and in the technology space i'm
delighted to give way to the honourable
gentleman thank you very much for for
what you've seen so far can i uh
agree with what durability is saying and
reiterate the position that northern
ireland has in recent
hydrogen as one of the uh new energy
systems that we can all use to benefit i
am very uh pleased to hear the
commitment from the right honourability
to all of the united kingdom when it
comes to leveling up northern ireland
has to be part of that as well
well i completely agree with the
honourable gentleman and i will be
coming on to that just shortly but what
he says about
the prospects for hydrogen power in
northern ireland is music to my ears and
i think that's a good example of some of
the measures the governments are putting
in place to ensure that we can green up
and grow our energy security and our
energy accessibility but at the same
time grow green growth and jobs and the
beauty of that madam deputy speaker
coming as i do from the financial
services sector before parliament having
spent 25 years in financial services
that was always considered the jewel in
the crown for the uk economy but of
course those jobs were quite
specifically in areas like the city like
edinburgh like in bournemouth like in
birmingham but not widespread across the
country and they tended to be a little
bit specialized not for everyone but of
course with the green technology sector
there are jobs for everyone there are
new apprenticeships for young people in
perhaps installing electric car
infrastructure in installing solar
panels there are jobs for people coming
from the industrial clusters in the
north and in scotland who might be
wanting to retrain to work on offshore
wind
stations or indeed on carbon capture
usage and storage so there are lots of
opportunities and of course for the
brilliant scientists and the
universities across the united kingdom
who are developing new technologies in
the green space so jobs and growth i
believe the green space could be even
bigger than financial services in the
years to come and if i was a betting
person which i'm not madam deputy
speaker i would bet that by 2030 there
will be more people employed in the uk
across the green technology sector than
there are today in financial services
and i do hope that the government will
remain absolutely committed to that
agenda and i will give way
thank the member for giving way and then
say and and mentioning about the green
economy and everything everything
associated with it and i don't
necessarily want to green northern
ireland by the way and i'm talking about
politically and not just about
that
but i wanted to say it's from the point
of view that we have uh
technology which is passive housing
and we should be driving that forward we
should be leading the world in
developing passive housing reducing the
need for carbon and
carbon uh
burning within our properties to keep
them warm and we do have the technology
and the availability to why do we not
use building regulations rules to impose
that upon new development 100 000 houses
have to be built every year let's say
can we drive that agenda forward and
reduce our carbon footprint
dramatically oh the honourable gentleman
is of course absolutely right and there
is already legislation in place to to
put new requirements on house builders
to reduce the carbon footprint of new
homes and i think those will tighten up
as time goes by and there are so many as
uh as he and his honorable colleague
have have already pointed out there are
so many different green initiatives and
i do hope that that becomes the way that
we make our living in the world through
jobs at home and exports overseas
i would like to go on madame deputy
speaker to talk about the third area
that i really want to highlight from the
queen's speech today and that is the
pledges towards the union and for me as
a proud conservative and unionist party
member
for me keeping the union together is
what it's all about there is no doubt in
my mind that it is the union of england
scotland wales and northern ireland that
is so precious to all of us and we make
a grave mistake in fact madam deputy
speaker i simply cannot understand why
separatists want to break apart our
union
it makes to me no sense whatsoever this
is a fabulous place where we have
centuries of shared history shared
family shared culture shared language a
shared currency shared institutions and
i will give way to the honourable lady i
thank the honourable leader for giving
away a number of bills in fact a whole
range of bills in the queen's speech
today it fly in the face of standing
orders number 9b
in in in the scottish parliament and and
of the sewell convention which requires
legislative consent from the scottish
parliament to these range of bills does
she think that riding roughshod and
imposing these bills against the wishes
of the scottish parliament will
strengthen or weaken the union
what i would say to the honourable lady
is that i think she as a separatist
wants nothing more than to see the uk
government setting out any sort of
possibility whatsoever that she can
argue against with some sort of fake
grievance what i want to do is to appeal
to the fabulous people of the united
kingdom
let's stick together and i have some
ideas madam deputy speaker i think we
should share rights to one another's
health systems because actually in wales
there are serious problems with wealth
welsh healthcare and i would like
nothing more than to see welsh citizens
able to access england's healthcare
system or indeed scotland's healthcare
system whenever they want to
and indeed that of northern ireland and
vice versa
i would also love to see school
exchanges right across the uk
so that children as they're growing up
can actually develop a better sense of
the unity of the united kingdom
and i would love to see consideration
given to more free ports around the
united kingdom and very particularly to
consider a free port that could
potentially encompass the whole of
northern ireland because as one part of
the uk that really does need and deserve
a huge boost to jobs to growth and to
opportunities i think a freeport that
gives beneficial tax status and makes
sure that northern ireland is absolutely
integrally joined and feeling a part of
the united kingdom would be something
that i would love to see i will give way
to the honorable thank the lord for
giving away again and and most gracious
not really is putting out a a good
argument on behalf of the united kingdom
of great britain and northern ireland
always better together and i agree with
vulnerability uh but to make that happen
the northern ireland protocol has to be
addressed does the owner really commit
herself
in this chamber to ensuring that the
northern ireland protocol has done away
with and that we in northern ireland
have the same rights as everyone else in
this house
well i can say to the honourable
gentleman that i share his concern about
the northern ireland protocol and i am
absolutely determined that there should
be no barriers to internal trade or any
other form of union between all of those
component parts of the united kingdom
and i will give way indeed does she
think it might be a good idea given how
the eu always wants everything in
northern ireland to be aligned with the
republic that we should add to that
freeport the same corporation tax rate
as the republic of ireland has because
that seems to be the one thing to me
they're actually getting right
well i think my honorable friend makes a
very good point and and really that sort
of
emphasizes my view that potentially
northern ireland could be considered as
a freeport to have a beneficial
corporation tax and other regimes in
order to encourage more jobs and growth
and more spread of business right across
the united kingdom so i agree with my
honorable friend but i do want to finish
off madame deputy speaker by talking a
bit about what i think is the greatest
to madam deputy speakers how wonderful
um by talking about what i think is the
greatest leveling up policy and it won't
come as any surprise to anyone in this
chamber that it's going to be about the
best start for life and and of course
when we human beings are born
we do not have any cognition whatsoever
we don't know
that that's our mum we don't know that
we're wet or cold or tired or hungry or
bored we don't know anything we just
know no the honourable lady says course
we know someone we don't actually as a
baby you do not know it's your mum you
know that that is a person an important
you know that that is an important
creature to you but you do not know that
that is very important to uh make that
distinction babies adapt to the
environment in which they find
themselves and so it is absolutely
critical in everything we do if we want
to level up that we provide support for
families of all shapes and sizes to be
able to give their babies the best start
for life and it's by doing that by
providing support for families who
perhaps don't understand about sleeping
crying weaning who perhaps have their
own relationship difficulties with their
other partner because of the stresses of
a new baby in the household
perhaps people who don't know what a
baby's stage of development should be
and therefore perhaps missing some
important problem with their tiny baby
that could that could be easily resolved
if tackled straight away so much much
better support i know is a shared desire
right across this house and i think
nothing could be more important for
leveling up than giving every baby the
best start for life thank you madam
deputy speaker
john trickett
very much indeed and listening to this
debate carefully
uh and speaking from one of the villages
in the heart of england in yorkshire
it's occasionally very difficult to
recognize the descriptions of england
which have been england and britain
which have emerged during the afternoon
but before i develop my argument i just
want to refer to the fact that it's more
than five months now since i've been
able to
uh speak in the house for medical
reasons
i had a bad accident in the new year but
also two of my closest uh relations fell
seriously and critically ill one was on
life support for nine days and i was
able to
see
hand
the miracles which performed on an
hourly or even minute by minute basis
by nurses and doctors in the intensive
care unit in pinterfields hospital
in wakefield and
i will never
my center of gratitude will never
diminish what i saw it was quite
incredible
and same with the
pediatrics
unit at the lgi in leeds who've been
looking after
uh a young member of our family
and i hope the house won't mind if i
mentioned my own surgeon uh mr venkatash
at chapel alton hospital in leeds who
managed to get me up and walking faster
than i imagined would be possible
now
there were times when i was in hospital
well it felt as if i was running a
surgery the casework surgery because
when people discovered i was a member of
parliament and i was like laid up they
took advantage of following a queue
to uh
lobbing me on all kinds of things but
the thing which was most frequently
raised with me
was the state of the nhs the staff the
clinicians the orderlies the cleaners
the patients all came up to me and spoke
to me about the nhs and when we heard
the prime minister earlier saying he's
putting record amounts of money into the
national health service i just want to
give this message not from me but from
the clinicians and all those people who
spoke to me in those quite intense
moments when i was there trying to
recover from the anesthetic
and what they said was the money isn't
getting to us absolutely
our incomes are low and being held back
they said that there was a scourge of
restructuring
going on all the time preventing them
from getting on with the business of
providing the kind of level of care that
they wanted to provide
and also they were fed up with
outsourcing
and they asked me to tell the house of
commons
uh there were their views and i captured
them in all honesty i happen to agree
with them but that's beside the point
now i want to just then just uh move on
to
the leveling up
the question of leveling up i mean one
might ask the question why is it that
after 12 years of tory government in
fact it's necessary
uh
for the government now suddenly to say
what we need to level up
i want to refer to
my constituency but to illustrate a
national
or series of national problems
and
there are
two aspects i want to raise in relation
to that first is inequality of income
now if you look at the average income
in my constituency it's 250 pounds a
week less
on the average
than the amount of money which is earned
in wastes and salaries in the prime
minister's constituency
it's a staggering amount of money top
and half thousand pounds a year per
person working in a full-time occupation
and how can that level of inequality be
justified and i'm sure there are many
people in the house on this side and in
in other parties in labour who've got
similar problems in their constituencies
how was it that that came about after 12
years
of a tory uh government and i want to
come later to suggest what might be done
but the second point i wanted to mention
again about my constituency but it
raises a wider question and the writer
will remember for helton price so isn't
he ceased now in his seat now mentioned
social mobility well look
the british are told if you work hard
play by the rules and you have even a
minimum of talent you should be able to
get on in life that's what we told
and that's what this promise of social
mobility is but the truth is the
government established a social mobility
commission
what happened they all resigned because
they said that social mobility had come
to an end in britain
now my constituency there are 533 seats
in england
mine is the 529th
least socially mobile constituency in
the whole of england and i speak not
only for my constituency but for all
those seats across the north of england
in the south west and elsewhere where
social mobility has come to an end and
it breaks my heart
to think of a child born in one of those
hospitals today
which i went through the experience of
in my constituency born into a family in
deprivational poverty
who faces a shorter life than people may
do elsewhere more prosperous areas
but a life in which they will die in
poverty
breaks my heart
to think that's where we are and so
let me know
it's a spurious rhetoric rhetorical
device that the government has developed
to try to pull her up
for the failures of the last 12 years
in office
what you have
in a society which is profoundly unequal
now
where the billionaires are floating on a
sea of riches while there are millions
of people
living in poverty and children too
and families at work
is a profoundly unequal society but when
you put an inequality
together with the lack of social
mobility what do you have you have a
class structure the old british disease
ossified
unchanging and built
on a system which enriches a few and
leaves so many millions of people
behind now what does the
what does the uh the government's
program offer
well i say it offers more of the poison
which created the situation which we're
now in
and pretends it solution
because what created the situation was
tory economic policies austerity
what we call
neoliberal economics and market
triumphanism
all of those things are at the root of
the problems which face communities such
as mine and those across the north of
england
and elsewhere and what the speech
pretends to do is to suggest that
government
the state can take an active role in
leveling up offering social mobility and
a route out of poverty to be for people
in the constituencies like mine but that
is not what it's been offered is it what
we've been offering is more
marketization
more cuts more austerity
planning laws being wet swept away in
order to deliver more marketization and
then deregulation
all of the defects which have created
the problem which have left so many
communities behind that's what's on
offer that's one of what's offering
these
in this queen's speech and i'm sure that
ministers in the quiet of their own
homes their consciences may say to them
well we do have a problem
but the key workers in the nhs and
elsewhere who kept this country going
through the pandemic have been let have
been abandoned on low pay pay rises
which are totally unacceptable while
prices
uh
accelerating
now i want to come back to my
constituency as i begin to wind up
if you calculate
how to
how much money you need to level up my
constituency to the prime minister's
it's an astonishing amount of money
a fifth of a billion pounds a year
is what would be required to pay
people in my area the same as the uh
in the prime ministers
if you were to try to get halfway there
it would cost you 100 million pounds a
year
the staggering amounts of money
what does the government offer
it offers a chancellor who never
hesitates to boast how he is a state a
small state kind of guy but what's
required is an active intervention in
the market
in order to begin to change the
levels of deprivation poverty
and the difficulties which arise which
are the source of so many problems the
breakdown of cohesion
um
and the other issues the anger which we
see in politics today
200 million pounds a year
to pay people in my constituency the
same as they already earn
down in
in the prime ministers
i there is only one answer to this and
that's a marshall plan a martial
on the scale of what happened after the
second world war in order to begin to
tackle the underlying problem anything
else is just rhetoric designed to
persuade people
maybe to give the tourists one more more
chance and before anybody jumps up
though i see that nobody is doing to say
that we can't pay for it this is one of
the richest country in this world but
where is that well
where is that wealth it's not in areas
across the north and elsewhere
it's in the hands of a very small group
of people and a tiny group of
corporations it's time to introduce a
wealth tax and by the way while i'm
talking about it
why is it
that money earned from wealth or from
property is taxed less
than
than money earned from work
why do we privilege wealth and capital
over labor
why is it our fiscal systems like that
we could raise more money to begin to
create a kind of a martial aid plan
all of these all of those things are
possible but we have to first of all the
house has to face the truth this is a
profoundly divided society a restless
and angry society which wants change
my final point is this
my very final point is this
in a society with divisions running so
it's not surprising
that the levels of consent
and consensus
which a democratic country requires in
order to be governed
they are breaking down
dissent is emerging dissent is emerging
because of the lack of social justice
which i've tried to explain from the
point of view of my constituency
now what's the government's response to
that is it to try to create a more
socially just society no it isn't it's
to actually try to crack down on dissent
last parliamentary session we've passed
some horrendously authoritarian
legislation and now we've seen the queen
speech today more is being proposed let
me tell you say this
authoritarianism will never resolve the
problems of a breakdown in consent in a
society which people feel profoundly
uneasy about because of how it treats
them that's my final point
so john redwood
speaker i have declared my business
interest in the register
i welcome a lot in this gracious speech
i welcome the emphasis on growth
we need growth to deliver many of the
other ambitions for leveling up and for
better public services
i think the government are right they
need to revisit the rules and laws to
promote better transport
uh to deal with difficulties in housing
and planning
and to pursue a course of greater
self-sufficiency
in energy
but i'd like to concentrate mainly on
the economic conditions that the
government is going to need over the
next two years
to make a success of this legislative
program
legislation only gets you a little way
what you're trying to do by legislation
is create conditions in which business
can flourish people can train and get
better skills that they can get into
better paid jobs investments can be made
and we won't level up all the mighty
cities and towns of this country that
are below average with public spending
we need to level them up with ambition
and private investment and people going
on their own personal journeys so that
they can develop a business of their own
they can get to the point where they can
afford a house of their own that they uh
have sufficient trading and
qualifications that they can get a
decent high quality job that is the way
the successful parts of the country have
got many more people into higher incomes
and better living standards
because those parts of the country have
worked
and have attracted the people with the
energy and the talent or given the
people already there more support and we
need to look at how we can give that
support and that encouragement more
widely around the country
i'm so grateful to my right honourable
friend for giving way because what he is
saying is echoing the words
of the mayor of the west midlands andy
street who said it cannot be governments
that create wealth we merely have to
provide the opportunity for businesses
and individuals to create that wealth
well i'm a grad all three of us agree on
on this thing
and we can proceed on that basis
so what does the government need to do
well my first recommendation to my right
honourable friend the chancellor
is that he needs to have a new framework
for the conduct of our economic policy
we are still running on maastricht light
we still think that the way to control
the economy is to control the debt and
deficit i've got news for him if we get
growth and inflation right the debt and
deficit will come closer to taking care
of themselves
we need to get the growth right and we
then have much less of a problem with
the debt and deficit in the last year
when the united kingdom led the growth
tables for the advanced world
an unremarkable thing happened it seemed
very remarkable to the treasury
unremarkable to me the deficit came
tumbling down
uh on one set of figures and they're
still keeping on changing them uh the
deficit came in at 90 billion below the
obr and treasury forecast
because with more growth you get more
activity more incomes more spending so
you collect more vat you collect more
income tax and it was mainly extra
revenues that came in because we had
that faster growth
so i say that the debt and deficit
matters but they should be subsidiary
the two main names of economic policy
should be first of all a two percent
inflation target embedded as a
government target as well as a control
mechanism on the bank of england and
that should be complemented by a two
percent growth target
uh not that exactly by 20th century
spirits in the united kingdom quite
challenging by the current century's
experience because of the disfiguring
effect of the big banking crash and
great recession uh in the middle of the
first two decades
of the current century
first of all inflation
inflation
once it gets out of control is extremely
damaging to everything it in it ends up
giving you shortages on your shelves
lack of supply businesses crashing
people being thrown out of jobs you do
not want to get into accelerating double
figure inflation
that some countries have suffered all
too much
and if you want to see what happens with
the playbook just look at what's
happening in turkey at the moment look
at what has happened on a grotesque
scale in venezuela where
the generous state kept printing and
kept borrowing and it's ended up
destroying over half the the national
income of the country and destroying
much of the potential of the oil
industry which used to pay for
everything because it was nationalized
and incompetently run so you need to
rule out those extreme versions and of
course you need to control the amount of
money you create
and you need to
keep an open eye on when you can afford
to borrow in the public sector and how
much but that is a second order issue to
promoting
growth and inflation as the prime aims
but the inflation target
cannot simply be delivered by a central
bank
unfortunately the bank of england i
think made a policy error and it was one
that i pointed out beforehand
last year because i think it went on
printing money for longer than it should
have done its policy was too loose for
too long i was fully behind its huge
injection of money and ultra low
interest rates the previous year because
of huge shock administered to the
economy but it now looks as if they made
a mistake they have now corrected that
they shouldn't overdo it they are no
longer printing any money toward in
excess
and they have put up interest rates on
three separate occasions and money
growth is now much more constrained in
our country
but you do need government as well to
put its shoulder to the wheel
to curb various types of inflation and
at the moment one of the inflationary
factors hitting particularly the budgets
of those in the lower income areas
are the the huge price inflations in
energy and food
and these are supply shortages
we were already pretty short of energy
in western europe because of the
policies being pursued
and because of the lack of natural
resource on the continent where they
don't have
any or much oil and gas outside the
netherlands
we're already very short of basic energy
and then of course the
the dreadful invasion of ukraine came
along and caused so much damage
most directly to the people there who
have such
dreadful shocks from it but a wider
economic shock to the rest of us and
as a result of policy
russian oil and gas has been gradually
withdrawn from our supply system so
we've exacerbated the shortage for
understandable and good political
reasons to try and help ukraine
in its battle against the russian
invasion
and if we look at food
we we see a shortage of rising as
markets are heralding
uh the sad likelihood that there won't
be a lot of crop coming out of ukraine
this year and so a very big source
of edible oils and of
grains
will not be producing and exporting in
the way the world market needs and so we
we see great price pressures there
so you need to engage government and the
government i'm pleased to see is is
working towards more energy
self-sufficiency and more food
production but these are crucial
as a response to what has just happened
and as a security for the future if you
want to keep inflation down in the
future
uh the one thing you can rely on is if
you produce more of your own energy and
if you grow more of your own food and
you will then have more control over the
pricing particularly with something like
gas because of course gas
is only traded on the world market to
the extent
that there is either pipeline capacity
or lng capacity so a lot of gas cannot
be traded internationally american gas
cannot be sent to europe in huge
quantities because there is no pipeline
and there's a limited amount of lng
capacity so america has much lower gas
prices and has nothing like the the
energy cost of living problem that we
have
as a result of producing a lot of its
own gas
and therefore having a domestic market
which clears at a lower price than the
current very spiked world prices for gas
so i trust the the government will
pursue
greater national self-sufficiency in key
areas and this not only includes basic
energy
and food where we can grow a lot more of
our temperate food but it also includes
crucial technologies uh which the
government is becoming increasingly
sensitive about
so i trust that when the government
turns its mind to the detail of its
energy legislation
it will facilitate by that legislation
the production of more domestic oil and
gas
i think there's more general agreement
today after the debates of recent months
with the proposition that we ought to
re-enter the north sea and instead of
a pretty rapid run down in its output we
should for a transitional period maybe
this decade uh get more on gas out of
the north sea it surely makes a lot of
sense it makes green sense because the
co2 output created by burning your own
gas is considerably less uh than the
elaborate process of carrying it halfway
around the world having
compressed it and decompressed it so
that it can travel as lng
it's about half the co2 generated by
burning your own gas but more
importantly for the point of view of
leveling up and growth and our public
finances
we pay the tax to ourselves all gas and
oil attracts massive taxation from the
countries that have the good fortune to
reduce it
and so if if we buy gas from qatar or
when we were buying uh oil from russia
we are paying them a huge amount of tax
which is revenue we could pay to
ourselves and our own treasury
could either spend or give back to us in
some other form as a rebate or grant
if we'd develop more of our own
production but there is the more
sensitive issue about onshore gas
where people are often rather opposed to
such an idea and what i would suggest
there is i think that no land owner and
no council should be made to have
onshore gas if they don't want to
and that would be a democratic decision
over permissions and it would be a
a decision of those who had the the land
or the property nearby
as a result but i think some areas would
have it suitably protected and
environmentally tailored as it could be
as we have some
onshore oil and gas already i mean which
farm for example is in a very beautiful
part of the world but it it produces oil
quite happily onshore and i think what
the government needs to do is to put
into law a framework
where landowners and communities that
agree to participate in onshore uh oil
and gas development
should receive a participation of some
sort in the royalty or in
free gas to consumers or whatever in a
good way
what he's saying and he's actually
talking i assume about fracking when he
says onshore gas production
and if you leave it to individual
landowners and local authorities
the pollutive effect of fracking doesn't
stop at the borders of somebody's land
or a local authority border that's
correct it pollutes the aquifers and it
can and does create earth tremors that
go obviously well beyond all of that
it's surely a matter of national policy
that we do not produce or pursue this
short-sighted avenue of trying to get
gas we look at better methods of
conservation and more sustainable
methods of generating our
don't know whether energy right
honourable gentleman has a gas spoiler
but i expect most people in this house
have gas boilers at home most of my
constituents and i have gas boilers and
the gas needs to come from somewhere
i'm not going to go into the details of
the techniques needed for reservoir
management because it obviously depends
upon the structure and the flow rates
and the nature of the
the stratum in which you find the gas
but there are a range of techniques that
can be used
uh if if gas or oil is shy trying to
come out of a reservoir which had been
developed over many years of course like
the right under gentlemen i want that to
be regulated there must be no pollution
of watercourses fortunately gas startup
and water are often well divided in the
united kingdom rather more so than in
the us
where they have had a gas revolution on
shore but have not polluted their water
supplies and have not caused great
environmental health problems so i think
that of course that needs to be properly
regulated it is very strictly regulated
at the moment we need to review those
regulations to make sure that the number
one priority of public safety is
guaranteed but the the number two
desirable effect assuming public safety
is guaranteed that we can get some out
is also taken care of because i thought
the right honourable gentleman would
rather like the idea of a big new source
of
oil or gas tax revenue that stayed in
the united kingdom
rather than being paid to qatar or saudi
arabia in a good way
i'm grateful to my uncle friend for girl
away and i know he and i talked a lot
about community
support for for onshore projects and
would he agree with me that another such
area could be
deep geothermal which the business
backbench committee is at the moment
looking into as offering a fantastic
potential for sourcing new forms of
renewable heating
well i'd love to hear that unfortunately
i was in this debate so i was not able
to get to that particular committee but
i would catch up with my right on your
friend elsewhere because i know you wish
me to
to move on one last point if i may madam
deputy speaker and that is about housing
and planning
and my own constituency working
now we're very generous and and we we
accept a large number of new people
joining our community as they would like
to do and we accept hundreds or even
well over a thousand new houses every
year being constructed in the
constituency
but i don't think we we should want to
keep all that to ourselves i think that
kind of housing that can attract people
who can provide leadership and better
jobs and can set up businesses needs to
be spread more broadly so i think that
the planning rules do need to be revised
so that we can use the planning system
to reinforce the wish to level up with
some of that really important private
sector housing investment going to
places that really need it rather than
having an awful lot in places that have
done pretty well already and are finding
the pressure on
public services and on roads transport
railway and so forth is just too much
and the infrastructure not catching up
so madam deputy speaker a good speech it
needs economic success it needs a policy
based on going for growth it needs a
policy that deals with supply chains
supply side shortages it needs a policy
based around lower taxes because we need
to give something back now to start to
lift the cost of living crunch
amy keller
madden deputy speaker as i rise to
contribute to this debate i want to
thank you and the speaker's office for
your kind words and support during my
recovery
the same gratitude to my colleagues in
these benches and across the house to my
family friends staff
to staff across the state and to my team
and significantly to medics across nhs
greater glasgow and clyde
this has been a long time coming
surgeries tears struggles and some
victories later
i'm standing up for the people of
eastern barchenshire where many doubted
i'd be able to stand at all
you're here
it's on that theme i wish to start
throughout the past two years across our
communities we've seen the best of
people
individuals and groups rising to the
challenge
to support the vulnerable way they
needed it the most
these are the triumphs of our
communities they've been faced with
crisis and the toughest of adversity
good people will respond with honesty
integrity and decency
these are the hallmarks of our society
and the principles that should uphold
our democratic process
we know that due to the actions of some
in this place those principles have been
called into question
i don't wish to expand on this but what
i will say is that we can't ever hope to
hold power to account
to elect members from across our
communities if the structures that under
underpin this place are fundamentally
broken
we make no secret in designing a
different path for scotland away from
westminster
but the structures and the processes of
this place must change
we must have decency in our democracy we
must have integrity in our processes we
must have equality throughout all areas
of this government's legislative
programme
but today's queen's speech entirely
failed to address the cost of living
crisis
one not experienced for generations we
needed bold action from this youth uk
government
the people of eastern barton share
deserved answers and actions
not platitudes and politicking
what we heard today was a lack of
willingness from this uk government to
take action to support or even throw an
olive branch to some of the two million
people across these four nations living
in poverty
because this government has made a
legislative choice causing them to be
poverty is a political choice by this
government
a different legislative program
featuring even some of the progressive
policies of my nation's government would
result in a far bolder agenda for the
year ahead policies like free
prescriptions free university tuition
free personal care for the over 65
free bus travel for under 22s the
scottish child payment the baby box the
young carers grant
this is the tale of two governments
one that helps those in need and one
that blames those in need
but again this speaks our democracy to
our politics
devolution was not designed to mitigate
it's there to empower
to democratize and bring power closer to
the people of scotland
it was never intended to be a shield to
soften the blows of successive tory
governments
we do what we can with the powers and
resources of our nation but we will not
accept the people of scotland the voices
of eastern burkinshire being abandoned
by an out of touch
uncaring uk government
in my constituency alone the scottish
government is forced to spend
11.8 million pounds each year
to mitigate the worst of what
westminster throws at us
just think that we could do with the
extra money with that extra money as an
independent country
on that note i returned to this place
physically in february of this year
specifically to raise the case of a
constituent and fellow stroke survivor
who had been struggling to get by on the
lawful welfare provided by this
government
we know that this an issue across the
board but disabled people in particular
can't afford to live on the measly
welfare this government dishes out
and i know this sadness that this is
unlikely to change in the year ahead
people are being forced into poverty
i've already noted as a political choice
and one this government could have set
out progressive plans to rectify today
i do want to add a positive note
um like other speakers need to debate i
do welcome legislation to ban conversion
therapy it is unfortunate this is the
second queen's speech in a row we have
heard this
we'll also add a note of caution madam
deputy speaker that this bill should not
be exclusionary and only a fully
inclusive ban of conversion therapy for
all lgbt people
would be welcomed there is no lgb
without the tea
today i didn't hear anything that would
make a tangible difference to the lives
of the people in eastern barnshare as
they struggle under the weight of the
cost of living crisis
last thursday the people of the across
these nations went to the polls my party
enjoyed yet another historic victory are
11th in a row
and the best ever result for
pro-independence parties
in contrast the conservative party who
once again
put their opposition to independence
front and centre had a disastrous
campaign and even worse results in the
member office members opposite may have
feared
but it hasn't stopped the uk government
plowing forward with its brexit bills
these seven bills will undermine
devolution lower living standards leave
us out in the cold when the world
desperately needs all democratic nations
to step up
if the uk government has faith in the
programme laid out today
let them put it to the test
let them surprise me and respect the
snp's democratic mandate to hold an
independence referendum
let them make their case and then suing
debates
and let the people of scotland decide
their own future
thank you
[Applause]
uh
can i say it's
it's very good to see them on an
honourable lady beckham in such good
form
um
as honorable and right honourable
colleagues will know um we do have
a lot of speakers for this debate so it
would be helpful if colleagues could
confine their remarks to about 10
minutes so roger gail
i'm deputy speaker
may i first add my voice to the many
that have expressed their good wishes to
her majesty the queen
our monik is a truly remarkable and
great lady
and i hope very much that she will be
back in rude health
in time not only to participate in but
enjoy
her
platinum jubilee celebrations
and could i also
say
how very good it is to see the
honourable lady for east and buttonship
back in her place
and i'm quite sure that we all wish her
a full recovery as well
um
madam deputy speaker
there are three issues that i wish
there is a planning bill
contained within the
proposals for the queen's speech
and
that is long overdue
that bill we are told
will allow greater local input
into development
and it is a sad fact
that under previous planning regimes
the
desire to build houses and i accept of
course that people need houses to live
in but that desire
seems to have overridden
local planning desires
there is also
in the speech
a bill
to promote sustainable and efficient
farming
and food production
those two issues have to be compatible
it is not possible to have sustainable
food and farming
if we are going to build all over our
grade 1 and grade 2 agricultural land
which is what is happening in thanet at
this very moment
and that has to stop
so i hope very much that the front bench
will take account of the fact
that that circle has to be squared
and that to me
is incredibly important
the
bill the the queen's speech
contains many mentions
of the cost of living increase
i have full confidence
in the ability of our chancellor
to get that right
i understand entirely why he probably
wants to wait until the autumn to
address the matter of fuel price rises
but i would say to him
that people are hurting now
in constituencies like mine in north
fennec
there are families facing very real
hardship and these are
normal hard-working families that
ordinarily would expect to be able to
eat their homes put food on the table
and maybe have a little bit of leftovers
to enjoy themselves
that's practically gone out of the
window
so i hope very much that the chancellor
will take on board
the need
for urgent action now
as well as addressing other matters
in the budget in the autumn
the
queen's speech also contains
a reference to the brexit freedoms
and
the fact
that we should be allowed to control
more of our laws now i was under the
impression that one of the
advantages of brexit
was that we would be able
to take control of much more
of
the legislation that affects for example
animal welfare
i was saddened to find that there is
virtually no reference
to animal welfare in the queen's speech
however upon further inquiry
i am pleased to learn
that at the very least part of the
animals abroad bill
although it's not mentioned in the
speech
will be introduced
and that the ban on the import of body
parts
otherwise known as trophies
from hunting
will be brought in
but it does strike me madam deputy
speaker is strange
that we
are allowed to ban
the production for example of foie gras
in the united kingdom
that we can
control the import
of the use of fur
but there is a reluctance
to ban products
produced under circumstances
elsewhere in the world that we would not
permit in the united kingdom
and i do believe that again those are
issues
that have to be addressed i hope very
much that as we move down
this line of legislation we shall find
time to deal
with some of those issues
i thank him for giving away and does he
share my concerns that a barefoot from
canada will still be
imported for the use of ceremonial um
caps for
army the honourable lady may or may not
know i'm one of the patrons of the
um conservative animal welfare
foundation
which is campaigning for the use of faux
fur
and it does strike me again in this
jubilee year that it's
rather strange that her majesty the
queen
has eschewed the use of real fur in
favor of faux fur
in all her new gods
while we and by the way we also use faux
fur
uh for bandsmen's
outfits for
in replacement for tiger skins and
leopard skins
and those are faux fur skins that are
used now
under the big bass drum and yet we're
still
using real fur
for guzman's cats
i do understand two things one the pride
with which those cats are worn
and second the need to make sure
that any faux fur replacement
is suited to the purpose and fit for the
purpose
but
so far
the ministry of defense which has got so
many other things right seems rather
reluctant to go down this road
i hope that if we can demonstrate there
is a real viable faux fur alternative
then that also
will change
in the context of
the queen's speech and the armed forces
the speech makes reference to our
gallant forces
and by god they are gallant
but of also
it is absolutely vital
that we continue to make the maximum
affordable possible contribution
to the war effort in ukraine
and
to continue to give across the house
our fullest possible support
to those who are fighting
so bravely
for the freedom of their country
and finally madam deputy speaker
this
issue of channel 4 privatization
i as a former broadcaster myself
producer and director
i'm fiercely committed
to free speech
and just as an aside i'd like to take
this opportunity to congratulate
anna cookson
and the team on radio kent's wake-up
call
for
a week ago winning an aria award
in the teeth of composite composition
from
um i believe the today program
and radio 5 live
and others
but that to me demonstrates
two things
one the importance of that free speech
and two
the value of public service broadcasting
i'm not philosophically opposed
to the privatization of channel 4
but i do believe
that we are in danger of throwing a baby
out with the bath water
and i hope very much that if we are
going to continue to go down that road
then we take very great care indeed
to seek to secure the future
of the independent production
industry that channel 4 has fostered
thank you very much
alison mcgovern
thank you madam deputy speaker um it is
an honor to be called in this debate
and a pleasure to follow um the
honourable gentleman who whilst i
disagree with him about much in politics
the words he says about animal welfare
i'm sure will be welcomed by many in the
house and agreed with
wholeheartedly i also associate myself
with all the remarks made by
my friend the leader of the opposition
about the contribution of her majesty
the queen and also about those
colleagues that we have lost in the past
year and also to the member for eastern
bartonshire as you said madam deputy
speaker it's wonderful to see her back
in her place we're all very glad and she
made an excellent speech and again
whilst i disagree with many of the
things that she stands for in politics i
think we all are glad that she is here
to say them
madam deputy speaker sometimes the house
of commons
captures so well the emotions worries
and desires of the people that we
represent
sometimes it feels like parliament is
having a day on a whole different planet
today
i have felt has been a whole different
planet
kind of day
the glaring and burning injustice
of children growing up in poverty and
far too many families simply not being
able to make ends meet seems to have
been
ignored
madame deputy speaker politics
is not performance art
all the pomp and ceremony in the world
will do no good at all for my
constituents in world south
unless the laws we put forward and we
vote for in this place
put money in their pockets
madam deputy speaker it was the um
the member for maidenhead when she was
prime minister who spoke of burning
injustices
and it's some of those burning
injustices that i feel if anything have
got worse
since she was prime minister that i want
to speak of
today
now
you know it's
the debate on the queen's speech has
many features
and we've heard
some self-deprecating humor not taking
ourselves too seriously and yes i do
think it's important madam deputy
speaker that we don't in politics
take ourselves too seriously
but people don't want crappy jokes from
us
they want action
and particularly when it comes to making
ends meet
so i am at a loss madam deputy speaker
to understand why
we are not having an emergency budget
there was no employment bill in the
queen's speech despite promise after
promise after promise
and there's simply no credible plan
contained in that queen's speech to end
the need for food banks in our country
we are letting the country down
on an emergency budget
i think it's universally accepted now
by
everyone from i think the chairman of
tesco
and across
most of this house with the acceptance
of
perhaps government ministers that what
we need is a windfall tax
on oil and gas companies to put money in
people's pockets to deal
with energy bills
and on the other side of the equation on
people's incomes
the prime minister claims that we're
living through some sort of jobs miracle
well if he thinks it's miraculous
that parents in this country can put
food on the table whilst working still
too many of them on zero hours contracts
that pay minimum wage where you don't
know whether you're going to get hours
next week or not if he thinks it's
miraculous
that women in this country are able to
do full-time jobs whilst relying on the
most minimal amount of paid for
childcare and if he thinks it's frankly
a miracle
that families in this country are still
able
to feed themselves and look after
themselves whilst dealing with loved
ones facing a social care system that is
failing before our very eyes then i
would agree with him that is truly
an employment miracle
i will give away just very briefly and i
thank her for giving away would she also
agree with me that the only jobs miracle
to be seen here is that the prime
minister's still got us you know
i mean madam deputy speaker i was quite
critical about parliamentary humor
before but i think that was an example
uh that we could all aspire to it is
truly a miracle that the prime minister
is still in his job but that is not the
jobs miracle that we need he can say
however many times he likes
that he wants high paid jobs it won't
put money in people's pockets madam
deputy speaker
and
to turn to a local issue
it's not just the fact that people are
finding it far too hard to get by and
even people who do
what i think of as really relatively
professional jobs
like nursing or teaching and now turning
to the shame of food banks it's also
that the government's promises on every
aspect of what they dare to call
leveling up are meaningless
it's that whether it's the
money that they're doling out that
doesn't seem to be reaching any of the
right places or their claims on the high
street and regeneration that add up to
nothing
i think this queen's speech is simply
not good enough for the british people
i'll give an example from my own
constituency madam deputy speaker you
will remember that new ferry
a town in rural south had a terrible
glass gas explosion in 2017 and we were
promised help and support to regenerate
that area we got far too little far too
late and one of the major problems has
been insufficient power and resources
for councils to tackle significant areas
of dereliction and deprivation and if
like me madam deputy speaker you
represent an area in the north of
england
that has post-industrial areas that were
never really fully regenerated after the
1980s
you will know only too well that the
lack of power resources for our councils
has been
incredibly detrimental over the past
decade in delivering the kind of
building on brownfield areas that will
help save green areas for everyone and
that's why the kind of suggestions of
some of the changes of planning powers
in the queen's speech may do a small
amount at the margins madam deputy
speaker
but they give the lie to the promise
that has been made to the british public
and i think that sense of injustice that
the ambition that people have for our
country will never be delivered by this
government is what people are really
truly angry about
the same on the issues that people are
facing
with the refugee scheme to help
ukrainians promises made from that
dispatch box madam deputy speaker never
delivered people were told put your hand
up help those who are fleeing the war in
ukraine and we will support you as a
government and what have we seen
applications for visas taking far too
long
people
left in poland and other countries
without any information at all and my
constituents continually beating a path
to my office to tell me how they've put
a shift in they've sorted out the spare
room and what do they get from the
government
so very little in terms of action and
it's that sense of injustice that people
have that they wanted to help at a time
of war
and the government were left wanting and
finally madam deputy speaker i just want
to put on record my thanks to the former
prime minister the member for maidenhead
who's no longer in her place for
speaking up for the hillsborough law
she knows the sense of burning injustice
that hillsborough created
she put forward
a proposal to change the legal system
that would treat every person in this
country with decency and respect when
the worst happens if this government
fail on hillsborough law as they're
failing on every other aspect of public
policy in this country
then i think the lack of justice in
britain will be clear for everyone to
see
thank you deputy speaker and it's a
pleasure to follow my the honorable lady
from world south and on the last point
that she made i'm in agreement with her
that i hope
this session is one in which we can
finally write that particular wrong and
pass a piece of legislation to enable
victims of great scandals and tragedies
to have the legal representation that
they require the experience that i've
had in working with survivors of the
grenfell tragedy leads me to believe
that those individuals and their
families need to have all the support
possible to help guide them through that
difficult period ahead
can i also pay tribute to the honourable
lady from east and barton show and
welcome her back to the house we all
admire the courage that she's shown in
the struggles that she's had in recent
months and welcome her back to her place
today
madame deputy speaker i think the
position that we find ourselves in
today is actually a particularly
perilous one for the country
we've heard in the course of this debate
about the constitutional issues that we
face and we've heard about the
geopolitical ones with the war not so
far away in europe and the work that we
are doing as a country to support our
brave allies in ukraine and to help them
to win and vladimir putin to lose but
here at home
we see a very challenging economic
situation
perhaps the most challenging in my
lifetime
the hit to household incomes this year
and next is going to be the greatest
that we've seen since records began
perhaps the greatest that we've seen for
100 years
we may see a recession later this year
i don't think that's certain but i think
only a fool would bet against it
seeing the economic indicators as they
are
and there is a very real risk
of the start of a new inflationary era
and an inflationary era is one which
should concern us all it's one that
should concern the poorest in society of
course the most
secondly we're seeing stagnant economic
growth
it's that economic growth that should
worry us the most in the long term we
need to be an economy that is generating
the good jobs the tax receipts
to help people into good careers and
fulfilling lives and to pay for public
services in an era in which public
services are only going to cost more
with an aging population the urgent need
to invest in our transition to net zero
and the desire shared across this house
to invest for leveling up and greater
productivity we will need those tax
receipts more than ever and yet they are
not forthcoming
if the bank of england and the obr
forecasts
are to be believed and they have been
wrong in the recent past
we're going to see a number of years of
anemic economic growth
we have to come together to tackle that
and thirdly
we see a number of major issues on which
this house should be coming together to
tackle
failing
energy policy is clearly won
and this year
we are seeing
reaping the whirlwind as a result of
decades of poor planning on energy a
failure to invest in renewables as fast
as we could have done and a failure to
invest in nuclear power and other
conventional sources of energy
that is placing an intolerable burden
upon individuals and families in this
country
and the other one that comes to mind to
me is housing
the repeated failure of governments
to build more homes more homes of all
types and tenures from social housing to
those homes that aspirational young
people want to buy to get on the ladder
we need to do more on both of those
fronts so in that respect i welcome the
queen speech because on a number of
accounts it brings forward bills that
may answer these challenges there's a
series of bills that look at longer term
economic growth
from online competition to reduce
the impact of big tech and its
stranglehold on our online platforms to
gene editing to help our farmers and
agricultural sector to compete to
improvements in financial services where
the city of london's position is by no
means safe and secure and needs to
improve if we are to continue to hold
that strong position in the
international community to transport to
education
but more i think needs to happen
the queen's speech is not a fiscal event
as has been said in one way or another
by many across the house
but i do think we have to recognize
that we have to intervene and take
further steps
firstly to support the poorest and most
vulnerable in society
i think it is inevitable that we will
operate universal credit
that will no doubt happen at the next
fiscal event as usual but there is a
strong case
to do so on a one-off exceptional basis
as soon as possible to help those poor
and vulnerable families to get some
extra money and alleviate some of the
pain for the months ahead
secondly
it is clear that taxes on working people
are too high the tax burden is now at
the highest level for more than 40 years
and we're going to have to work to bring
it down i appreciate the chancellor's
position that a further tax or a tax cut
will occur in 2023 or 2024 prior to the
end of this parliament but that doesn't
seem soon enough to me and my
constituents
we need to have a more competitive tax
system and that means work now
when household incomes of any level are
under strain rather than in a year or
two when potentially inflation will be
starting to ease
and the need for tax cuts will be
somewhat diminished
i hope to see those two changes amongst
others in the months ahead
looking to the longer term and to speak
to
three bills in the queen's feature which
i have some experience having been
responsible for them until recently
firstly the bill which i was very
welcome to see which is reforming the
regulation of social housing
this is a bill which originated under my
right old friend the member for
maidenhead when she was prime minister
and the experience of speaking to social
housing tenants in the immediate
aftermath of the grenfell tragedy and as
she said in her contribution earlier
today it was clear that too many of
those individuals feel ignored and
disrespected by the providers of their
social housing
some of those providers particularly the
largest housing associations in this
country have a poor record of listening
to their tenants and responding with
good quality housing good quality
consumer service
this bill will go some way to changing
that by putting in place better
regulation and a better more
consumer-focused regulator to respond to
those complaints and concerns and i
strongly welcome its inclusion in the
queen's speech
secondly a bill is going to be brought
forward to complete the journey towards
leasehold reform
in the last queen speech
i started the first half of this
two-stage legislation
which i hope will enable any leaseholder
in this country to be able to easily
enfranchise their property
leasehold is
a product of our history a feudal system
which has little place in today's
society we are the only major developed
economy in the world to continue with
this system and it does now need to come
to an end
i hope that this bill will be an
ambitious one which not only enables
people to enfranchise their property and
to purchase a share of freehold if
that's what they want
but leads to the end of leasehold
and that we as a house can set an end
date for that system
from which point onwards we move
wholeheartedly towards common hold a
better system which is usually enjoyed
by citizens and homeowners in every
other major developed country in the
world
and thirdly i'm pleased to see the
leveling up
and regeneration bill included in the
queen's speech there are two elements of
this which matter to me the first is
devolution enabling more devolution
deals to be done
with cities and counties across the
country for those deals to be done
faster and for greater power and
responsibility to be handed to local
communities
as housing secretary during the pandemic
reflecting on that period it's very
clear to me that the one area of our
state that performed consistently well
during that crisis was local government
almost every other government department
or area of the state has at best a mixed
record there are triumphs
and there are failures
within local government
it is mostly a story of success
it's also a story of thrift and value
for
money as secretary of state i gave nine
billion pounds to all of the local
councils
in england to help to get them through
that period to look after the homeless
to dispense grants to our local
businesses to look after the most
vulnerable to do local contact tracing
and many many other responsibilities
that is a fraction of the funding that
we gave to other areas of the state if i
have one regret it's that i didn't win
the battle within government for contact
tracing to be done exclusively by local
government rather than the expensive
system that was ultimately created of
track and trace but the record of local
government is good and we should build
on it with further devolution
i'm conscious time i'll give way briefly
to the uh honorable gentleman
and i just want to applaud him what he
was saying about the the terrific work
of local government uh through the
pandemic and the action that was
absolutely right however the government
did promise they would do everything
necessary to support local authorities
financially through that time whatever
it takes and unfortunately local
authorities like warwick district
council and workshop councils are really
struggling now because they did not
receive that
i hear the point that the honourable
general mates i would dispute that today
probably isn't the right moment to do
that because time doesn't allow but the
point i was making
is that where there is waste
in the record of most other areas of
government in its response to covid i
don't think that's the case with local
government it did those crucial services
quickly in a way that worked for local
communities and providing good value for
money and that i think should lead us to
do more devolution wherever we can
the second half of this bill is going to
be about housing and planning a subject
on which i know well and have scars on
my back to prove
i would simply say because there's
limited time today
that it is a matter of the greatest
importance to this country that we build
more homes
successive governments have failed to do
this there's always an excuse
we don't want to build on green fields
we don't want to spoil the look and feel
of a local community
we don't want to over develop an area
we've got to get those homes built
because we're letting down hundreds of
thousands of our fellow citizens
people are homeless today
because we're failing to build those
houses
young people's right and rightful
aspiration to get on the housing ladder
is being neglected because we're not
building those homes
if i had to guess
i would say that the number of homes we
built in the first year of this
administration under the prime minister
and myself almost 250 000
will be the high water mark of the
number of homes built in this country
for several years to come and that the
government will miss its 300 000 homes a
year manifesto pledge by country
mile the only way in which we will get
back to 250 000 homes a year and exceed
it is if we together
on a cross-party basis agree that that
is not good enough and that we need to
build more and find ways of doing that
otherwise i'm afraid we're going to
consign hundreds of thousands of our
constituents to a life at best in secure
rented accommodation at worst in very
insecure rented accommodation and life
on the streets that isn't good enough
that's not the society i want to live in
and i hope that members on all sides of
the house of all political persuasions
will approach that planning bill with
that frame of mind thank you jeremy
corbyn thank you very much uh madam
deputy speaker
and i will try and keep within the ten
minutes you've requested that we do and
i absolutely agree with that the day of
the state opening parliament is actually
quite surreal because you have all the
sort of pomp and the gold coaches and
the ancient rolls royces and everything
else out in the streets
and you then have a prime minister who
comes into the chamber and tells us he's
got all the big calls right on covid and
all the big calls right on finance
and uh then disappears
the reality
of this country today
is that we have 4.2 million children
living in poverty in our society
1.3 million babies
very very small children are being
brought up
in households in desperate poverty often
with not enough to eat and a heavy
reliance on food banks and food co-ops
merely to survive
and so
dealing with poverty
dealing with those issues does require
wage rises does require as the member
who spoke before me pointed out an
increase rapidly in universal credit it
does require recognizing the desperate
state of poverty within britain and it
became very obvious during the coving
pandemic that there is a whole
generation of people that came together
in mutual aid groups that now recognize
that poverty
and food hunger is unacceptable in our
society and that the work that's being
done on the right to food and so much
else must be recognized and must be
taken up there is nothing in the speech
that says anything that gives hope to
those people living in desperate poverty
at the present time
many members have spoken about the
problems of energy costs there are
6.3 million people in this country
living in fuel poverty a very nice sort
of
sociological term fuel poverty what it
really means is they can't afford to put
the electricity on they can't afford to
buy the gas they can't afford to heat
their homes and if they're lucky they
heat one room of that home or they just
go cold
i would have thought there must be quite
a few members that were campaigning in
the local elections last week who came
across houses even when it was getting
dark where there were no lights on there
was a reason they could not afford to
charge the key meter they could not
afford to put the lights on in their
homes that is the reality of poverty in
this country that poverty again leads to
not just
unpleasant living it leads to
hypothermia and a real serious problem
for people just trying to survive so why
hasn't the government done what the
french government did and introduced an
energy price cap why isn't it instead
taken the hit on the increase in energy
prices as a public good in order to
protect people against it why isn't it
promoting public ownership of energy
rather than the massive profits being
made by the energy companies at the
present time during this period of
crisis and so i do think we have to look
at all of those issues 83 percent of
adults say they're having a
noticing or suffering from a
considerable increase in the cost of
living and that means not just food
poverty it means shortage of being able
to buy clothes and so much else as well
these issues have not been addressed in
that speech
i was interested in
the speech the very thoughtful speech
made by the member for newark just now
because he did address many of the
housing issues that we face in this
country
the homeless people that were
very obviously on the streets of this
country when the covey pandemic started
were housed
because there was government
intervention sufficient funding given to
local authorities to ensure that they
were housed and indeed some local
authorities leased hotels some bought
new places and
a very large number i don't think all
but a very large number of street
sleeping rough sleeping homeless people
were housed during the pandemic
if we can do it during a pandemic we can
do it at any time we can carry on doing
that it is simply immoral that anyone
should be forced to sleep on the streets
of this country at any time and it does
mean however addressing the issues of
housing costs and housing stress
i represent an inner city constituency
which has a very large number of council
properties
a considerable number of housing
association places
decline small and declining number of
owner occupiers and a very fast growing
private rented sector by and large the
council properties are well managed and
well run and have reasonable levels of
rent and to live in a council property
gives people a considerable sense of
security
housing associations i don't think are
particularly well managed i don't think
by and large they're very good at doing
repairs i don't think they're very good
after often and management and they're
profoundly undemocratic in their
behavior and refusal often to listen to
tenants or have any real bearing on what
tenants actually want and i do think in
any housing legislation we need to
hardwire into it a sense of democracy in
the way in which housing associations
manage their properties and are forced
to listen to their tenants
but it's in the
private rented sector that the worst
problems occur
about 30 to 33 percent of my
constituency live in the private rented
sector the rent levels are absolutely
horrendous
they are
more than three times the level of
council rents and the local housing
allowance is insufficient to help people
mostly moving into the private rented
sector so those on universal credit
moving into the private rented sector
because there's insufficiency of council
housing have to supplement the rent
themselves or move way away from their
community their schools their families
their support networks and all the rest
of it
we've got to understand that if we're
going to have such a huge proportion of
our population living in the private
rented sector they need certainty of an
affordable rent they need certainty of
long-term um
long-term tenancies and they need
certainty that they won't be perhaps
parentally
evicted from that property and that they
will
get their repairs done when they need
them to be done
many of our local authorities my own
included are very innovative and very
creative in building some degree of
protection and regulation within their
communities but it's this house and this
place that should build those
protections and those regulations within
the private rented sector
and so there is so much in the speech
that is simply well it's a whole lot of
things that ought to be in the speech
that are not there if the government's
proposing deregulation of the economy at
a very time when we need an investment
in the economy if they're
not doing anything about job protection
about fire and rehire about the
insufficiency of wages with so many
people then the inequalities the
gaping chasm of inequality in britain
will get considerably worse there is a
regional inequality there is national
inequality there is social inequality
there is class inequality and it is
getting considerably worse and i think
this parliament has to address those
issues and as the
my friend member hemsworth was saying
social inequality is dealt with either
by dealing with the inequality by
raising wages by raising public
expenditure and all those issues or
you repress the protests and repress the
anger and try and control people who
want to demonstrate against it and so a
whole agenda of a law and order society
rather than dealing with the social
divisions in society is not a very um a
very appealing prospect going forward
the last point i want to make is this
the world
is in an environmental crisis at the
present time cop 25 said that cop 26
said that albeit there was a lot of
green wash surrounding it and there is a
massive problem of environmental
disaster around the corner
and the global refugee crisis of 70
million people around the world comes
from wars comes from
human rights abuses comes from
oppressive societies but it also comes
from the environmental disaster that
we're facing we cannot just close our
doors on refugees
i absolutely and totally condemn the
russian invasion of ukraine and i hold
my heart out and hand out to the
ukrainian refugees that have come to
this country albeit with great
difficulty no thanks to the home office
processes and procedures
but we should hold the same handout and
same welcome to refugees from other
conflicts and other wars in yemen in
syria in libya in palestine in ethiopia
in eritrea and all those other places
and recognize that if we want good human
rights for ourselves and those human
rights should apply to others they also
apply to human rights of people to
express dissent around the world the
number of journalists real journalists
very brave people who've stood up
against
oligarchs and dictators
and have paid the ultimate price of
being murdered as a result of it
should be recognized and should be
supported and our home secretary should
think very very carefully of the
responsibility on her shoulders about
whether or not somebody who has bravely
reported about human rights abuses and
military activities around the world
julian sarge should be removed from this
country or not i think he's a
whistleblower who should be protected
and a journalist who should be protected
not removed
last point i'd say is this
we should be building a world that's fit
for the next generation we're bringing
up a generation in this country of
children that are over stressed and over
tested in school
that are streamed out of out of sight
almost in secondary school and
victims of the competitive culture
between secondary schools and then
charged in college and heavily indebted
in university and then because their
wage levels and so on are so low cannot
afford any decent or permanent place to
live what is the message we're giving to
the next generation they won't have it
as good as the current generation
they're going to have to pay the debts
for the future we should be investing
nurturing cultivating and including all
of those young people
joy in their creativity their art their
music their science their learning they
are the future and what are we doing
consigning them to stress and in many
cases so much poverty we can do things
very much differently and very much
better than we are at the present day
and sadly this speech we're given today
offers no hope whatsoever for any of
those issues that i've drawn attention
to today
ben bradley
thank you madame deputy speaker a
pleasure to take part in today's queen
speech today and lots to welcome i think
uh in the conversation and in the
announcements we've heard today uh the
uh rumor for his links north very nearly
said something that i agreed with about
schools uh at one stage in his speech
and i was about to stand up and say how
i actually agreed with him and then as
the sentence went on we kind of ruined
it and
i didn't agree anymore but part of it
which i will come back to i very much
enjoyed and agreed with um but i'd like
to welcome um some elements within
today's screen speech i think it's first
worth identifying what the queen's
speech is because we've talked a lot in
the chamber today about the need for
short-term intervention while the
queen's
screen speech lays out the legislative
agenda by its very nature it's not
short-term legislation takes time uh
inevitably it takes a year or more in
this place to get any serious piece of
legislation
done
we all recognize the need for short-term
support and help for the most vulnerable
we all accept that and we all see in our
own constituencies my own is one of
the poorest the most disadvantaged on
many indicators in the country we all
see that hardship
we all recognize the need for support
and the chancellor has said that overtly
uh the chief secretary has been on the
media round today making clear that that
will happen and more support will come
but today's queen speech is about the
long term and about the legitimate
agenda there's a lot to welcome as i've
said uh not least on the economy i'm
levelling up which i'll come back to um
and focus on in more detail later on in
my speech but um
i'm pleased to see
elements around um
start with the perhaps the relatively
small in the grand scheme of leveling up
and the cost of living um but football
governance i think um sustainable um
support for our clubs which are not just
businesses but are the heart of our
communities in many places i welcome the
opportunity to look at that in more
detail i welcome the opportunity
to further crack down frankly on the
mass disruption the criminal damage that
has often been allowed to masquerade as
legitimate protests in recent years
which is not right or acceptable um i
hugely welcome the school's bill and the
opportunity to do more on school
standards this is where i was nearly
he's gone now but i was nearly gonna
agree with the member for islington
north he obviously didn't want to hear
how how he agreed um because that would
only be damaging to the reputation i'm
sure all mine um one way or the other
but he was talking about the need for
more
um
more autonomy within schools for more
broader curriculum for the opportunity
to prioritize and promote cultural
capital as opposed to just exams in our
school system and on that i totally
agree with him i would like for
nottinghamshire the council that i lead
to take forward the school's white paper
as an early adopter as an opportunity to
drive that to give schools more autonomy
to give our schools
a clearer structure of accountability to
give them
more of an ability to
to be empowered as teachers and as
schools and trusts to do their own thing
to do what they think is best for their
children i think we'd retain more
teachers if we empowered them
to do that as well so opportunity in
that school's bill and as i say i hope
that nothing shall be an early adopter
of some of that new legislation
i want to urge caution on a couple of
things as well madam deputy speaker not
least the online safety bill um i think
it's well intentioned and i think we all
understand the reasons um why we want to
seek to protect people online and why
things that are illegal uh in the real
world inverted commerce should also be
illegal online but i am also concerned
about the risk of allowing big tech
companies to police our language and our
speech in a way that you know we see the
debate that rages about twitter and
about elon musk and all of the
controversies around that it is a really
difficult topic and a really difficult
thing to get right i would just urge
government not to go too far in
restricting or allowing
anybody frankly to choose to police the
language
that we are allowed to use because that
can only end
badly in my view and also i welcomed
earlier in the year the chances
commitment to move towards
a lower tax small state kind of economy
where we can
you know promote growth where we can
allow the private sector to
flourish to create jobs and sport uh
constituents he he talked about a small
state and i would like for the
government to consider perhaps putting
that into practice on some other
legislation too not least things like
the obesity strategy where we're
starting to talk about you know which
adverts can be placed where in which
shops it's madness and it's not
something that the government should be
involved in so again
i hope
that the government might reconsider on
some of these things but i wanted to
focus the majority of my comments on
the economy and on leveling up i was
pleased to see the phrase economic
growth repeated over and over again one
of the the most uh successful
political campaigns of my uh brief uh
career has been the long-term economic
plan that we all remember and we all
heard about over and over again uh and
those that was the the same kind of
language um that we used in those days
proved to be very popular it's very
important uh my honourable writer friend
from newark talks about the importance
of growth in terms of being able to fund
our public services in terms of being
able to have better life chances
for residents in our communities
some of the bills and legislation that
we brought forward in this term is
absolutely vital to that not least the
leveling up bill which will be
a key driver of that growth
and it's that private sector growth not
government spending that is the heart of
better opportunities for areas like uh
the east midlands uh where i come from
uh that has historically been at the
bottom of all the the charts in terms of
both public and private sector growth
but we have huge opportunities
to get more of of both but at the very
least we already have projects in train
that will allow us to free up uh the
private sector to invest in our area to
create those uh better paid better
quality jobs that we are in are in short
supply
in our region that's not about high
spending
it's about
promoting and creating an environment
for business to flourish in our region
it's about delivery because we've talked
for a long time about the funding that's
going into the most disadvantaged areas
i just mentioned that the east midlands
is the lowest on all those charts about
what money private and public goes into
these places my own constituency in
mansfield is the bottom end of that
regional scale as well but we have got
things in the pipeline where we are
setting these uh that will come forward
in the future that are really positive
we've seen uh whether it's capital
investment things like the townsv on the
leveling up fund we've seen huge funding
announcements what i asked of the prime
minister and promises questions a few
weeks ago was about delivery and
outcomes because you can only talk for
so long about how much money you've
secured for an area
without residents being able to point to
a thing that is new a lot of what we
will achieve and a lot of what's most
important in that leveling up agenda is
not visible right it's skills it's
education it's schools things that are
long term and things that you're not
going to be able to appoint to a shiny
achievement within the life of one
parliament but some of it
is short-term some of it is building
some of it is regeneration of town
centres some of it is things that we've
announced hundreds of millions of pounds
for uh getting on for two years ago now
and these things are bogged down in
process they're bogged down in whitehall
often
and
if we're going to get to a position
where residents believe us when we talk
about the big things that we're doing
around skills around education
and how that's going to benefit them in
the future we need to show them the
delivery of those short-term things of
that high street regeneration of those
towns funds of that money that we have
promised it's all in the pipeline i'm
getting fed up of how we'll get here
i just feel uh slightly disappointed for
his constituents when i point to
things in my bristol sales constituency
that were delivered by the last labour
government every single school rebuilt a
brand new hospital
the investment that came there that
those people deserved after the years
under the last tory government that's
what we delivered for them on the ground
his government has had 12 years and he
still can't point to anything in his
constituency
i thank you for that intervention i
understand the point she's making but
she's not quite there given that the
labour government was obviously 13 years
ago there's been a
great amount of time for the delivery of
a number of those projects going back to
97 i was eight years old when that
labour government came into power you've
had a fair old while to deliver on some
of those things the government um that i
represent or certainly my constituency
has been represented uh by the
conservatives 35 years in its entire
history
and that's always been
me we've been working on a number of
projects and this government and this
prime minister and this leveling up
agenda has been a very brief period in
time we've talked already about the
hundreds of millions of
pounds of investment that have been
secured from my own constituency we can
talk about the towns and we can talk
about additional support and investment
in skills we can talk about capital
investment for our college that we've
not seen before we can talk about new
capital investment in our hospitals all
of that
is in train some of it is visible some
of it is not yet visible but the point
that i'm making is that we need to be
able to point to those things not just
in my constituency but across the
country and some of those seats um that
we only won you know matter over two
years ago
where
new
talented conservative mps are making the
case
for that investment we need to see
outcomes across the board and it's no
good standing and saying we've made
promises of money because residents at
some stage will say
where is that new town centre building
where is that new project where is my
shiny new town center
i will give away
um i thank the member for giving way and
i well understand the concerns of people
in nottingham and nottinghamshire as he
does but what aren't many of those
people saying to him right now why isn't
the government doing something to put
more money in my pocket because i'm sure
he's hearing from his constituents as
i'm hearing from mine that they are
worried sick about paying their bills
and at the moment when they're really
struggling that's not doing anything to
help those families and it isn't doing
anything to help our high streets in
nottinghamshire either
thank you for that intervention she's
right there constituents are worried and
they are in my constituency they are i'm
sure in hers
they also recognize that the government
can't flick a switch and fix everything
and nor should anybody suggest that they
can there's a 22 billion pound package
of intervention we've already brought
forward and a commitment to more um in
the pipeline and coming over the course
of summer and into the autumn chance has
already made that commitment but no very
few residents in marketing situations
come to me and expect the government to
have a magic bullet and i think it's
slightly um false i have to say that so
many on the opposite ventures seem to
suggest that there is one when there
isn't but the final point i wanted to
make madam david speaker and unconscious
of time was around that leveling up bill
in particular which is hugely important
for our region more so perhaps than many
because it contains the mechanism for us
to bring forward
a devolution deal for the east midlands
for derbyshire national nottingham and
derby that is the delivery mechanism for
many of the things that we've talked
about remember opposite no longer in a
place talks about brownfield funding the
ability to bring forward sites and have
more clout over what you do with that
funding that's part of our devolution
negotiations there were other examples
that she raised and i sat at the time
thinking we can do that if we bring
forward this devolution uh arrangement
that we crack on with this negotiation
the only thing and the thing that will
slow that down in the course of that
negotiation which should be done by the
end of the year is that legislation
which will take longer so i would call
on government to prioritize that to
bring that forward and let's get those
levers that additional funding if you
look to the west midlands our partner
that we often look to enviously that's
been worth billions and billions of
pounds of additional investment since
they got their deal just six or seven
years ago
we want that and we can bring that
forward quickly
if government commits to bringing that
legislation forward in a timely way in
spring because if it's
may rather than march we'll have to wait
12 months probably before we can
actually deliver on the outcomes that we
want to see so i urge government to
crack on and prioritize that devolution
element of that leveling up bill and
agenda which is massively important to
get those outcomes for my constituents
not just promises but outcomes that we
will need to show those residents who in
many cases you know seats that used to
be represented by labour who voted
actually for
this prime minister for this
conservative government to deliver for
them they will need to see those
outcomes the mechanisms to deliver it
are in the queen's speech today so i
urge government to bring those forward
as quickly as possible
jessica moored thank you very much
when this queen's speech today confirms
what we already know that this
government lacks the vision and the
ability to chackle the main challenges
of the day last week we saw voters in
wales deliver their message to this
prime minister loud and clear in the
local elections and it was a very good
friday indeed for the labour party in
wales i'd like to congratulate all the
successful candidates uh the welsh labor
candidates in newport east in newport
and in monmouthshire on the mandates
they secured particularly to those
colleagues in monmouthshire whose work
has resulted in the party opposite
losing the only their only council in
wales what ambitious labor-led councils
like newport have shown and will
continue to show that there is a kinder
a more positive and a more proactive
alternative to the tory way of doing
things and given this message that was
sent last week on behalf of constituents
in newport east i am deeply frustrated
that this queen speech has failed to
deliver anything meaningful to help
people cope with the cost of living
crisis now
um in fairness expectations were low you
only had to watch the prime minister's
disastrous interview with susanna reid
last week to see that those in power
have such little understanding of the
sacrifices people are having to make and
in the last few days in the news we have
been bombarded with news of of how
household energy bills will potentially
hit 3 000 pounds a year by october our
fire services across the country
reporting they're dealing with blazes
caused by people burning scraps of wood
to keep warm and as was widely reported
how more than two million people aren't
eating every day because they just can't
afford it how as the fifth largest
economy in the world are we in a
position where our people are resorting
to to skipping meals and burning off
cuts of wood to keep their heads above
water and with food prices continuing to
increase this situation will only get
worse not better which is why today the
queen's speech we should have in this
queen speech we should have seen more
action to tackle to tackle this and to
support households this government
continues to hit people on modest
incomes disproportionately but there was
no hope today for these families just an
energy bill that will eventually make
energy cheaper and a nod to working to
ease inflation like other honourable
members i see messages and emails daily
from people who have nowhere to turn who
just don't want to live a life where
they aren't worrying about whether they
can where they are worrying about
whether they can heat or eat and there
was little here today to help them now
or even in the short term no emergency
budget no extra help and given that the
things today are essentially the
government's program for the next two
years i worry about all those families
who are already out of options
and the government
and if the government have run out of
ideas of their own it's still not too
late for them to adopt our proposal to
keep energy bills lower through a
one-off windfall tax on oil and gas
profits a move that was referred to by
the ceo of tesco's in radio 4 today a
move that would save every household
hundreds of pounds a year on their fuel
bills and provide much needed additional
support to the lowest income household
this is right and fair this is the right
and fair thing to do that the government
continues to side with major firms like
centrica of today announced they expect
their profits to hit the top of their
expected range and oil and gas companies
who describe their situation as having
more money than they know what to do
with rather than those of ordinary
families speaks volumes
and while the uk government doesn't
clearly doesn't get the scale of the
problem
i'm pleased that the welsh labour
government does and it's worth sharing a
contrast with the welsh labour
government the extra support in wales
includes 150 pounds cost of living
payment to all households in properties
in council tax bans a to d and to all
those in receipt of any council tax
benefit which goes further than the uk
government's equivalent announcement for
england and that there'll be an
extension to the welsh winter fuel
support scheme which will again provide
people on low incomes and others a
non-repayable 200 non-repay will be in
the keyword here 200 pound cash payment
to help with their energy bills later
this year which they'll receive on top
of the 200 pound loan from the
government unlike the government i also
want to talk about steel another
important issue for newport in india and
newport east eastern indeed the whole of
the uk if the government's actually
serious about levelling up there was no
reference to steele or the industrial
strategy in any of the queen's speeches
since 2019 and this one was no exception
as a community union member and i
declare an interest here as a you know
community union member um community
union have highlighted the world cannot
decarbonize without steel whether it's
to build wind turbines electric vehicles
energy efficient buildings or anything
else it's a foundation industry that we
need for our defense and national
security particularly important at the
moment sadly we have a government that's
only willing to do the bare minimum at
moments of crisis for the industry and
is otherwise more than prepared to leave
the sector hanging without support and
steel workers in my constituency and
tata language and in liberty feel this
acutely i want a government that will
give them the voter confidence they
deserve a pressing priority is on steel
safeguards and tariff rate quotas
something i hoped would have been
addressed in the brexit measures that
are in here today ministers should also
move forward on previous commitments to
a thorough review of the trade remedy
system to ensure that we have a trade
defense system fit for the 21st century
uk steel and the steel appg have been
calling for this for some time and swift
action is needed we also need action on
high industrial energy prices other
countries in europe can step in and help
their steel industry why can't we and
while on the surface promise of more
policing powers to make our streets
safer sounds welcome there's no detail
on how these additional powers will be
resourced the new recruits we've seen
over the last year of course welcome but
the government really need to stop
claiming that they're employing extra
police officers these are not extra
officers but partial replacements for
those they've cut since 2010. today we
have 11 thousand less police officers
seven thousand less pcsos and eight
thousand less police staff in work than
we did when labour left office in 2010.
we need new police hubs in every
community and more protection for
victims of anti-social behavior i can't
help but wonder whether the failure to
mention wales today is simply because
the government know how badly their
announcement on the shared prosperity
fund we received last month with wales
facing a loss of more than one billion
in unreplaced spending over the next
three years it does beg the question as
to whether the prime minister seriously
thinks the people of wales have
forgotten his governments not a penny
less promise to at least match the size
of eu structural funds that wales would
have received
and onto rail i welcome work to
modernize and improve rail services but
what plans are for are there
within this uh green speech today for
the government to address the appalling
rail infrastructure and defending in
wales wales accounts for 11
of the uk rail network but still only
received 2
of rail enhancement funding from the uk
government rails wales rail networks are
underfunded by billions of pounds and
this needs addressing today so i'd urge
the government to take a strategic look
at what it can do to include improve
cross-border transport between south
east rails and the south west of england
a new station for mega would help and i
paid tribute to the
volunteers at major action group on rail
who continue to campaign so hard for
this um actually in the group's plan
would be a positive step in the right
direction to finish on a slightly more
positive note there were rays of hopes
in the government's response to the
crouch review on football governance
recently which was referenced in the
queen's speech today but i hope we'll
soon see the dcms secretary make good on
the pledge to introduce an independent
football regulator a timetable on this
would be good as would an assurance that
ministers will not cede to the demands
of vested interest and delay or water
down their plans on regulation as fair
game have highlighted we also need to
see an overhaul of the outdated
parachute payment system and its
replacement with this sustainability
index that rewards conscientious run
clubs conscientiously run clubs like
newport county afc and my constituency
which prioritize good governance and
strong relationships within the
community and i hope the government will
engage with fair game and other
stakeholders over the coming months to
ensure that momentum on these important
changes are not lost and look at the
newport county model in short what we've
seen today is a queen speech that was
written to shore up a listing pm not a
queen speech for families and workers
who are really looking for support right
now deeply disappointing yes surprising
no
and just to say that we've got about a
dozen people left uh who want to speak
and even without jessica jessica morton
being told to keep it too roughly about
10 minutes she did nine minutes so
everybody will get equal dibs if we can
just have a little bit of time control
peter alders thank you very much mr
deputy speaker i will do my best to do
that it's a pleasure to follow the
honourable lady the member for newport
east and i congratulate the members for
my right on my honourable friend from
south end west and the honourable lady
from east donbartonshire
for their labour speeches
mr mr
deputy speaker i'd like to also pay
tribute to my predecessor as mp for
waveny bob blizzard who sadly passed
away at the end of last week
bob was a
formidable political opponent
he held passionate beliefs
and he was a staunch advocate for
waverly
my condolences are with his family and
friends at this sad time
mr speaker this queen's speech has been
delivered against one of the most
challenging backdrops in the past
century
war in europe following quickly on from
the kovid 19 pandemic has exacerbated
the challenges that bis people and
businesses were already facing
soaring energy and food prices
rising interest rates and slowing
economic growth are putting enormous
pressure on budgets
both family and business
the program for government for the next
session cannot on its own address all
the challenges that we will face over
the next two years
but there must be
a clear statement of intent and a
decisive direction of travel
there is a need to focus on the issues
that matter to people on a daily basis
the cost of living the ability to pay
one's bills without spiraling into debt
and the opportunity to have a well-paid
and secure job with good prospects of
career progression
we don't know what lies ahead in these
increasingly uncertain times and thus it
is important that the government are
flexible and where there is need to
bring in measures to address a
particular pressing need they must do so
without delay
i shall briefly highlight four issues
two are specifically covered in proposed
bills whilst two are not
first and foremost the need to address
the cost of living classes
yes the government have brought in some
measures to help support families and
businesses but more targeted assistance
is required to enable people to get
through this coming year which many are
facing with fear and trepidation with
the expectation of inflation at 10
percent and off gems increase in the
energy cap looming in the autumn
in suffolk
135 000 people are already living in
poverty
a survey in the low stock journal shows
that 41 of people are in debt
and citizens advice local councils and
local charities are already working in
overdrive assisting advising and
supporting people
poverty among pensioners needs a
particular focus due to prevailing high
inflation with the state pension and
both defined benefit and defined
contribution
private pensions all exposed there may
well be a need for review and reform and
i would urge the government to not hold
back in introducing such measures
secondly it is vital that the
opportunity
is there right around the uk for people
to secure a good job with good prospects
for career advancement and with the
opportunity to realize their full
potential
the school's bill and the leveling up
and regeneration bill
should help secure this ambition
suffolk has for a long time received a
poor education funding settlement and we
must use this opportunity to address
this inequality
there must also be a particular focus on
improving both early years and sen
education and whilst the skills and post
16 education act that went through in
the last session provides the framework
for improving the further education
sector it does remain
poorly funded for the vitally important
role that it plays in preparing people
for the workplace helping improve the
uk's overall economic performance and
eliminating the productivity gap
there well may well be a need for fiscal
support to encourage businesses to
invest in people and skills and last
week the learning and work institute
recommended that smaller businesses
should be able to deduct 230 percent of
the cost of accredited training from
their tax liability
turning to the long-awaited leveling up
and regeneration bill i acknowledge the
enormous amount of work that my right
honourable friend the secretary of state
and my honourable friend the minister
the member for harbor have carried out
in a relatively short period since their
appointments in since their appointments
in september in laying the groundwork in
the white paper which was published at
the beginning of this february
i urge them not to forget coastal
communities which all around the uk
including in waveney and low staff are
so in so many respects the forgotten
powerhouse of the uk economy they have a
vital role to play
empowering the nation as we embrace
renewable energy in feeding the nation
through sustainable and responsible
stewardship of our fisheries
promoting global trade through our
network of ports both large and small
and also in providing holidays at home
rather than abroad
thirdly energy mr deputy speaker the
energy act of 2013 was good legislation
which played an important role in
promoting renewable energy particularly
offshore wind in which the uk is now a
world leader
there is a temptation to leave well
alone a regulatory framework which has
worked well
however we do have new challenges that
must be tackled particularly if we are
to meet the 2050 net zero target
therefore it is right to now build on
the foundations that were laid nine
years ago
i briefly highlight some of the
challenges that we need to address
we must promote and incentivize further
investment on the uk continental shelf
adding to last year's north sea
transition deal so as to ensure that
this unique uk asset continues to play a
lead role empowering the nation
generating
rewarding and well-paid jobs and
ensuring a smooth transition to a net
zero energy supply
a windfall tax would jeopardize this
work though there is a need for the
major oil and gas companies to do more
following the good work of many
innovative and smaller businesses
with regard to offshore wind we need a
framework that builds on the success of
the last decade and which promotes
investment in interconnectors and
battery storage so as to absorb surplus
wind as well as facilitating the
development of a modern onshore
transmission network
nuclear power is very much part of the
government's energy strategy and the
nuclear nuclear energy financing act
which was passed in the last session
provides the framework for size will see
to proceed if the development consent
order is issued this is an enormous
infras national infrastructure project
mr deputy speaker locate located close
to my own constituency which can play a
vital role in levelling up and
regenerating local economies providing
jobs during construction and leaving a
legacy of skills that brings lasting
benefits to places like lost and waveney
edf are committed to this strategy but
it is vital that national government
provide the framework that ensures that
they deliver these benefits working with
local businesses local colleges local
charities and local councils
hydrogen is the new kid on the block
which presents boundless opportunities
though even at this stage we do not
quite know either what precise direction
it will take or the full scale of what
it can deliver
whilst a hydrogen strategy was only
published last august there is an urgent
need for a route map if it is to realize
its full potential
community energy has an important role
to play and we used to remove those
regulatory obstacles to prevent local
communities from promoting their own
projects
an area of energy policy where we have
not succeeded in recent years is the
promotion of energy saving retrofitting
our homes and business premises
the green deal did not work and the
green homes grant scheme was too low in
ambition and lack the capacity to have a
significant impact
in the short term so as to address the
challenge of fuel poverty we should look
at extending the warm homes discount
the war the home upgrade scheme and the
energy company obligation
the government must also produce a
scheme that will deliver meaningful and
significant enhancement of our whole
building stock this will probably
require fiscal incentives and local
government will have an important role
to play in overseeing and ensuring
workforce planning training and then
delivery finally mr deputy seeker we
need to revamp the strategy for the
rollout of small smart meters which i'm
afraid really has stalled
mr deputy speaker the fourth and final
issue that i will raise is the nhs
whilst there is no bill that directly
addresses our health service and one
might argue there is not a need for one
as we've only recently finished debating
the health and care bill care bill which
has just received royal consent royal
assent this is a subject this is a
critical importance and concern to our
constituents
people are worried that they're not able
to see their doctor the government need
to work with gps to address this concern
nhs dentistry is the number one item in
my inbox there are dental deserts all
around the country and urgent attention
is required if these are not or not to
merge into one area of sahara
proportions
there is a backlog of operations many of
them time critical that needs to be
significantly and immediately reduced
my right honourable friend secretary of
state is very much aware of these
challenges and regardless of whether or
not there is specific legislation they
must be given the highest priority and
attention
mr deputy speaker in conclusion
there is a great deal to do and there
are great many challenges to confront
the life of like of which we have not
seen during our lifetimes
we can get through this crisis
and the government do need to have in
mind
the need to bring together a nation that
has been divided first by brexit and
then by kobe thank you thank you very
much gareth thomas
i very much i very much welcome the
honourable member for waving his remarks
about bob blizzard i had the great
privilege of being elected at the same
time of him and as we learnt uh together
and with others uh how this place works
and indeed how it perhaps doesn't work
quite so well i had many uh many
conversations uh with him and uh i knew
of his passing uh last week from
friends a friend of his in my
constituency and i feel very sad and
such a good man and such a great figure
in the labour party as has been has been
lost to us
what stands out uh mr deputy speaker
from uh the prime minister's speech this
afternoon is a complete failure to
understand just how poor his
government's response has been to date
to the desperate circumstances of too
many of my constituents
because of the cost of living crisis and
particularly because of the huge high a
huge hike in energy bills
up at least 70 percent since 2010
ministers have been complacent and too
slow to
to act
the average household bill is now about
two thousand pounds a year and in
october could rise to almost three
thousand pounds
everyone in the country is affected but
for many the huge rise in bills means
some devastating and very difficult
choices for those who are the most
vulnerable in our country it's do they
feed themselves or do they put the
heating on
similarly for business once one small
business owner explained to me recently
how his energy bill is going up from
1200 pounds a month now
to 2 400 pounds in
june
more than 2 million adults have gone
without food for a whole day in the past
month two and a half children uh two and
a half million children now regularly
miss meals or have to have uh smaller uh
smaller meals in the 21st century in one
of the richest countries
in the world that is a truly
shocking indication of the government's
failure
a sustained and meaningful plan to
tackle immediately that cost of living
and food security uh crisis is uh is
needed we should have been told today
when an emergency budget was going to be
brought forward to tackle those uh
issues
my right on with a friend
the leader of the oppositions a
suggestion of a cut in energy bills
funded by a winful tax to help everyone
is entirely sensible and further help
for those on average or very low incomes
will be critical to an increase in
social security payments an uplift in
universal credit is the obvious way to
do that
one particular but unsurprising
disappointment about the gracious
address was the absence again of the
much promised employment bill leaving
far too many vulnerable to bland
employers
making sure those who treated fair those
in work are treated fairly with respect
and have decent incomes is fundamental
to the even greater country than britain
can be
it's why all public services should be
supported to pay a genuine living wage
why sick pay should be extended to
and it's why an employment bill is
needed to rein in the worst employers to
for example outlaw fire and rehire and
to increase the penalties for
discrimination against women having a
baby it should have been in the queen's
speech
on the economy more generally energy
price heights widespread inflation
interest rate rises and growing concerns
that the economy is going into recession
only underlying how badly the economy
has been run for the past decade indeed
over the last 10 years britain's growth
in exports has lagged significantly
behind the rest of the g7 yet there's
little recognition or action by the
treasury or other key departments
between 2010 and 2020 american exports
of goods and services for the rest of
the world rose by over 14
germany saw growth over the same period
of over 13 in its exports across the g7
average growth in exports 10 percent yet
britain under the party opposite over
the same decade managed growth of just
four percent even italy saw faster
export growth
and indeed we actually saw a decline in
exports to the world's fastest growing
economies in the g20 over that period
exports of goods down 10
to g20 countries since 2010.
we lost our position as the world's
biggest centre for financial services in
2018 to new york
we missed even allowing for covet by a
huge margin
george osborne's target for troubling uh
exports
exports matter they're crucial to
business growth to generating tax
receipts they're a factor in our soft
power they're fundamental for job
creation indeed jobs linked to exports
pay higher than average wages so not
properly supporting exporters is only
going to prolong the cost of living
crisis and hold back economic growth
and the party opposites failure to take
serious steps to address the problems
businesses are facing trying to get into
european markets will only exacerbate
this problem the prime minister thinks
it's down to a lack of ambition by
exporters
we need as a country to make brexit work
better we're not going to be rejoining
the european union but we do need to
sort out the problems in the deal that
the prime minister negotiated with
brussels we should be negotiating a
veterinary agreement sorting out mutual
recognition for the qualifications of
our professionals so they can travel and
trade with ease across europe we should
be tackling visa problems for our
creative industries accelerating
investment in digital borders and trying
to build more productive relationships
with our key allies
i wish i was surprised mr deputy speaker
that the gracious address did not give
consumers significant new powers to hold
the businesses who aspire to serve them
to account
water bills have rocketed since
privatization sewage spills deliberate
or not are at shocking levels
underlining the insufficient levels of
investment while executive pay and
profits for the often overseas owners
of water companies continue to be too
high and clearly at the expense of
treating water users consumers properly
why don't water companies have to answer
properly to their customers complaints
are at record levels yet ministers
continue to give the boards of water
companies the benefit of the doubt why
don't ministers support the consumers of
water companies to coordinate properly
at each english water company to elect a
representative to the board and to have
the right to sign off the board's
accounts to sign off executive
remuneration and their investment plans
why isn't there action to stop excessive
profits and to stop the diversion of
funds that could support investment to
pay
dividends to shareholders similarly the
shocking level of energy bills only
underlines the lack of agency that
consumers have in the energy markets
even before the current crisis it was
clear big companies dominated the market
too much so new thinking on how to give
consumers more agency in energy markets
in the long term is essential to shape
energy security to shift patterns of
ownership and accelerate that switch to
lower carbon renewable systems indeed
where is the serious plan to tackle the
climate crisis if the government had
backed our plans on this side of the
house we could double our onshore wind
capacity to power an extra 10 million
homes we could back tidal power and we
could triple solar power by 2030 and
accelerate energy uh into insulation to
reduce similarly the bills of working
families and pensioners
and lastly on financial uh
services
it's that where in the last 12 months i
think it's most apparent that ministers
haven't shown enough interest in
consumers british banking is dominated
by four large banks who provide 70
percent of current accounts
even the most generous
think recent measures to boost
competition are having only limited
impact
banks are closing branches fast
increasingly it is mutual and
cooperative financial services that are
having to step in to maintain branches
and support the high street building
societies credit unions and mutual
financial insurers need legislative
reform to enable them to get the capital
they need to invest in new products new
i.t and new markets
one boss of a mutual insurer with
experience in other countries described
the uk at the moment as a uniquely
difficult regulatory environment for
them
and the shocking
attempt last year to demutualize
liverpool victoria
demonstrated the need for legislative
change to strip out the remaining
incentives for boards to try and
demutualize and to give the consumer
owners of those mutuals more powers as
well as the need to address those
capital raising difficulties that many
mutuals have and which have already been
resolved in other countries such as
australia in theory the financial
conduct authority is supposed to stand
up for consumers it didn't do so during
the lv debacle and almost 35 million
pounds of owner's money was wasted as a
result
the fca didn't stand up for british
steel pensioners either and it certainly
didn't during the mutual mini bond
scandal it doesn't have the resources
and it doesn't have the appetite clearly
for really standing up for consumers it
has too many other things to do so i
wonder whether a separate consumer
ombudsman is needed now with the sole
objective of standing up for consumers
with significant information gathering
and class action powers lastly mr deputy
speaker
voters in harrow sadly decided to end my
local party's leadership of harrow
council
we have some work to do as a local party
to understand and crucially face up to
why voters collectively made that
decision
in time there will i'm sure be much for
us to be proud of the council's
actions under labour control
particularly the response to covet
but we do have to confront now the
question as to whether despite cuts in
government funding to harrow council of
over 90 percent whether better council
services could have been provided
and one particular concern locally were
recent revelations that the council had
been hit by fraud media reports
suggesting that up to 2 million pounds
of money that could have been spent
repairing pavements and roads have
disappeared
that is money that local people have
paid out through their council tax and
other tax bills and they have every
reason to be angry about such behavior
to be fair the previous council
leadership did act immediately they
investigated and those responsible have
been sacked the police were called in
and supported as they investigated to
that money taken wrongly needs to be
reclaimed and if prosecutions are
appropriate and why wouldn't they be
that they need to happen i expect the
new council leadership to lead that
charge
poor paul maynard i thank you mr deputy
speaker today pleasure to speak in this
direction to follow the remember for
hara west to always speak i think with
great insight and i found him always
worth listening to i'm sure he would
agree with me that after these local
elections whichever party is represented
when a counselor loses their seat we
should have some sympathy because they
are all whether in harrow or anywhere
else in the country engaged in public
service just like we are and they will
be disappointed that they would have
ceased to serve their public so whether
in harrow or labor law seats or in other
parts of the country when my party last
seats let's just at least at this point
think for those diligent public servants
locally who have lost their chance to
serve
pleasure also to follow the number four
uh waveny a fellow coastal mp nothing he
said in his analysis of his constituents
needs but i disagree with juan sintilla
and he says in repeating many of the
points that he himself has made
it's taken me 12 years to work out that
the best time to speak in the queen
speech debate is on the day of the
debate itself
because actually i get 10 minutes not
just the three you normally get on the
day of the day after the day after that
so i'm going to make the most i think of
my 10 minutes i normally really don't
like the day of the queen speech debate
to me it's a it's a matinee pantomime of
your beef socks often those early
debates from real crammed in here show
the house at its worst in my view and
today it seemed a little so different it
might have been perhaps the
certainly their wattage contribution
from the leader of the opposition i
actually think that is more likely the
seriousness of the time for which we are
confronted whether in the ukraine or
domestically here in our constituencies
as of all the people we represent face
a cost of living crisis a challenge to
their financial security day in day out
at every moment
and
very often i hear the cry from
from politicians from the media from
constituents that what the government is
doing is not enough
i'm not quite sure at the moment what
enough
would actually look like in this regard
government cannot craft a solution where
global costs rise
but no one sees the consequences here in
the uk
but that doesn't mean that nothing can
be done or should be done
the inflationary pressures that we
currently face
are largely external the rising cost of
foreign oil and gas the disruption of
global supply chains caused by cobras
which linger on and reoccur in china
thanks to their code
zero coded strategy
we cannot change china's approach to
coping only harsh economic reality i
think is going to do that
but what does matter is the speed the
agility of our domestic response
here in the uk
and i kindly say to all the mps on my
side of the house gathered here this
evening or one of them
that we have to stop campaigning like
it's 2016.
i start governing like it's 2022 but i
mean the back bench it's not just the
front ventures we have to stop
campaigning like if 2016 start governing
like it's 2022. none of my constituents
who live in eight of the ten poorest
neighborhoods in the country give one
fig for what
box i crossed in a referendum six years
ago they want to know what i and the
government i am supporting are doing to
tackle the cost of living crisis at the
moment
now some argue that the answer to this
is to increase public spending that's
right and center
to put more money into the economy yet
that would have an inflationary impact
in my view the risk of sounding
unquestionably such a right to what i
think is often a rather a leftist
government at times i think i would
argue that we have to drive inflation
out by controlling the money supply not
fuel it by responding to the front pages
of the top-line newspapers this is not
inconsistent with protecting the most
vulnerable in our society nothing will
have a
worse impact on my constituents than
rampaging inflation it homes the most
vulnerable in society it harms the
poorest the most that's why inflation is
our biggest enemy as many today have
said
so i can therefore welcome a number of
the bills
particularly the financial services bill
which is the chance to tackle some of
the small print of the cost of living
crisis in particular i will welcome the
provisions that are contained on access
to cash an issue that i have not shut up
about in this place for the past two
years i will scrutinize the detail and
if i'm not satisfied amendments will go
down equilibrium want to see much faster
action on the regulation buy now pay
later that both i
understand so i've campaigned on for
many years as well i know the
government's consultation closed on the
6th of january they are concentrating
and contemplating what to do next but
things are changing rapidly in this
sector we hear ever more common stories
of people using
buying our payday to products to pay for
groceries
this is no longer about buying
discretionary items
clothing during lockdown this is about
people using buy now pay data for the
essentials for energy for food the
the importance of getting this
regulation in place
is massive and it has to happen now in
my view i also very much spoke to the
pilots the government are introducing on
no interest loans which we're going to
take by the government
on behalf of the government rather i beg
your pardon by fair for all and try and
behold but this has to move so much more
urgently this idea has been political
around government for years now it can't
just be a curiosity for policy wants it
has to be an urgent man
an urgent priority for the government to
help move people away from loan sharks
charging extortionate interest rates no
interest loans have to be the way
forward to that
and i also hope to see interim provision
in this financial services bill to
improve the regulation
of funeral plan providers we've seen the
uh collapse of safer hands i'm sure many
in this chamber have also had contact
from constituents
now got great uncertainty about how
their loved one feels will be paid for
the government has to step in and i'm
not hearing very much from the
government and having learned the
delights of amending government
legislation for the first time in the
last session by trying to amend the
building safety bill i have now got a
taste for it so i'm looking forward to
having a go with the financial services
bill and also the online homes bill
the online safety bill which i'm getting
a bit nervous about
because no one seems to be able to
define harms let me help them by
offering them one definition of harm
which is physical harm
and i want to uh talk in a few minutes
left to me about a campaign by a young
man called zach eagling who has epilepsy
as do i
and
at times uh rather unpleasant and cruel
people seem to think it is a good idea
to send flashing images over social
media that are designed to trick your
epileptic fits in those with epilepsy
um to me that is a form of online harm
who could disagree with that
the scrutiny built the scrutiny
committee who looked at the first draft
bill agreed and argued the clause should
go in so did the law commission there is
not yet a clause in that bill and if
we're struggling to define harm
well at least let's start with physical
harm that can be quantified it could
potentially be fatal to force
an epileptic fit that can occur in any
circumstance where you can't guarantee
what the outcome of it would be
there are other bills i would love to
have seen in this green speech private
member's bills i have booked problems
myself in recent years some of which i
would love to see the abolition of the
house of laws why was that not in the
queen's speech for heaven's sake the
compulsory introduction of the or the uh
optional preferential vote a tentative
step towards proportional representation
not in the queen's speech whatever came
over the government and my favorite
aimed once again at the front bench is
an annual review of ministerial
competence
undertaken by an outside body to assist
the prime minister in making decisions
over who should be appointed for
government i'm sure the mums shot them
within the front range will pass through
flying colors but the time of a cost of
living crisis
where our constituents are under such
immense pressure is incumbent upon the
government to do the very best it can do
to the very best people working on these
intractable and difficult problems it
isn't simply a matter of finding a
switch that i think the member from
bristol lee suggested we can pull all
the switches we like there are some
fundamentals underneath our society that
also have to change and that's what this
party should be doing not looking back
to 2016 but looking forward to a
brighter conservative future thank you
thank you karen smith
speaker and it's interesting to follow
the environment for blackpool north
particularly his comments about epilepsy
i think which were really well made now
we heard earlier in the queen's speech
that the government's priority is to
grow and strengthen the economy which
for me really only highlights the
question of what on earth have they been
doing over the last 12 years why are we
now looking at negative growth why are
we looking at projection of 10 inflation
why are we not now and were we not
before the pandemic more resilient and
able to cope with the pandemic that hit
us why are my constituents wages
stagnating why are they not any better
off and i think the porsche speakers we
have left no more speakers on the
government's benches tonight to defend
the queen's speech says an awful lot too
now as a new mp seven years ago my early
speeches in this place were all about
apprenticeships devolution and the need
for us to work together locally to grow
our local economy but also to share in
the prosperity of what is in bristol a
good strong economy that's with
businesses educationist trade unions and
politicians
that has always been my politics
at this time in 2015 apprenticeships
were a torii flagship policy however we
now know that apprenticeship starts have
declined since 2010 by over nearly
thousand forty one percent
now apprenticeships are so important in
bristol south because
of the uh poor attainment of people into
university
for the businesses the small businesses
that dominate bristol south they're also
really crucial because they are
desperately short of skills and my
constituents are desperately short of
well-paid secure work
apprenticeships are really crucial that
we have a little bit this afternoon
heard about to build in the green jobs
of the future to help us tackle the
climate crisis head-on
why not insulate our homes why not
support those jobs why not save energy
on that demand side rather as we face
that terrible supply-side crisis it
shouldn't be so hard in a prosperous
city like bristol to match the desire
and the needs of business and the
ambition of local people
now in a couple of days time on thursday
mr deputy speaker i will welcome over 50
employers to my sixth jobs and
apprenticeship fair located in the heart
of south bristol at the skills academy i
have led work locally to bring together
a partnership of the college bristol
city council and the department of work
and pensions who are all very dedicated
to offering a better opportunities for
people in south bristol this didn't
happen previously but bringing them all
together has been really successful so
that company
people such as women hill city farm
adult care professional apprenticeships
based in south bristol first bus st
monica's trust and the university of
bristol hospitals trust will all be
there including also one front door and
the national career service to directly
work with the people of south bristol
and match their ambitions with business
needs i wish the government was doing
more to support us because i have
supported the government's ambition
around apprenticeships
representing bristol south when i see
the apprenticeship route offering a way
for our young people to get a chance at
those high-skilled jobs and for those
who've ever even lost out at school to
gain entry-level qualifications this is
particularly also helpful to the health
and care sectors as well as ensuring as
i said earlier that we tackle the
climate crisis through the skilled green
jobs that are out there the government's
failure to address apprenticeships in
the recent skills and post-16 education
act demonstrates not only the lack of
government ambition but shows a sad lack
of ambition for our children and young
people
the queen's speech is a missed
opportunity from a government which has
consistently treated our children and
young people as an after talk which is
even more shocking after what they have
experienced in the pandemic
there are two free apprenticeships
available because the level is not
working as it needs to with too many
small businesses not participating and
fewer level two and three
apprenticeships available
now i do believe as does the labour
party that we should have a stronger
role for colleges providers and local
and regional authorities such as
combined authorities to help with the
development of local skills improvement
we have to have much better careers
face-to-face careers guidance and
meaningful work experience none of that
is in this queen's speech
on devolution which i'm also a strong
supporter of the government has failed
to support the ambition we have for
bristol in the west country and it looks
like once again there is no devolution
really of finance or the power that we
want in the west country we are
continuing to have to bid for small pots
of money in competition with each other
the recent deferment of the portis
headline extension by the government
again i have supported the uh honourable
members tory party locally about that
the way in which the decision has been
taken in whitehall starkly exposes the
fallacy that the government supports
bristol and the west of england
at the other end of the educational
spectrum talking to people in bristol
south last week the crisis in early
years and the lack of support for
parents and providers is deepening the
crisis for cost of living particularly
for families with child care
four out of ten parents are saying that
they had to change their working hours
or leave their jobs due to child care
pressures
conservatives are underfunding the free
so-called free childcare hours mostly
for three and four-year-olds by over two
pound an hour and parents are paying for
this short form
we've heard nothing from the government
again today on how they intend to help
families with these rising costs and
help those people back into the crucial
jobs we need them to do
on multi academy trusts it looks like
uh the government have hinted at changes
to
multi-academy trust there may be a
review now there are real obvious
problems with the maps they are hugely
powerful with the ability to move
resources within trust but no
accountability locally to parents and no
responsibility locally for the outcomes
for those children again i've been
working with government ministers and
the regional schools commissioner to try
and get a look a focus uh around south
brisbane as they have done in plymouth
as a um
from plymouth is is in the chamber to
look at the geographical problems that
children in south bristol are facing and
share that knowledge but the vertical
organization of mats precludes that
happening and that really needs to be
addressed
finally i would like to say something i
would like to see more about my
constituents living in lakeshore the
government are hinting at lease whole
reform but i really want to know what
they are doing to improve leaseholders
rights and make it easier for
leaseholders to manage a changing uh
managing agents of properties
in this parliament we have heard a lot
about the government having fixed social
care
we will see in the next two years that
that fallacy will be exposed the tax
rise has hit with no link to any service
improvements no help for people facing
collapsing care packages and the silent
misery of millions of women particularly
giving and receiving care will not be
helped
the test of this queen's speech for my
constituents in bristol house will be
are they better off in the cost of
living crisis will they have more money
in their pockets
after what we have been through there
should have been more hope more ambition
for fixing our country after the
pandemic so we never have to go into
another situation as unprepared as we
were the last time today we have
received nothing of that assurance
gibson
the queen speech says uk's program for
government offers little comfort to my
constituents in north eastern ireland
and it comes in a context where we have
seen the tory vote across scotland
collapse with the labour revival
amounted nationally to no more than a
lackluster 1.6
increase in first preference votes on
the last council elections in 2017
and its second worst local government
performance since devolution in 1999
i find myself in the odd and
strangely surprising position of
agreeing with the leader of the tories
in scotland the honourable member for
murray a real event and i'm sure he
would agree with that when he said that
the prime minister must and i quote
reflect on a series of disappointing
results for the conservatives across the
uk
the reality is that there's a leadership
crisis for the tories in both london and
in edinburgh and i'll say no more of
that for fear of intruding on private
grief
the prime minister and his cabinet would
also do well to reflect on its deafening
silence over the cost of living crisis
which is hammering households across my
constituency in north ayrshire and aaron
and indeed the whole of the uk
this queen's speech as others have said
before me has indeed been a missed
opportunity the prime minister should
have used this speech to urgently
deliver desperately needed support but
it seems that standing back and
consigning more people to poverty and
hardship is the plan which is
disgraceful
although i do welcome proposals and to
bring forward measures to protect access
to cash in the financial services and
markets bill following huge pressure
from myself and my snp colleagues as
well as consumer organization which and
a range of other stakeholders
but these measures must be meaningful
and they must be fit for purpose and i
look forward to scrutinizing the detail
of these proposals
households are suffering rising food
energy and goods prices record levels of
inflation with brexit at the centre of
much of this all playing a part in this
crisis but the government continues to
downplay the impact brexit is playing in
these challenges
we in the snp have consistently called
for a meaningful package of measures
that would help tackle the cost of
living crisis and put money back into
people's pockets
however this tory government has ignored
these calls with the chancellor
apparently holding off on addressing the
crisis until the budget in autumn
struggling households simply cannot wait
until the autumn as they struggle under
the weight of increasing hardship
we in the snp again call for the uk
government at the very least to convert
the 200 pound energy alone into a more
generous and substantial grant scrap the
aggressive national insurance tax hike
reverse the 1040 pound cut to universal
credit match the scottish child payment
uk wide introduce a real living wage to
boost incomes and reduce or remove
vat on household energy bills and follow
the scottish government's six percent up
rating of benefits
or sitting on their hands from this
prime minister and his chancellor and
indeed the cabinet whilst household
struggle with the soaring cost of living
is unforgivable there is no end in sight
to this crisis so we need action now yet
there is nothing in the queen's speech
to suggest that such action will be
taken
as the bank of england predicts that
inflation is likely to rise to an
eye-watering 10
later this year food and energy price
rises are placing a particularly high
burden on households
despite the fact that the uk has the
highest poverty rates in northwest
europe with 11
11.7 living below the poverty line
things look sadly as though they are set
to get even worse
people are told that work is their best
route out of poverty but the reality is
that in-work poverty is rising
this phenomenon of in-work poverty
should be a contradiction in terms it
should not exist and the fact that it
does is utterly disgraceful
instead of a plan to support households
through this crisis we have a chance of
telling those who are suffering
because of this crisis that it would be
and i quote silly
to introduce measures now to help people
no wonder people are angry and so much
mr deputy speaker for levelling up
alongside this the tory strategy to
undermine devolution continues where
scots are to be punished for not voting
tori by having their parliament
undermined via the orwellian tactic of
introducing the ironically named brexit
freedom's building
much retained eu law is incorporated in
act passed democratically in the
scottish parliament and these must be
respected instead brexit bills will
deliver nothing but a race to the bottom
on so many issues
and i remind the benches opposite and
sadly they are empty but i would remind
them that under rule now be of standing
orders and in accordance with the sewell
convention the uk parliament should not
legislate on devolved matters without
the consent of the scottish parliament
here
this means that
[Music]
this means under the constitutional
arrangements we have the procurement
bill
the trade bill the bill of rights the
leveling up and regeneration bill the
energy security bill the economic crime
and corporate transparency bill the
brexit freedom bill the northern ireland
troubles bill the social security bill
the transport bill the modern slavery
bill and the data reform bill will all
require
the legislative consent of the
democratically elected scottish
parliament and indeed to that
substantial list there may be more to
add
this shows
that the intention of this government is
to trample all over devolution and i
remind them that riding roughshod over
scotland's parliament will simply not be
tolerated and it will not serve them
well yeah
and alongside this
we have an absence in the queen speech
of an employment bill
first promised in 2019 and there is no
animal welfare abroad bill which would
have banned for imports and foie gras
these measures have been quietly dropped
this
queen's speech has been defined not by
action but by complacency and
short-sightedness
scotland needs no more of this
as well as attacks on scotland's
democratically elected parliament set to
continue
our resource budget allocation has been
cut by westminster by 5.2 percent and
the capital budget allocation has been
cut by 9.7 percent in real terms
the snp government is doing what it can
to support households during these
difficult times i could talk about the
bedroom tax being fully mitigated the
council tax mitigation the scottish
child payment being doubled free tuition
free prescriptions free school meals for
all primary school children i could talk
about all these things
but as scotland tries to mitigate the
worst excesses of this tory government
the scottish government is hemmed in by
tory cuts to scotland's budget
and by the lack of power over the full
fiscal levers needed to tackle the
fundamentals of poverty and want in
scotland
a lack of powers for the scottish
government means that we can only really
deal with the symptoms of poverty
inflicted by this tory government not
the deep-rooted causes of inequality in
our society that delivers child poverty
pension of poverty and leaves many
households struggling to make ends meet
the people of scotland understand the
westminster system is broken
it does not serve scotland's needs it
does not serve the people of scotland
and their families interests
today the first minister of scotland
confirmed that a bill for a referendum
on scotland's future will be brought
forward with white papers to be
published in the near future for an
increasing number of people in scotland
this cannot come soon enough because
they agree
scotland deserves better than this
scotland deserves to have its own future
in its own hands scotland deserves
independence
[Music]
thank you
speaker this really does feel like a
queen speech of a government that has
run out of ideas and isn't capable of
dealing with the very serious times that
it finds itself in it's an awful lot of
press releases and no plan we
desperately need a plan i hear obviously
in the queen's speech reference to bills
that might be brought forward to deal
with the cost of living crisis
we don't need parliamentary bills to
drive down people's household bills what
we need is action that could be taken
today the government could decide to use
one of the rare brexit benefits and
reduce vat today it could decide in the
next day or three to do what we have
been calling upon them for some time and
bring about the windfall tax on the
energy companies who've made profits
that are unearned unnecessary unexpected
and use that money to give to people who
desperately need it people across my
constituency in cumbria and across the
rest of the country who literally cannot
afford to put food on the table to pay
the rent to pay the mortgage to pay the
bills no amount of smart alec culture
war ruses will pay anybody's children's
food bills and that is what we see from
a government that is lost touch of what
it is or ever ever had any idea of what
it was to be serious about governing at
a serious time so i just want to talk
specifically as you might imagine mr
deputy speaker about rural communities
and in particular when it comes to
issues through agriculture and housing
there is nothing for us in this queen's
speech nothing that remembers the rural
communities of this country particularly
in england neglected and taken for
granted by this government so very
obviously let's look at farming and
let's also just to plea to all others in
this house now who maybe don't represent
rural constituencies rural communities
matter to you they should matter to you
and they matter for two principal
reasons first of all if you eat you
should be grateful to the farmers who
live in my constituency and indeed yours
mr deputy
speaker who put the food upon our tables
no country that is serious about its own
security will be in any way reckless
about its lack of food security we
should also care though because our
farmers are on the front line in
tackling climate change and in providing
environmental restoration 70 of
england's landmass is farmed and so if
we care about tackling climate change
and the biodiversity crisis and the
reality is the greenest thing any
government can do is to keep britain's
farmers farming because they are the
only people who will make even the
greatest plans in the world come to
fruition because the greatest plans in
the world will remain just plans in a
draw without farmers to actually
introduce them and yet the government is
making an absolute disastrous mess of
the transition from the old farm payment
system to the new uh if you had asked me
a few years ago mr deputy speaker to
list uh potential advantages of the uk
leaving the european union i'd give you
a very small list but on that list would
be being outside the common agricultural
policy and yet again here is a potential
benefit the government has grasped and
they're failing
miserably failing as they botch the
transition from the old basic payment
scheme to the new environmental land
management scheme let me tell you this
and
in my constituency every single farmer
has lost at least five percent and will
this year lose at least 20
of their basic payments that is hundreds
and hundreds of farms all of the farms
that i represent are in that position
and this year 13 1 3 a tiny percentage
but little more than one percent of the
farms i represent will actually be
getting anything from the new
sustainable farm incentive the
government's botching whilst of the new
transition for new scheme is costing
farmers
thousands of pounds a year with nothing
to replace and so what will happen
farmers will either go bust or they will
go backwards we will lose hundreds and
hundreds of small to medium-sized family
farms many of them tenanted right across
our country costing us in biodiversity
costing us in food production and if
they don't go bust they'll go backwards
what i mean by that they'll give up on
doing any environmental work whatsoever
they just have to get more stock because
that's the only way they can keep uh
food upon their own uh table we also see
not just the accidental mistakes the
government's making when it comes to
farm transition but the deliberate ones
through uh landscape recovery and the
local nature recovery schemes part of
those schemes give a clear incentive for
land owners and indeed investment
companies want to become landowners to
get huge tracts of land evict tenant
farmers and then just get massive checks
in the government for doing nothing and
letting those valleys go to seed it is
an outrageous state-sponsored lakeland
clearances and we must not stand for it
and there's nothing in this queen's
speech that gives any clue the
government understands the damage that
they are about to do there is nothing
there for the uplands we think about
upland communities in the lake district
in the dales in places like cornwall and
devon in northumberland in north
yorkshire places that have enormous
cultural significance and yet there is
nothing in the farm payment scheme to
recognize that you know the lake
district and the uh cumbrian uh tourism
economy worth three and a half billion
pounds a year in under normal
circumstances and yet nothing to
compensate the people who create the
backdrop that makes so many people come
to visit our beautiful part of the world
and that's why i'm calling for a
cultural cultural landscape payment as
part of the new farm payment system to
make sure we value and reward our upland
farmers it is absolutely ridiculous
though that we have a farm payment
scheme a government policy an
agricultural policy that is
strategically
as a senior and strategic aim
to reduce our capacity to feed ourselves
to actively take land out of food
production that is not only stupid when
we're trying to protect ourselves in
this case on the face of a grave
international situation it's also
immoral because if you think about it
what that means is that we are now and
increasingly
going to be fishing in markets where
developing countries are seeking their
grain their commodities so we're pushing
up the prices for the poorest people in
the world why because we've got a
wrong-headed farm payment system which
is taking land out of food production
stupid and immoral
and i will move on then to housing and
the impact of the last two years on the
housing crisis in rural communities is
that it has become a catastrophe what we
have is too few houses in our
communities that are lived in
permanently and therefore communities
that die as a consequence during the
pandemic 80 percent of house sales in my
community have gone to the second home
market 80
at the same time we've seen a rise in my
community of 32
and the number of properties have gone
into the holiday let market in devon i
can tell you that meant a 70 reduction
in the uh put in the long-term private
rented sector and so what do those two
things mean when it comes to excessive
second home ownership and no one wants
to be beastly about second homeowners we
want to be generous and welcoming to
people who want to spend their time in
our communities this is nothing personal
but the reality is it has a massive
impact on the communities that i am
privileged to serve in cumbria it means
communities are hollowed out of
full-time uh occupation so you lose the
school you lose the post office you lose
the pub you lose community and when it
comes to the huge and very speedy
transition from a holiday let's or two
vast numbers of holiday let's from
long-term let's what does that mean it
means people who've lived there for
years expelled evicted through section
21 evictions that this government said
that they would abolish but have not
done so that wasn't in the queen's
speech and it should have been and you
see those people ejected from their
communities these are people in work
these are people with children local
schools and yet evicted nowhere else to
go in a place like the lakes or the
dales you're gonna leave all together
uproot your kids
leave your work and that is outrageous
and the impact in our communities is
devastating and the government is doing
pretty much nothing about it there is
one thing in the queen's speech which
has been floated and that is that the
government would borrow something of the
welsh government's proposals to double
council tax on second homes and i
thought great when i read that at first
and now i've seen the detail and it's
rubbish basically what will happen is
that you will have your council tax
doubled if you're a second homeowner who
never ever goes to their home well
that's a tiny minority of second
homeowners and it takes no account of
the fact that 90 of second homes brought
in my constituency are bought for
investment they're then let out for 70
days a year and as a result what are you
oh he's not a second home you're a small
business you're a whole dealer then what
does that mean are you a small business
you pay no council tax you pay no
business rates either and that means
people in kendall in penrith in appleby
and ambleside who are going to food
banks are subsidizing wealthy people
with second third and fourth homes that
is outrageous and this government
despite knowing for sure listening to
their own back benches i'm certain from
rural communities has cho had chosen to
do nothing meaningful to tackle that
outrage a final comment about planning
first of all if you want to tackle the
second home crisis and the whole elect
crisis the affordable housing crisis you
change planning law to make second homes
and holy let's different categories of
planning use so that national parks and
councils could just put a lid on it that
would be the easiest the straightforward
thing to do why has the government not
chosen to do that and again when it
comes to planning we talked about
building more houses the problem is in
places like mine if you build houses
you'll sell them but the difficulty is
we are building for demand we are not
building for need it's time to build for
need i was talking to some of my local
councils earlier today jenny boat pete
enzo sue sanderson who represent grange
and carmel just outside carmel hags lane
38 39 properties only eight of them to
be affordable why because the government
does not give planning authorities the
power to say to developers get knotted
unless you're going to build for local
families for local people and make those
places affordable so i am angry not just
on behalf of my community but
communities across
rural areas of our great country but
there is so little if anything at all
for us in this queen's speech it feels
very much to me looking at it from the
inside in cumbria that this conservative
government is doing to rural communities
here in this decade what a conservative
government did to urban communities in
the north in the 1980s the difference is
margaret thatcher had a plan i'll give
her some due she had a plan but this
government shambolically through neglect
through taking rural communities for
granted is devastating our rural
communities and they will not be excused
for that and they will not get away with
it and you see the results of the
elections last week in cumbria in
somerset and soon i hope in devon we
will see that rural britain will not be
taken for granted
abrahams thank you so much mr deputy
speaker
um
i i wanted to sort of look at the
context for this um queen's speech
we have
escalating poverty there's absolutely no
doubt about this over 14 million people
are living in poverty
um over eight million of those are in uh
in work poverty
four and a half million children uh
living in in poverty again more than
half of those in working families
increasing in pensioner poverty
increasing in
disabled people living in in poverty and
we know as well from the autumn budget
the net effect of the autumn budget and
the spring statement is that we're going
to have 1.3 million more people living
in absolute poverty including 500
000 children so when we're talking about
you know social mobility as many
colleagues have been doing
on the other side social
mobility
educational attainment we need to
recognize this is the context
i i chair a group called the all party
group in health and oral policies and we
had a session with on health
inequalities with professor michael
marmot
a week or so ago and he was describing
how
the uk and the united states are
outliers
in advanced economies in terms of our
life expectancy and our healthy life
expectancy how long we're going to live
in good health
is actually falling
and
we should be really
ashamed
of that but we also had another academic
professor claire bambra who was looking
at the regional impacts
of of this and
has been able to develop some estimates
showing that 13.2 billion pounds a year
uh mr speaker deputy speaker are being
lost because of this differential in in
health so the the lower life expectancy
the lower healthy life expectancy that
we are seeing which is the product the
outcome of the initial inequalities the
structural inequalities that we have had
and which are getting worse and have got
worse under this government this is
contributing uh to that
we the other context um uh mr deputy
speaker is
uh what can we do about it you know
there's we're doing the best that we can
that's absolute rubbish we have the
highest tax burden in 70 years that is a
government choice uh we have escalating
energy costs and food costs again the
government has refused to
accept that they need to do more on this
uh the
opposition parties and as has already
been said chief executives of different
companies tesco was the latest one this
morning which was saying that there
should be a windfall tax which wouldn't
be inflationary
but again the government has refused to
to act no emergency budget no help with
energy bills no scrapping of the
national uh insurance contributions
which is adding to the burden that
people are asking nothing on social
security support for
people in work out of work and
pensioners just three percent and we
know that um uh inflation is currently
at seven is predicted to go to ten by
the end of the end of the year on top of
that we have got a system
there's now decided they're going to
move across people who are on legacy
benefits
through the managed migration process
and that that has to happen in the next
three months the impact of that by the
government's own documents are that
nearly a million more people are going
to be worse off a million more so these
are government choices unfortunately
nothing in terms of bringing forward our
retrofitting our homes so that we can
not just help people with the cost of
their energies but we'll actually reduce
the demand for energy
and nothing in terms of how we're going
to transition to us to support for
businesses
that produce
and stimulate sustainable
green jobs
nothing on tackling the inequality
that's depriving our citizens not just
of opportunities but of living long
healthy lives
and if the health of our children is a
litmus test of how our society is doing
then given we have the highest level of
infant mortality in western europe we
must include we're doing very badly
nothing in the government's on the
government's manifesto pledge to double
research funding to find cures for the
diseases that lead to dementia the most
common cause of death in this country
and what people over 60 dread the most
and nothing on how to correct the
injustice that disabled claimants who've
lost their lives of experience and know
their families and and friends nothing
about an inquiry
that will investigate how that this has
happened
what we do have is more of the same from
the government including stripping
british citizens of their human rights
and protections under the law
we have to see if these privations are
restricted to the many not the few it's
clear that some people believe that they
make laws for others but don't need to
abide by them themselves
and to illustrate the government's
thinking and how they are also
skillfully packaging uh their bills and
in emotional divisive language we have
very helpfully have the brexit freedoms
bill
the government say this is designed to
get rid of red tape things such as those
annoying employment rights that try to
hold abusive employers to account for
those troublesome health and safety
regulations designed to well stop dying
at or from our work
but even more fundamentally mr deputy
speaker where is the legislation
legislation that will build back trust
and confidence in our politics and our
politicians that reinforces politics is
about public service about serving our
communities and our country
not ourselves or our mates that
addresses not just the inequality in
income and wealth but in power to
including in political power
where is the legislation that would put
the ministerial code on a statutory
footing as it is
in the devolved nations
underpinned by the nolan principles of
selflessness integrity objectivity
accountability openness honesty and
leadership that would make lying to this
house and to the people of this country
a sackable offence
where is the legislation that will make
lying about a candidate during an
election in speech in print or online in
order to influence the outcome of that
election an offence
clearly the 1986 representation of the
people act is inadequate to today's
digital age
mr deputy speaker we don't need to see
the results
from the many surveys surveys that show
our citizens don't trust us we just need
to see the turnout at last week's
elections especially in our part of the
world
we have to change the culture of our
politics being an honorable member
whether in this chamber
or
of a local authority should mean
something our constituents must know we
will act with integrity and decency that
will we will be on their side
but with the people allowed to stand as
candidates in last week's elections who
base their campaigns on misogyny racism
division and hate and others dishing out
leaflets
containing trump-esque q anon conspiracy
theories to rebel rows then i'm afraid
we're a long way from where we need to
be
thank you
patrick grady
frequent a coincidence of the queen's
speech with significant electoral or
political developments in scotland over
the last few years and and once again we
meet um in the aftermath of
in the council elections and i'd like to
congratulate all the councillors elected
in glasgow north last thursday
particularly my returning colleagues a
from the snp ken andrew kenny mclean
jackie mclaren alan gow and franny
scally to congratulate lindsay wilson
who ran a fantastic campaign in
particular kelvindale but didn't get the
result she deserved and a particular
mention to counselor abdul bastani who i
have spoken about in this chamber before
abdul arrived in glasgow aged 18 fleeing
for his life from the taliban and 20
years later he's representing his
adopted community of mary hills as a
glasgow city council and joined in the
chambers by glasgow girl councillor rosa
sally the first refugee ever to be
elected anywhere as a councilor in
scotland so when glasgow says it loud
and says it clear that refugees are
welcome here we mean it we elect
refugees as councillors to champion
their local communities and what a
contrast
with the tory government's increasingly
and continued hostile environment for
people who want to make their homes in
the uk a rhetoric that continues in the
queen's speech today and i hope that the
provisions of the anti-refugee
nationality and borders act are
challenged at every turn as the
government seeks to implement them and
constituents in glasgow north who want
to see the government held to account
for its inhumane attitudes to refugees
can rest assured that snp mps will
continue to speak up loudly and clearly
the reality is that the home office is
collapsing under the weight of this
policy and attitude the homes for
ukrainian scheme is moving far too
slowly there are many afghans still want
to come here who can't and now even uk
citizens who just want to go on holiday
are unable to travel because of chaos at
the passport office constituents are
getting in touch on a daily basis and
the government really needs to get a
grip
but the hostile environment is just one
aspect of the increasing divergence
between the politics of westminster and
the policies of the devolved
administrations where the scottish
government is doing everything in its
power to tackle the cost of living
crisis doubling the child payment
increasing social security payments by
six percent this story government is
slashing universal credit and hiking up
national insurance and it's had to be
dragged by immense campaign work across
the country including a vulnerable
friend
for inverness a to a propose in the
queen's speech the social security end
of life bill that will finally allow
people including one of his constituents
a very close friend of mine
uh melanie finley um to access the
benefits they ought to be entitled to
after receiving a terminal diagnosis and
i congratulate her on her bravery in
facing her illness and a fronting up or
helping to front up marie curie's
campaign to make sure that nobody dies
in poverty and why in the 21st century
does any organization have to run the
campaign with such a slogan that is the
divergence um that is the level of
ambition that needs to be tackled and is
not largely missing now from the queen's
speech
that divergence continues in other uh
policy areas the scottish government has
helped to support the refurbishment of
glasgow's borough collection and the
city is becoming ever more popular as a
creation uh for the film industry while
the government embarks on the
privatization of channel 4 which doesn't
cost the tax payer a penny for purely
ideological reasons
and as others have said today the speech
is as noticeable for the bills and
policies it does not contain as much as
those that it does people in glasgow
north want to see the highest standards
of animal welfare applied across these
islands and they'll be disappointed at
the lack of ambition i outlined today
and we need to see more and faster
action to tackle the climate emergency
this time last year the uk government
was boasting about its soft power
superpower global britain as great
status as the host of cop 26 and now
barely a mention
in the in the speech delivered in the
house of lords earlier and the real
agenda of the conservatives is revealed
as they seek to drop net zero action as
quickly as possible real reform of
housing and energy would not only reduce
emissions but it would reduce the cost
of living as well but again such action
is posted missing and that is simply not
good enough the vast majority of
councillors returned in scotland last
week are fully committed to tackling
climate change a message that ministers
should heed and next week and i know
many other colleagues will be joining
constituents in the big plastic count to
help build up a uk-y picture of plastic
waste and the action we and the
government need to take to tackle it
and how we approach climate change also
speaks to how seriously we take our
other international obligations
constituents in glasgow north are
overjoyed at the release of nazanin
zagari radcliff but they have not
forgotten prisoners of conscience and
other human rights defenders who
oppressed and persecuted elsewhere they
want urgent action to secure peace in
the middle east an end to armed sales to
brutal regimes and the restoration of
the 0.7
aids spending target again all points of
ambition that is lacking in the queen's
speech and the documents uh associated
with it instead what we see from this
government is constitutional overreach
more attempts to undermine the
devolution settlement
and the solution to eu legislation and
regulation apparently is yet more
legislation and regulation the biggest
brexit opportunity seems to be an even
greater power grab by the executive than
the promise taking back control for
parliament and many of us will be
keeping a very close eye
on the so-called brexit freedoms bill
what actually we're seeing as my friend
from north ayrshire spoke about is the
queen's speech trying to put into action
the government's muscular unionism
policy the scotland office is going
around boasting that 27 of the 38 bills
will apply across the uk but many of
them
will encroach on devolved areas the tory
government isn't just disrespecting
devolution it seems to forgotten that
devolution exists at all which is
perhaps not a surprise seeing as they
never really supported it in the first
place
and so the divergence on these isles by
the insistence and action of this tory
government continues scotland's
government and parliament are
progressive outward looking
internationalist and folk focused on
helping those who need it most in
challenging times that the tories pursue
their pet obsessions no matter the cost
of the economy society or the
environment so the choice for scotland
is clear our best future our best
opportunity to build a fairer greener
society will be as an independent
country and if the tories are so
convinced of their case for the union
and the level of support for the union
that exists in scotland then they should
be welcoming the opportunity of a
referendum instead of trying to block
one their candidates all stood last week
obsessed with an independence referendum
all of their literature said vote for
the conservatives to stop a referendum
from happening well people didn't vote
for the scottish conservatives and the s
p secured its best local election result
in history so perhaps they should listen
to the message that is being sent by the
voters
the reality is as this queen's speech
has shown every promise made to scotland
in 2014 has been broken scotland was
told in 2014 that if it voted for
independence it would leave the european
union the cost of energy would skyrocket
and supermarket shelves would be empty
well all of those things have happened
the last time i checked scotland didn't
vote for independence but next time it
will that opportunity is coming soon and
when the people of scotland have that
opportunity they will choose an
independent future
matt weston
thank you mr deputy speaker and uh it's
a pleasure to follow um the member for
glasgow uh north um uh and it's can i
just say it was also good earlier to see
um the member for east dalton
dumbartonshire back in her place as well
and also if i can say um hearing the uh
very good maiden speech made by the new
member for south and west just being
reminded of the three
good colleagues that we lost across this
chamber uh david amos of course
yesterday the memorial service for james
brokenshire and of course our own jack
jeromey they're all missed um i was
going to speak about the uh say a few
words about the prime minister but i'll
say that for another day um
just uh touching on a few issues um
there i see there is a higher education
bill being put forward by government and
i'll i will look forward to that um i'm
particularly interested of course in
what has been proposed around the area
of lifelong learning but there are huge
issues across the whole educational
sector
in terms of what is happening in our
schools and in our nurseries the
hemorrhaging of teachers
teaching assistants being lost and our
senior leadership teams
because the budgets aren't there the
pressures are so great and the morale
has absolutely sunk through a lack of
respect i think uh from uk government
the real issue and the priorities that i
think the prime minister is really uh
missing are it must be around the cost
of living that's because i have to say
the prime minister and his chancellor
are really out of touch remember this
was the prime minister who said uh back
in the autumn last year
that any talk of uh inflation or high
inflation was unfounded and i have to
say i hate to say this but i was
actually on bbc coventry and
warwickshire radio back in september
last year and i was actually saying how
concerned i was at that time uh mr
stephanie speak about inflation uh
looking at that time that it might even
go to six percent i think it was only
about three at the time three and a half
but of course now it's run away um
we should have had an emergency uh
budget why do we not because the reality
is that people aren't hurting they're
hurting great about one in seven people
uh our food insecure we have two million
people uh that has been been um
estimated uh who are unable to eat uh
every day we have people reporting to
food banks and i know this having been
to food banks in recent weeks where
people are actually saying i'm sorry but
i will take food that needs cooking i
will only take food that is cold because
we cannot afford to cook it uh that is
the harsh reality of what is going on as
we heard in the um select committee base
base select committee uh from the energy
companies they anticipate 40 of uk
households will be in energy poverty by
the autumn
estimating 2 900 pounds a typical uh
annual bill for households come the
autumn that's why the chief executive of
scottish power was saying just the other
day that he believes that 10 million
homes will need something like a
thousand pounds per household if they
are going to see themselves through
this
crisis this energy crisis of course
there is no money of that skill anything
like that scale coming from the
government we could have that of course
we've been proposing a winful tax um
when you hear mr speaker the figure of
nine billion pounds a quarter of course
that sounds like a good telephone number
it's it's hard for us to get our heads
around that but if i could say the
company i used to work for just 12 years
ago was worth three billion pounds that
was the entire peugeot citroen uh
corporation globally and here we have
nine billion in one quarter it is a huge
amount of money and it could be realized
and it could allay
so much of the financial crisis that is
facing our households up and down our
country look at what the uh
energy cap was in france at four percent
four percent
compared to what we're doing in the uk
how can they do that but we can't
and of course you look at what uh is
being uh talked about in terms of uh
inflation the federal reserve are saying
that this is a really serious problem
that will be sustained i think the bank
of england might be being slightly uh
too optimistic in how they exceed their
forecast
just to talk about the economy the
outlook is really not
good
uh we've seen that that among the g7
countries we will have the worst
economic performance next year um
we also had the worst economic
performance versus 2019 prior to the
pandemic so we are the hardest hit of
all so i'm not sure how that is getting
the big calls right uh i think that's
probably the most uh marked indicator of
how the government and this prime
minister uh got it wrong we've had 15
tax increases since the prime minister
sorry the chancellor took over two years
ago uh what i'd like to have heard in
this queen's speech was about talk about
an industrial strategy addressing the
challenges of our automotive industry
where it's 34 reduction in production
this year last year was not that great
either
we need to address the global supply
chain issues the the issue of
semiconductors but we also need to
quickly get our heads around urgently
get our heads around the need for the
transition to electric uh vehicles and
also hydrogen
motive power sourcing lithium production
uh cheaper energy the gigafactory is
like in coventry that we desperately
need the energy bill i really cannot
believe that we are ignoring like in
warwickshire there are no
onshore
wind termites it's like one of the few
counties that has no wind turbines we
desperately need this it's the cheapest
form of energy and we should be
investing in it then just on housing
i can't believe that we are so way off
the pace against the sort of housing
that we need the mix the volume the fact
that zero carbon homes should have been
built from 2016 under the last labor
government they would have delivered we
would have to do one million zero carbon
homes instead i see houses to this day
just last week with 50 mil of insulation
in those properties 50 mil is nothing
that's why we have the worst housing
stock in europe when it comes to energy
uh inefficiency um
planning well i'd love to see what's
going to come out on that because we had
the nppf in 2012 the localism act the
the public the communities were promised
more say and of course guess what
happened they they didn't so i have
communities up and down my constituency
where there are not there is not the
infrastructure not the bus services the
shops the cycle routes and so on uh to
serve those communities um there's a lot
of other legislation i would love to
touch on such as
the
those
issues
for renters
and
the precarity that they face with the
increase in the private rental market i
want to talk just briefly about the
environment i think a lot of warm words
we have to address that with the onshore
wind energy that i was talking about i
do not believe fracking is the right
solution and it would be
deeply damaging to our environment it is
not necessary and we could have
anticipated uh the the energy shortages
a long time ago by building in
resilience just on justice and police of
course we want safer streets but you
know when we lost 7 000 police uh but
for since 2015 um it was clear what was
going to happen on our streets hence the
rise in knife crime like in my
constituency at work and lemmington rise
in drugs anti-sexual behavior speeding
and so on we need more community support
officers on the street we need the
police hubs to to go with them just on
security um i really do believe that
when it comes to security we should be
talking much more about food security
sourcing more food from the uk um
like in my constituency where we have
some excellent farmers uh but we're
losing land as it's been lost to housing
development but also potentially to
quarries uh just like outside uh barford
um
mr deputy speaker there are however
several omissions uh in
uh the amount of legislation that the
government is uh putting forward i've
only just touched on some of the bills
that are being proposed but i see
there's nothing in terms of
any legislation on business reports and
for example the need really for
legislation on auditing and governance
you think about the four billion pounds
that was lost in covert loans and how
did that happen but because there is no
true oversight we need an audit watchdog
and this is something that the institute
of directors has been uh calling for and
we need um it's really disappointing
that the governance of football has uh
has not been pursued and has been
dropped uh in this queen speech we
desperately need it and clubs like
levington fc and racing club warwick uh
would love to have seen that uh as well
um
mr deputy speaker there is
a lot of legislation being proposed by
the government i really
hope uh that the government uh can
change its priorities because the public
is desperate uh to be heard and for its
needs to be met the cost of living is
such an immediate crisis as is the
climate crisis and an actual fact so
many of these issues are interrelated
and i just fear that without the right
strategies in place like the industrial
strategy that i've been talking about
for housing but also for for the
automotive industry i'm afraid those
priorities will not be met
mr maskel
thank you mr deputy speaker the bare
bones of a list of bills has now been
revealed to us all by a skeleton of what
i call a functioning government build
titles conceal their contents and aim
and this parliament must ensure they
address the community's greatest needs
distracting attention with divisive laws
will not mask the deep inequality that
we're seeing across our communities the
cry of the people we represent and that
cry is getting louder day by day as they
have been plunged into
abject poverty and i therefore i will
reserve judgment before i see the detail
of the bills but i make the case of my
constituents today
in the light of the economic crisis
where the few profit and seriously
profit
many of my constituents are paying and
they seriously pay it should have been a
cost of living speech and we've heard so
many speeches in this place to confirm
that
4.3 million children in poverty 2.1
million pensioners in poverty 11.
million people in our country in poverty
and when you put in housing costs that
rises to 14.5 million
and therefore it should have been a
housing parliament debating housing
measures
for york the measures on housing and
planning will be the most significant
reforming the planning system and giving
residents more involvement
in local development will be important
today in york after 76 years without
having a local plan the inquiry has
commenced we've got a serious housing
crisis but the things i've seen coming
forward from government will not address
those measures as things stand
developers and property tycoons have
found their ways to profit out of
virtually every scheme sucking money and
eventually people out of our communities
while ticking government boxes
many people have nothing left in their
pockets for my constituents in york
housing is the greatest driver of
inequality yet a home could provide the
greatest source of stability and
security the ownership generation may
rest easy but renters are at the mercy
of their landlords extracting every last
penny causing house prices and rents to
explode with ease to profit for some
far too often new build developments and
luxury apartments which no one in my
community can even think of affording
for investors to buy up in london us to
find a bolt hole existing stock is being
now hoovered up with bytolets hmos and
airbnbs
families in york are being priced out of
their community and we are regressing
the council is slow to build and
therefore we have got so many people
tripled since my time in this place now
i'm waiting this housing poverty is
soaring leaseholders are becoming
enslaved renters trapped and more and
more people are being forced to move
away jobs are therefore left vacant with
the local economy and public services
understaffed and suffering it feels
everything is spiraling down and
imploding the system is so broken and
ministers know this but they need to put
in place the frameworks to repair this
something that labor will do if we were
in power right now
local plans are nothing if they are not
prescriptive prescriptive of the tenure
of housing that is needed people and
planning are not two separate entities
they must be together in one united
purpose
let's take short-term holiday let's
airbnbs we must leave this parliament
with regulation and i will do all i can
to try and secure this imagine a
beautiful city like york i have the
privilege of representing it now pray to
the weekend of stag and hens
chasing local families out of our city
center and tourists leaving in disgust
the city then spews out the crowds into
our communities every street fearing the
arrival of a party house an airbnb a
short-term
let
we have seen 1785
[Music]
of them and rising sharply in york alone
in my constituency this is why the
legislation is so crucial
for some
its parties and anti-social behavior
are there all weekend every weekend
these were once family streets they no
longer are
residents living with a misery or
selling up when they they move guess
what happens to their home
then a string of party houses hosting
maybe 30 guests turning up the volume
investors buying up york's housing stock
where local families should reside it's
easy money it denies local people a
chance to live in their city work in
their city contribute to their city
pushing up house market prices even
further in york central alone increased
by 29
since july
2019 it is destroying my communities
these aren't individuals letting out a
spare room but organized businesses that
aren't paying their way not paying
council tax or business rates it is
completely unregulated and that's why
legislation however we can find a way
must address this crisis
and the government need to get a grip on
that and not just register but license
these places regulations for councils to
license all current and future airbnbs
and shortlets and full powers to refuse
them find them for noise like they do in
nice restrictions on ownership how long
you it can be left for like in london
and how a licence can be revoked council
tax doubled like in wales
and a right
to place a blanket ban on certain
communities all with a license fee to
cover costs this must be a major focus
or else my community will be destroyed
not just the communities but the economy
too
we all know that this isn't just about
party homes but landlords are also
converting family homes into hmos
they
and very rapidly then into an airbnb
they should be demanding full planning
with proper community engagement i'll be
interested to see what the government's
proposals are
and then licensed with no weakening of
permitted development rights local
authorities must have the right to
refuse
in some student areas streets no longer
have a mix of residents and communities
are dying better regulation will bring
better stability
as for standards in the private rented
sector i welcome today's announcement to
strengthen the rights of tenants and
ensure better quality safer homes but i
want to see the detail we need
to to up stability of homes we need to
uh sustainability of homes minimum
levels of energy efficiency needs to
rise and that's why labour's programmed
to retrofit 10 million homes is needed
right now
addressing things like infestations and
damp which come across my death so so
often also need to be issues which can
be uh
assessed by by people inspecting these
homes
a register of landlords and inspectorate
and enforcement is needed and if
landlords break the law
they should lose their right to rent
on any of their properties plain and
simple
however you can't talk about standards
if we don't talk about rents
section 21 of the 1988 housing act must
be repealed it is now used widespread as
it enables private landlords to
repossess their properties
from
assured
short tenants without having to
establish fault on the part of the
tenant no fault evictions as seen as a
way of getting more rent from their next
tenant however with rental going through
the roof as
available properties are just
disappearing and house prices
push up
prices are
rising so fast
it means that landlords are just able to
name their price it needs controls rent
controls and local authorities should be
able to demand rent controls in places
where housing costs are out of control
leasehold properties are also dominating
new build leaseholds need protection and
i would say and i agree with the
honourable member who spoke earlier they
need to be
something of the past now paying
extortionate amounts for services which
if needed could be delivered locally for
far less ending the leasehold model is
crucial all of this comes back to
planning and good housing legislation we
must protect our current stock and build
to meet local need
if it is in the hands of this parliament
to stop the extraction model to stop
evictions and exploitation protect the
existing stock and build a new
generation for local people
plain and simple to have a safe and
secure home
that would be a job well done by this
government
but i fear we may not get to that point
as we're seeing at this time
our communities under such pressure
food
energy and now shelter those basic
things that everyone should have as a
right now being stripped away i want to
see government's response in the fine
detail of that legislation and i will be
scrutinizing it because my community
deserves so much better
governments carry a heavy weight in this
parliament and i trust that they will
listen carefully and ensure that our
communities are left stronger
safer and more sustainable thank you
thank you very much catherine west thank
you very much mr deputy speaker and it's
a real delight to follow the member for
york central who i know has such a deep
uh understanding of housing and the
problems that so many of our
constituents face
from the basics around mold and
infestations right through to the
complexities of leasehold properties
cladding and all of that and
it was a very very good speech so thank
you for that
and indeed there are some very good
themes in the queen's speech
the question is going to be on the
detail and how much we managed to
achieve in this parliamentary session
i do welcome
this opportunity uh for the queen's
speech and the jubilee the platinum
jubilee celebrations mr deputy speaker i
don't know if you're going to be at any
street parties but you'd be very welcome
to come along to the cecil park street
party if you're available in the four
day holiday uh no one's mentioned that
today but i think that's um actually
quite it's probably the best thing the
government's done in the last few years
to give us those extra few days to enjoy
it and a bit of a boost for the local
economy
um and a bit of celebration as well that
we've got through a pretty tough time
with kovid
and that we're hopefully at the other
side of that and the other really
positive elements which have a lot of
potential in the queen's speech
are the modern slavery bill which the
member for maidenhead spoke at length
about in her speech
the possibility of civil penalties for
organizations that did not comply with
the modern slavery requirements
um and of course we've also got a lot of
potential with the economic crime and
corporate transparency bill
and hopefully that will contain the long
overdue company's house reform
which we know is key to cracking down on
the kleptocracy which was so
evident
when the
president putin began his terrible
assault on ukraine earlier in the year
i want to focus in my
short remarks
on the context of this queen's speech
coming straight out of an election
period and i wonder if that's why their
benches opposite are completely empty
except for one whip and one front bench
member bit of wind out of the sails
perhaps following the 500 odd losses
at local government level um but who is
to say i'm not sure why it's so empty on
the other side but the context of the
queen's speech is pretty desperate we
are on the verge of a recession
and we cannot afford to be complacent
we want to see an emergency budget as
well as this queen's speech and it was a
little bit um unsure as to whether the
prime minister mentioned that there was
going to be a statement from the
chancellor or whether that was then
ruled out by his spokesperson at number
10 downing street but if anyone can
clarify please do intervene
but
i was surprised also that in the prime
minister's
short words about the queen's speech
peppa pig didn't make um any um
appearance because i thought at one
point with the speed at which he
delivered his his remarks i thought
peppa pig might just accidentally pop
out of his mouth as he was speaking it
felt like one of those speeches i don't
know if anybody else shared the
sentiment listening to how it revved up
and then slowed down again i thought it
could have perhaps gone into that and
speaking of peppa pig um i noticed that
the cbi today has said that
the queen's speech is not good enough or
the measures any of the economic
measures which have been proposed are
not good enough and that is a real pity
because
the chancellor's response during covet
actually was a correct tripartite
response between
government
the cbi and the tuc
sadly the tuc
has severely criticized the queen's
speech for not having an employment bill
where we could address
the lack of security in our workplaces
the vexed issue around flexibility at
work and who should be in work and who
should have the right to work at home
maternity provision pregnancy adoption
provision all those things which we
could have put into that speech to
improve our workplaces and also to
address the issue of retention because
we know a lot of good workplaces do not
know why they can't retain staff so
that's a real missed opportunity
and the other missed opportunity of
course
is on the uh the environment we really
want to be turbo charging the insulation
of all of our homes particularly those
of us who have very very old victorian
stock which is expensive to retrofit but
desperately needs to be tackled
one of the members who spoke earlier
spoke about the failed um green
uh
new deal
in 2010 which was a tragedy and then of
course the second scheme which failed
in after the the 2017 election and time
after time we've had schemes which have
failed if local government and i was
really pleased to hear the member for
newark praising the role of local
government during covet if local
government was just given cash to get
all of their own stock up to scratch we
would be doing a lot for the environment
we've been doing a lot for fuel poverty
and we would be doing a lot um to save
people's bills so it's those sorts of
basic schemes
which in the end cost less because we've
had two failed schemes which cost a lot
but didn't do very much either for the
environment or for the consumer
that would be a real way of getting
things achieved again
on the food poverty side we've heard a
lot of contributions on that what we all
want to see in our constituencies is
fewer cues at food banks
and people being able to afford with
their earnings to work a decent week's
work and be able to put food on the
table i don't know why that is so
difficult to do but i do know that by
the end of the year when inflation hits
10 percent we're going to be seeing even
more people at food banks queuing and
that is not a site that any of us wish
to see that of course will be
exacerbated by the situation of um a
drop by 30
in ukraine's exports particularly
around cooking oil and around wheat
and we know that that is going to
increase
hardship on our tables
and we really need the government to
step in and take responsibility and to
roll out a program that addresses that
lack
we also need to have much more
innovation uh in our industrial strategy
and i was very disappointed to see last
year the government cancelling um the
industrial strategy i think that was
a real missed opportunity
for example manufacturing why don't we
just
fund the manufacturing of more ppe we
know that we need it because we need to
have a stock ready we have plenty of
centres like leicestershire or parts of
london parts of the midlands where we
could just begin that um fund it and
then it would pay for itself over time
you know let's get innovation and let's
have a brexit dividend let's do that and
and be creative
in addition of course we have the
productivity challenge
and this comes back to the fact that we
have far too many people in fe um or who
are in low quality courses in fe because
we still haven't put right the 50 cut to
fee from 2010 and that desperately needs
to be addressed
and
it was good to hear others speaking
about the apprenticeships and the way
that many of the um the apprenticeship
schemes have failed
um
the other point of course is on public
services
and it's really it's essential that we
tackle
the lack of gp
appointments and that we look at the nhs
record waiting lists of for doctors and
nurses we simply do not have enough
health practitioners are working in the
health service
we've been promised mental health a
parity of esteem for mental health for
years and we still haven't got it i
don't believe in this sketch out of
bills but we will continue to keep
fighting for people who have mental
health problems for those to be
considered just as seriously um as
physical health problems the super-sized
classrooms issue
we know that last time labour came in in
1997 it immediately reduced the
classroom size and kids started to learn
better we need to do that now let's not
wait until labor has to come in and do
it again let's just do it now because we
know it works we're still only spending
what we spent per child what we spent in
2010 on education that is holding our
productivity back severely and we need
to address that urgently
and finally victims of crime i'm very
pleased it's mentioned in the queen's
speech but i want to see what that
actually means
far too many victims of crime
not being supported
just getting desperate that our justice
system is not working for them
and i will be following that detail very
closely because we know just one in 35
victims
of rape for example
ends up with a successful charge and
that has absolutely got to stop
my time is up mr deputy speaker but we
can re revisit those issues you're
shaking your head
all i would say in conclusion because i
know that there's one or two more
speakers to come
is to say that we have had a missed
opportunity today
um we've had a very um interesting and
engaging
set of speeches from the government
ventures but perhaps not attached to
what the reality is
in our own constituencies whether it was
the northern ireland protocol which we
had a bit of a debate on whether it's
about apprenticeships and young people
whether it's about manufacturing in some
of our hubs whether it's about the
housing crisis which the member for york
central manager mentioned there are so
many areas where
really it could have been addressed um
by the front bench earlier um on the
government ventures and yet it didn't
seem to occur to the prime minister talk
about the pressing issues and i wonder
in conclusion coming back to my first
point about the empty ventures on the
other side whether that was the
disconnect which did lead to the 500
losses of council seats because in the
end in a democracy if you don't talk
about the issues which matter to working
people you don't end up winning an
election thank you thank you toby
perkins
thank you very much mr deputy speaker
let's start by
passing on the very best wishes of the
people of chesterfield to who to her
majesty the queen who were all very sad
was unable to be able to address us the
first time uh since 1963
uh that uh the remarkable woman has been
unable uh to be here
and i know people will be wishing her
well um it was not just for that reason
a very remarkable speech and also not
just because uh as the honourable among
a friend from honzi uh from holder green
has said the speed at which it was
delivered which suggests to me that the
prime minister when he finally loses
this job that he should have lost
several months ago might be able to be
gainfully employed as a horse racing
commentator
but alongside that
it was remarkable for two things i think
firstly uh the fact that as we were
listening to the government and the
issues that they wanted to address it
was remarkable to think this was the
government responding
to a country they've been running for 12
years
and also that it was so clear that so
many of these issues that are facing
the country are not an accident but are
actually a deliberate result
of the policies that this government has
pursued for the last 12 years
it was a speech simultaneously packed
with
different initiatives and yet at the
same time failing to meet the challenges
uh that the british people are
struggling with uh so much at this
moment and i think it is for precisely
that reason uh that this government
looks so uh exhausted so tawdry and so
uh out of touch but let's have a look at
what this government's priorities will
be i i obtained a copy uh as mr speaker
suggested we should of the gracious
speech
and the government start by claiming
that they will grow and strengthen the
economy and help ease the cost of living
for families on growth this is a
government of high taxation
uh because they are a government of low
growth there are government that have
had low growth during 12 wasted years
they've consistently grown our economy
by less than the previous labor
government in all but one year the
growth under the labor government was um
sorry in all but one year the growth
under this government was less than two
percent under labour two percent growth
was achieved ten years straight so why
should we believe that this is a
government capable of delivering on its
priority to grow the economy on
strengthening the economy the
government's consistent failure to
deliver the brexit they promised means
that our economy is considerably weaker
and less resilient than it was before
the prime minister was elected and on
living and cost of living their refusal
to implement a windfall tax means that
uniquely this government of all the
european government is allowing oil and
gas producing firms to enjoy obscene
profits whilst raising taxes on working
people and we're just two lines in to
the loyal address and already the
government are referring to three areas
to growth to strengthening the economy
and to the cost of living in which they
have indisputably failed but it goes on
mr speaker they claim they will support
the police to make our streets safer but
we have seven thousand fewer police than
we had in 2010 our court backlogs mean
that terrified victims of crime wait
months and even years for their
perpetrators to face justice and the
government were forced to exclude fraud
from their crime stats in order to try
and pretend
that crime was falling just last week i
met a woman in my constituency jane
allen who still mourns the loss of her
brother philip he was murdered by a man
who was
unlicensed after being released from
prison halfway through his sentence the
murderer jordan maltby should have been
housed in an approved premise but none
were available he should have been in
regular contact with probation officers
but he was seen only once in the nine
weeks that he was out he should have
been monitored by police but the demands
on police time meant that that didn't
happen and then in a completely
unprovoked attack he murdered philip
parlin in cold blood outside his house
these government failures to provide the
number of police we need or to properly
fund probation or to address court
delays all mean that under this
government our streets are less safe and
not safer in 2013 there were 634 000
violent offences in england and wales
last year there were
1.78 million violent crimes
1.78 million opportunities
to see the full cost of that failure so
we have a larger population but fewer
police more violent crimes longer court
delays failing probation service and
they want us to believe that this
government is going to make our streets
safer
then the government claim they will fund
the nhs to reduce kobe backlogs and
we'll briefly give way
just on the point of his constituent
jane
and our condolences go to her for her
loss of her brother but would he agree
with me because so many crimes happen by
the same group of people that if you
don't get them the first time
it's just multiplying and that the
failure to actually
bring the charge is making in the first
instance is making it ever so much worse
for more and more victims
absolutely this is this is absolutely
the case and and whether it be that you
have um courts that are uh not seeing
people in time or whether it be courts
that are deciding not to send people to
jail but they really should be doing
because the jails are so overcrowded
giving people shorter sentences um a
whole variety of reasons you know these
violent criminals are making our streets
uh less safe
moving on the government claim they'll
fund the nhs to reduce kobe backlogs
this is the government that caused the
pre-covet backlogs we went into covid
with the biggest waiting times uh since
guess when guess when since the last
time we had a tory government labor left
government with a two-week cancer
guarantee and waiting times below 18
weeks across the country this government
has reduced nhs spending from when they
came in in 2010 to 2019 when the covid
pandemic hit so that britain went from
being in line with european average to a
back marker once again they presided
over an nhs staffing crisis failed to
train enough doctors or nurses
discourage european nurses from helping
out this failure is on their watch i
haven't even got to the end of the first
paragraph of the loyal address mr
speaker and what we have is a government
who ask us to believe that they are the
party to address the very problems that
they have caused and these are not
issues that they inherited but ones
through a decade of austerity through
their failure on brexit and through
their prioritization of culture wars
ahead of the business of government uh
explicitly acknowledge the failure that
12 years of tory rule has led to but we
shouldn't be fooled mr speaker into
believing that this is a government with
a plan to address these failings the
budget showed that a government who's
normalized food bank usage will not be a
government committed to helping people
with the cost of living and it is
remarkable that we heard the prime
minister on his feet today claiming that
the uh we will be getting action on the
cost of living in the coming days only
for treasury sources to be briefing the
chancellor of the exchequer knows
nothing about this and that there are no
plans this is a government who not only
fails to take action on the cost of
living but fails to even agree what the
line is as to when uh they are going to
make different steps they had a choice
about how the global rise in energy
prices could be tackled they could have
chosen to ask the energy companies to
share a little of their grotesque wealth
or they could have asked landlords and
property billionaires to pay a little
more instead the chancellor's eyes fell
as they always do on the working poor
with the british government uniquely
raising tax on working people so this is
a government big on tactics but bereft
of strategy the home secretary wanders
around looking for a culture war to join
while failing to address the issues that
make our streets and indeed our homes
left safe a labour queen's speech would
have contained measures to genuinely
alleviate fuel and food poverty and
supported people with the cost of living
crisis we would have seen a commitment
to an industrial strategy that targeted
the greatest resources on the areas that
need it most and address the ways in
which things like the apprenticeship
levy is failing a labor queen sweet
speech would have recognized that you
can't cure nhs waiting times unless you
resource and value carers in our
community and the overseas workers help
us to allow our elders to grow older in
dignity a labour's queen's speech would
have tackled tax avoidance and non-stop
status which it turns out was the modus
operandi of prominent members of the
cabinet and their families and it would
have rooted out the scandalous wastage
of public money that this government
routinely allows and it would have made
repairing relations with our european
counterparts so that brexit can be a
mutual success a priority rather than
revisiting previous failures as
depressingly it appears this government
is now intending to do this is a
government exhausted of ideas and too
mired in their own disgraces to address
the problems of the nation and it is
well past time for them to be gone and
they've now reached the stage where the
prime minister is so weakened he has to
threaten his own party with an election
if they don't offer him their support
well when that election comes mr deputy
speaker label will be ready for that
election and it can't be a moment too
soon
mr speaker a deputy speaker in fact i
beg to move that this debate be now
adjourned
the question is that the debate be now
adjourn as many left and say i
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
order order
debate to be resumed what day tomorrow
tomorrow
deputy speaker i'd like to move to this
house room now journal the question is
that this house do now adjourn neil
hanvey
thank you mr speaker um i i
want to um
start off by saying
how important or illustrating how
important diagnostics are
and the importance of testing
and i think nothing illustrates that
more clearly than the decision to
discharge elderly people to care homes
without testing now the government
answer that asymptomatic transition
transmission was not understood properly
that doesn't excuse fundamental
and standard infection control measures
which should have been in place
the
prime minister today said in his closing
remarks of concluding remarks to his uh
speech that he wanted to create
high-wage high-skilled jobs that will
drive economic growth across the united
kingdom well i'm going to measure that
sound bite against this government's
performance and track record on the
diagnostic sector in the uk now the
diagnostic
sector should be at the vanguard of the
world's intellectual development but the
evidence does not support the prime
minister's claim that this government
supports the domestic diagnostic sector
i'm going to look at past performance in
the early days of pandemic where we are
presently and also into the future in
terms of the government's strategic plan
and the opportunities it could miss
uh to our share of peril now my interest
in this
is underscored by an nhs career spanning
back uh a quarter of a century and in
the um
in my work infection control and its
management was a staple part of my uh
responsibility and i understand the
really important elements of genomic and
epidemiological surveillance and i first
raised this with the chief medical
officer in july of 2020
and i have rece uh repeatedly explored
testing with the right honourable member
for west suffolk when he was secretary
of state
and i'm i focused particularly on his
exaggerated claims of 99 accuracy of
lateral flow device tests um but my
concerns have always been sincere and
this is not a political um debate i'm
bringing
my very genuine
clinical concerns to the attention of
the government yet again um
and i i am not making a constitutional
point because many of the issues that
i'm going to talk about today are as
true north of the border as they are
south of the border and they are very
very serious now there's an additional
element to my interest in this case and
that was my constituent craig engels who
contacted me um
to tell me about his concern around
his investments in
one of the diagnostic
companies that was contacted by the
government and contracted by the
government to provide lateral flow
devices
and he now and many many others that are
watching this debate feel utterly
betrayed by the government because of
events that i will set out in due course
and the same is true of the diagnostic
sector themselves
one insider told me there is a lot of
acrimony remaining within many uk
companies saying they would not respond
to the uk government if a similar crisis
arose
now i don't believe that they wouldn't i
think that they would um the good will
and trust however has been severely
damaged if not completely broken on that
point of goodwill yes
mr david speaker can i thank the
unconverted the honourable gentleman for
caldey and counting b for bringing this
forward and
does the album ever not agree that the
methods which we were able to rule out
uh the vaccine strategy making uses of
the public facilities and spaces as an
indication of the capacity that already
exists in the nhs and doesn't remember
not agree that the focus and time given
to that successful rollout must be used
to assist the nhs and the ad
and to address the backlog situation and
even better to address the efficient
operation which we believe and i think
our resentment also believes can happen
i thought i thank the lord for that
intervention i think he makes some
really important points there the first
one that i would make and i've paid a
tribute um to uh
the um
uh chair of the vaccines development
task force um previously and i you know
i continued to do that i think there
were also an excellent strategies for
the control of infection in terms of
barriers and mass bearing and the like
but there's a fundamental part of
infection control is that you can't pick
and choose the bits that you do you have
to do them all
and that has been sorely lacking when it
comes to testing it's not been robust
it's been lackluster to say the very
least and it's been oversold and the
point that he makes about the important
role of diagnostics moving the nhs
forward and picking up the backlog is a
really important point i'll touch on
that very briefly at the end this is
such a huge subject i will really
struggle to get everything everything in
but and the points that he make uh makes
are really uh important
so in terms of where we started off from
the operation moonshot was supposed to
build the best of capacity and there was
i think genuine engagement with the
industry and certainly from the
conversations i've had with industry the
uk rapid test consortium was
something that they felt uh and very
keen to progress but that failed
and i understand
the challenge that the government faced
and that i understand the reasons why
they went to the international market to
secure lateral flow devices uh or any
kind of test and what i would say this
is not about bad china or or anything of
that nature whatsoever it's about
fundamentally it's about uk government
decision making and i hate to say this
but it's true but um profiteering
in the sale of those devices now the
reliability and
validity of the results of the lateral
flow devices
has been undermined by various different
assertions and
i i think the government's original
assertion was lateral tests are accurate
and reliable and have extremely low
false positive tests and a specificity
of at least 99.9 percent however in
leaked emails by um the then secretary
of state's adviser ben dyson
he uh cast doubt on this estimating that
as few as 10 uh two to ten percent of
positive results may be accurate in
places with local bid
cases and the government's own
liverpool evaluation conducted by the
university of liverpool found that
lateral flow devices failed to detect
positive
pcr cases in two-fifths of positive
cases
and they also missed a third of um high
viral load and highly infectious cases
as well but through
out that this time the government was
telling everyone that these were
reliable trustworthy tests that we could
depend on i certainly recall one case
where a constituent of mine's daughter
had had multiple lateral fluid device
tests that were negative and it wasn't
until they insisted on getting a pcr
test that they found out that she was
infected and she had infected everyone
around her and that was
a mini cluster that caused great concern
to to them and throughout this time i've
worked with academics and who have been
absolutely fantastic who've written in
the bmj and other respected journals
they have set out these concerns and
they are experts but the government of
that
of that time and i
particularly focus on the secretary of
state for health and social care at the
time didn't listen to those concerns and
didn't modify the message
and lord bethel's
infamous tweet of the 15th of march uh
2021
where he said that omega diagnostics and
more logic were in line for an order of
2 million lateral flow devices per week
by the end of may promising jobs and
security and
those
assertions just didn't
come to fruition like several companies
omega have suffered big losses and had
to make significant changes to their
operations they had to sell their aloe
site and they're looking to divest a
remaining infectious disease portfolio
and as part of the rapid
test consortium the uk government
committed to support the manufacture of
lateral flow devices and other
diagnostic equipment
on the 11th of february 2021 omega
announced they had agreed a contract
with the uk government colin king who
was then the chief executive officer
said we are delighted to formalize our
relationship with uk government to
utilize our latin fluid test production
capacity
to support the covert 19 mass testing
program being rolled out across this
country going on to say that the new
financial year will see this growth
opportunity realize then we'll also see
the full impact of copic 19 antigen
testing and so we are likely to deliver
substantial revenue growth
these are very exciting times for
business and i am delighted that we can
play a part in supporting the uk
government's national effort to control
the spread of coronavirus the herald
newspaper in scotland
headlined jobs boost for scots firma
omega scoops 375 million government
contract to produce instant covered
tests
but none of it
happened none of it happened despite
these promises significant barriers were
put in place and have continued to be
erected to the domestic diagnostic
sector in the case of omega additional
manufacturing capacity was created in
order to meet the demands of the uk
government but the uk government failed
to deliver on the contract and the
promises
and instead of
substantial revenue growth
there the shares in omega diagnostics
lost more than a quarter of their value
when the government pulled the rug from
underneath them
some investors have lost substantial
sums of money on the back of the
promises of the uk government and
announcements on twitter by lord bethel
they feel utterly betrayed and
understandably so and we have a
situation now where the uk government
failed to make
a commitment in full public view and is
now seeking to recover the costs of the
readiness and preparation for that
expansion from companies like omega
despite them doing everything that they
were asked of by the government the uk
government distorted the market with
those decisions so will the minister
commit to review the impact of these
decisions
on
investors and on industry
the
other side of this of course is the
domestic diagnostic sector felt
completely left like down but the
department of health find 3.7 billion to
fast-track innova branded lateral flow
devices with an eye-watering profit
margin to middle men taking a tiny uk
firm run by a property agent and a shoe
rate retailer from 3 500 pounds in debt
to 20 million pounds in profit in a year
and this was all facilitated by an
exceptional usage
authorization from the mhra
more on that in a moment
in contrast uk companies have had to
navigate their way through and overcome
additional regulatory hurdles the
is best summed up by industry body the
association of british health tech
industries which called on the uk health
security agency to remove the confusion
and uncertainty surrounding the
implementation of the coronavirus test
device approval the ctcdta
now cvta is a hurdle that only domestic
producers have to navigate
all of the imported uh
products that i've set out of the
problems and flaws with
through the government's own study have
a free pass they they are not subjected
to cdta it's only the domestic market
that
has to deal with this challenge and so
inventory gene tests are exempted from
cdta putting the domestic diagnostic
sector at significant uh disadvantage
now private feedback from the industry
is that the procurement process suffers
from a lack of progress transparency and
poor communication so will the
government govern the minister please
consider this question why is the uk
government purposely disadvantaging the
domestic diagnostic sector surely there
should be a level playing field
and in a written parliamentary question
to the government uh
in the last session i asked a simple
straightforward question what are the
number and proportion of ppe lateral
flow devices pcr tests and other covert
19 testing equipment that have been
manufactured by uk-based companies the
response was absolutely staggering we
are unable to provide the information
requested for lateral flow devices and
pcr tests other than
another
covert 19 testing equipment as this
information is commercially sensitive
how can a
basic statistic
be commercially
we have to uh move the ten o'clock
adjournment i beg to move that this has
to now occur the question is that this
house do now adjourn
neil hanby please continue your speech
thank you uh mr deputy speaker so how
can such a basic statistic be
commercially sensitive no one is asking
for information about the companies no
one is that i'm certainly not asking for
information about how contracts were
awarded and merely asking
what number of government procured tests
were manufactured not assembled
not put in boxes
were manufactured in the united kingdom
[Music]
and this is a really important uh
point
and now another
tweet from lord bethel going back
further in the 8th of april 2020
we are backing a new business consortium
including the university of oxford
oxford to rapidly develop a homegrown
reliable antibody test kit to determine
whether people have developed immunity
after contacting
the virus
perhaps the
the minister can tell me what the total
amount of the government's investment
has been in the domestic sector and what
has been the success to date
what is the volume of products that has
been made available by surescreen to the
nhs and when will the government invest
on a scale that is necessary to allow
biomedical research to flourish and
prosper and successfully underpin
effective partnerships between business
academia and the nhs now another
important part of this
is biomedical research and
before um
the
um
autumn statement i believe it was it was
a westminster debate looking at the
amrc's proposal for a life sciences
partnership fund
and this was intended to help
charitable
research and sustain it through the
pressures of a drop in covered funding
it was a drop in the ocean for
government it was 300 million pounds
they needed to sustain that research
there was cross-party support
many of the medics that sit on the
government benches were there and spoke
passionately about the need to sustain
uh the research um uh portfolio
the government didn't put i think it was
uh there might have been 10 million in
there i i i
couldn't um say for sure but
that doesn't um
meet the needs of
the research community
and
the academy of medical sciences has
underlined the value of biomedical
research and its importance to the
economy and health of the population
their campaign what it's worth concluded
for every pound that is invested in
medical research
it delivers a return equivalent to 25
pence per year every year thereafter so
you get a full 100 recovery from the
investment within four years and you
continue to accumulate value thereafter
a hundred percent of that investment is
therefore recovered in four short years
the academy of medical sciences are also
calling on the government to invest
three percent of gdp on research and
development and setting 2.4
by 2027 as an intermediate goal so will
the minister
commit to seriously considering this
request
from this important and prestigious
organization
there's one such charity that's working
in the research space
action for
me and they have said that collaborating
with the me community could further
support uk diagnostics research in their
pursuit of tackling long covert and this
is because there are clinical
similarities between long covered and me
and there is a real opportunity to
further research in both fields
so i want to talk about the future
and the rest of the world is planning
for a 10-year strategy
to deal with the nobel virus covered
and its further mutations
the us have effectively cornered the
electoral flow device market from the
east
and that is a very clear explanation is
why as to why we had difficulty in the
winter securing lateral flow devices and
indeed probably pcrs but that's not the
only novel virus that we could
potentially have to deal with
particularly as a result of global
warming and noble virus and variants of
ebola and dengue fever are possible and
so it's really important that we have
the uh
testing diagnostic equipment that is
sensitive to all of these different
eventualities
what we
can't do is ignore surveillance
it must be robust and effective
testing and
surveillance is the answer to protecting
the nation from further lockdowns
and there are two innovative companies
that i've spoken to i won't go into
detail about them at the moment one in
scotland one in england and their
technology
and
their expertise could be lost to the us
because the uk government is dragging
its heels over its support for the
domestic diagnostic sector and those ai
tests are particularly sensitive and
they are able to be tailored to
all of these novel viruses once you have
a profile then you can deploy that
profile
really swiftly
so if there's a new variant you get that
into the system you build up the
sensitivity to it and the tests can be
deployed
but that um
intellectual
property is now
a risk of being
taken out of the country because the us
are very interested in that technology
and it really i think illustrates how
important it is to value
the science community that has got us
out of this really nasty scrape um
so it's clear to industry
that the uk is not preparing for any
future pandemic and and i'm not
convinced that the government has
learned any lessons from the current
pandemic and how they will incorporate
the lessons into the planning for future
pandemics so
i know there is some surveillance that's
happening at the border but it's not
clear to to certainly to me or i think
to any other members what that actually
looks like
the next question is the government uh
considering implementing civil
contingency planning
and attaching that to a ministerial
portfolio with the responsibility to
regularly report back to the house and
indeed to select committee
and our ministers being provided with
civil contingency training and the
decisions that they must take
confidently during any future pandemic
industry is focusing on how focusing on
how to establish a playbook for
recommendations in the case of a future
uk pandemic but the uk government must
pay attention to the industry
industry also hope that the uk
regulations for medical devices and
diagnostic currently in development are
flexible enough to cover emergency
situations so we don't see
a return to these ad hoc uh regulations
such as euas and cdta you know i i
completely um
distorted playing field
these are
damaging
these method method mechanisms and
statutory instruments that put barriers
in the way of the domestic diagnostic
sector are damaging the sector and they
act as a barrier to the uk
diagnostic sector making progress so in
conclusion mr deputy speaker there's a
need to find a way through these
barriers fostering new ways of working
and ultimately finding solutions and
that is surely what we would all want to
see
realizing and releasing the uk's
ambition as a scientific superpower
depends on valuing the scientific
community and the future health of whole
populations both in the uk and abroad
relies on that investment the diagnostic
domestic diagnostic sector is vital to
tackling the nhs backlog as the
honorable gentleman pointed out
some time ago
not just in cancer but in a range of
different diseases and it's important
that we have that capacity
built up and ready to be deployed and
the success of the uk diagnostics
industry is critical to achieving all of
this and there is huge potential for uk
uk companies to break into the
international markets with novel
approaches and new emerging technologies
that will benefit patients at home and
abroad as well as exporting that
intellectual know-how there is no point
in crossing our fingers and hoping that
covert has gone away there are new
variants lurking in the background and
they could strike at any time and we
must have the diagnostic capacity to be
able to
almost immediately switch on both
genomic and epidemiological surveillance
so um i i thank you mr dick thank you
very much minister
thank you mr deputy speaker and uh could
i just start by congratulating and
thanking other members for coding
columbia for securing this important
debate and putting on the record some
very very serious points which i have
listened to and will read with great
interest and can i just also pay tribute
to his own personal experience uh as a
very um respected
uh
professional clinician in the fields of
oncology and adolescent cancer in
particular and i as someone who has
brought a different expertise to this
house it's hugely valuable and i really
welcome his uh input i'm grateful for
the opportunity to respond on behalf of
the government i think actually the
points he's made are probably better
answered really by somebody from the
department of health and social care but
i will raise the points he's made
with them in particular some very
important points about infection control
in the new post-pandemic landscape
and
the points he's made about
the importance of learning the lessons
from the pandemic procurement emergency
for that was what it was and the lessons
for us going forwards in terms of a
sustainable and vibrant diagnostics
sector and the concerns he raised on
behalf of his constituent craig uh
engels i think he said in terms of the
investments
um the issues around omega the
reliability of the natural flow test in
particular
and the new pathogens and the point that
the honourable member for strength has
made i think he's well made and
belfast university in northern ireland
is a diagnostics powerhouse in fact and
uh
i'm very well cited on that in the heart
of our science superpower and innovation
uh plans and i'm looking forward to
revisiting belfast to see that work
um
mr speaker in the uh three minutes i
have i can't deal with all the points
that have been made but i will pick up
the specific questions the honourable
members
raised and write to him uh with an
answer i think it's worth just saying
that um the kobe pandemic was the most
extraordinary unprecedented uh emergency
that we faced the first pandemic we
faced as a generation and
if you cast your mind back to
uh 20
20
i got into a hot past
i won't detain the house unnecessarily
but that means i can
i don't need to uh
rush quite in the way that i might uh
but we if we cast our minds back to um
february january february 2020 uh
the truth is um we were confronting
completely unprecedented national
decisions and emergencies government was
there was no playbook for this and i say
that as somebody who
sadly i wasn't able to bring my
expertise in the sector to government at
the time i was liberated of the burden
of office mr navy speaker on february
the 13th
the valentine's day reshuffle in fact my
last government role was to attend the
first cobra meeting
on what was then called the virus
emergency yes a happy giveaway
i think in the midst of a given way i i
think one observation that i made and i
i may be professionally uh slanted in
this but one of the observations i made
was that we have lots of um
very academic academics uh who were
involved in the decision making at cobra
but there are
extremely capable and experienced senior
nurses and emergency clinicians who deal
with major incidents day in day out and
they are the ones who understand how to
run an uh an emergency and they are the
ones who understand where the gaps could
be uh and i would just make this very
gentle suggestion around i i have a a
bit of a professional hero louise boden
who was chief nurse at ucla and uh got
us through the seven seven uh bombs and
also the adam duncan pub bomb
unfortunately i wasn't
going duty as site manager for both of
those uh and it wasn't very pleasant but
when you have somebody of that
capability i would suggest that would
the government consider having somebody
with that major incident experience in
the room when they're planning these
things in future
well the owner general makes an
important point and um
uh
look i don't think he'd expect me given
that i wasn't the minister at the time
uh sadly i would have loved to have been
but i mean i don't think it's a state
secret to say that um clearly there were
mistakes made in that national emergency
and that's why there is a proper and
inquire full inquiry and i think uh he's
made some important points that need to
be picked up but i don't think he'd
expect me to give a running commentary
here on those decisions that were taken
but he's raised some really important
points if we cast our minds back mr
every speaker you'll remember the
there was a two or three week period
where we were worried that the lack of
ventilators would be the great crisis
there was a national ventilator
challenge
and
innovative groups all around the country
were stood up to try and design
ventilators engineers worked out how you
could i mean all of that happened in
very fast order and there are all sorts
of uh issues raised procurements uh
flagged that in the end we didn't need
so i mean i don't think anyone would say
that it was a seamless process it was a
national emergency and there are clearly
many lessons uh to learn
um
i i just wanted to deal with the
i think the sort of bigger points that
he's made and i'll pick up perhaps the
specifics in detail in a written reply
um but as
former minister for life science i would
just make this observation that one of
the things the pandemic revealed
is that things that we've done seven
eight years earlier in the coalition
um
paid uh not just the four times uh forex
return on investment which is
traditional in this sector but uh many
many times over and the truth is the
reason we were able to sequence the
covid virus so fast was because of the
launching of the genomics program which
i was very proud to have led back in the
coalition
the accelerated access review we put in
place the parallel approvals to process
with the mhra the early access to
medicine scheme uh the setting up of
vmick which
myself and john bell in 2016 suggested
would be a sensible piece of
foresighting to invest in vaccine
manufacturing it was clearly going to
change we had no idea of course there
would be a pandemic which meant that
that facility was suddenly incredibly
important and urgent for us to have and
the establishment of nhs digital i think
one of the lessons of the pandemic
was the importance of really good data
and the importance of having national
data sets but also local data sets and
as an mp in norfolk in my constituency i
remember being frustrated that we didn't
really have the granularity of data or
the ability to do public health by
cities districts it was done by big
clumsy government regions and i think
there's all sorts of lessons
in there about how in an emergency yes
it requires national implementation and
measures it also requires a subtlety of
local control and empowering the local
experts on the ground uh who
are best equipped to work out how to
contain and to
control but i wanted really to focus
where i can add perhaps most value to
this debate in the important points he's
made about the importance of the
diagnostics industry and i
i think one of the
uh great um lessons of the pandemic
actually
which has absolutely been taken to the
heart of government is that
we need to recognize that
globalization is going to drive more and
more infectious disease challenges and i
mean god forbid we have another pandemic
of this type mr every speaker but i
think you only have to look at the last
10 15 years we've had zika we've had
ebola we've had kovid
it is very likely that we will see more
of these hopefully local regional but
potentially if we don't if we're not
ready to contain them uh global
outbreaks solve disease and
globalization
will drive the release of new pathogens
and that's why pathogen detection is one
of the technologies that i'm putting at
the heart of our
three-year plan going forward and indeed
we're investing in
and i'm working with the chief scientist
separating balance on how we can make
sure that we harness our leadership in
genomics for broader pathogen detection
across animal plant and human health and
make sure that we've built off the back
of the pandemic that network uh but he
makes a more specific point as well
which is that
in the
both the health care system the nhs here
the care system but also in the life
science industry diagnostics has really
for years i said this to someone who
spent 15 years in the sector before
coming to parliament it was always
slightly the poor relation of the sector
drug discovery the pharmaceutical sector
tended to raise the big money and have
the
higher profile but in fact it's the
diagnostics that the pandemic revealed
are absolutely key if you really want to
get on top of the disease but also
uh the uh
the life science industry is moving to
recognize that
actually if you want to
deliver real value and if you want to
reduce the cost of disease which is the
real key to the economy and to the
health system then we need to build
diagnosis in much earlier and that's
both
if i can if i may call it basic
diagnosis of
easily detectable and treatable diseases
but also the
deeper science of longer term diagnosis
of tomorrow's conditions and that's why
in the life science vision that we set
out last year the update to our life
science industrial strategy this next 10
years we've insisted on closing that gap
between the traditional dichotomy
government where my department base
sponsors the research and dh does the
procurement and the licensing and the
approvals to try and build to a much
more integrated model where we focus on
diseases in places and the patient
pathway and bring diagnosis treatment
prevention together around those eight
disease missions and one of the things i
hope and
intend for that to do is to put the
diagnostics industry right at the heart
of those missions so that uh instead of
being traditionally the dancers
industries tend to be the black box that
sits on the hospital uh ward uh these
days it's becoming absolutely integral
to the life science industry working out
how to treat uh disease and how to
understand and detect so i think those
missions are
completely key and
to reassure the honourable gentleman and
other colleagues
here this evening we are investing
heavily uh in this next phase
in both the mrna technologies that are
absolutely key to the next phase of
detection and diagnosis the new
treatments
vmic actually the vaccine manufacturing
innovation center which we set up as an
academic unit to work on future
vaccine manufacturing technologies
suddenly became during the pandemic an
urgent facility for onshoring and so i'm
pleased actually that we have
transferred vmick into the hands of
catalant a world leader in mrna
diagnostics and therapeutics and
treatments so we have established a much
more robust national supply chain
for both flu and other respiratory
diseases and other pathogens so i do
think many of the lessons have been
learned
but there is more to do obviously and
we've set out in our latest life science
vision an 8 billion pound
commitment to research across
mrc deep research on my side as it were
of the portfolio as minister of bayes
and uh four and a four or four and a
half billion into dh and the national
institute for health research
the nihr about a billion a year is the
sort of engine of research under the nhs
and at its heart crucially we've said
that the diagnostics
piece has got to be absolutely central
to that landscape and that's both
the
influenza and other respiratory pathogen
detection but also the molecular
diagnostics the biomarkers the genomic
insights into disease because the truth
is the nhs is a huge procure daily as he
knows the only gentleman knows very well
of blood tests for individual conditions
but if we properly integrate that then
we will be building up a database of
deep expertise in biomarkers in
understanding
what are really the early detect the
early signals of disease and we can
harness that to make the nhs much more
of a diagnostics research engine and
those missions the eight missions eight
diseases
the dream the aim is that we'll then be
able to mobilize patients
much more quickly through digital
technologies into trials patients
through charities can enroll in clinical
research and using that spine of biobank
and the
molecular diagnostics piece we can start
to give industry much quicker access to
the patients who are on the front line
of the conditions that we need to treat
and that i think should drive a virtuous
circle in which we detect earlier treat
earlier attract investment and it
ultimately as the honourable member says
we move from a paradigm where the nhs
under cost pressures is a low price and
often late procurer to a scenario in
which the nhs doesn't have to be a high
price payer because it's giving industry
the even more valuable thing which is
access to patients and charities and
disease and patient consent for research
and the nhs role in this sector is as a
research engine and i've been very clear
to industry we will never in a publicly
funded health care system be the highest
price payer
you wouldn't expect us to be but the
promise i can make you is that we will
move heaven and earth to be an earlier
adopter an earlier tester the best place
in the world to come and test diagnose
your new treatments uh get the data on
which patients they work in and then you
can use that to go around the world and
sell to other countries and i think that
is the vision really of the nhs as a
21st century research engine i'll
happily give away
and thank myself for giving away mr you
early on and uh
referred to queen's university of
belfast and i really particular interest
in being there and involved with them
is there any way that you can maybe
indicate that at queen's university in
belfast or any other universities in in
northern ireland have been involved in
this type of research and partnership
it's so important to take advantage of
all that
massive amount of of knowledge that
there is in that sector
yes the honourable gentleman does make a
uh really important point invites me to
um
to signal again my support for what's
going on there and if you look at the
council outcomes in
northern ireland
the truth is that the queen's university
team we've been working on biomarkers
earlier detection
have ended up driving
not just investment but also much
quicker much better
outcomes for the people of northern
ireland and that that is the
uh the real power of this sector is that
it delivers better health care for
everybody in the values of the nhs but
also attracts investment and drives
industry and i
would go so far as to say that in the
new landscape we will see companies like
randox
developing very affordable
consumer diagnostics kits that can help
drive early detection
building onto a digital interface and we
can then help support patients to get
into trials earlier and to drive that
research medicine piece and i think
belfast normally is actually on the
front line of that
i perhaps just close by just
highlighting
i'm really grateful and it's been an
excellent debate this evening um
in york we we had a company which was
developing um aptmas in order to be used
in the diagnostic process
and
government didn't have a grip on the
governance and the understanding of the
capability
of what can be produced and the quality
that that would match and therefore
how is that mapping process being done
to ensure that every part of the
manufacturing process is brought
together
well the honourable lady not for the
first time makes a really important
point and not being a minister in dh
department of health and social care i
better defer to them on where they are
in terms of that specific mapping point
in terms of
um
my responsibilities at bayes we are as i
think she knows
very carefully looking to grow the
innovation economy by mapping the
clusters of expertise around the country
including bio yorkshire which i came up
to visit recently
and to make sure that we are aware of
and supporting those clusters of
research around the country and i would
just at this point
as soon as i've been invited to comment
on other geographies highlight i mean
how proud i was that actually the
norwich research park was the first
place in the country to establish a
local testing facility and the local
testing infrastructure to process it and
i think one of things the pandemic
revealed is that whether it was on test
and trace or data or local epidemic uh
local epidemiological control the best
people the people on the ground locally
to get on top of it and i think
one of the lessons of the pandemic is
yes you need strong national leadership
but you also need to free up and trust
the clinical and professional judgment
of people uh on the ground
let me just highlight because i think
for the record it's important just to
speak to the scale of the diagnostics
challenge of the pandemic at peak over
700 000 pcr tests and 74 000 genomic
sequences were done daily
so this has been the most extraordinary
turbo charging of our diagnostics
infrastructure and
um the you know i think everyone is
aware of what we owe the diagnostics
industry which um needs to be put on the
record but also that that infrastructure
must be maintained for future events and
i would also just
uh highlight that the genomic sequencing
technology has been completely
fundamental to this the groundbreaking
analysis of the combined sars covert two
genomic sequences and the
epidemiological data has supported the
uploading of 2.7 million of the 10.7
million genomes in gsa the global
initiative on
sharing avian influenza data so we are
leaders because that geological
investment we're now leaders in the
global networks for genomic sequencing
and over 2 billion lateral flow tests
have been provided across the uk uh
i'm conscious of the time uh mr everly
speaker um i think with the permission
of the house i'll deal with the detailed
questions the honourable members raise
but i hope i've reassured colleagues
that we've absolutely learned the lesson
that this diagnostics industry is never
again the poor relation that emergencies
require us to learn the lessons we won't
have got everything right that official
inquiry is important uh i'd like to take
the politics out of it make sure that
the clinical lessons are learned but i
can assure him that we are determined to
make sure this industry is put
uh four square at the heart of our life
science vision going forward
the question is that this house do now
adjourn as many of that people
now i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it
order
order
you